SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE L. MEMBERS- WE
CAN SEE- LET'S SEE WE HAVE-
CALL. CHAU GOOD MORE AND
WELCOME TO THE SHOW ADVICE SAY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE
HEARING. WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THREE OUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. CERTAINLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN PERSON. I'D LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYONE TO MAINTAIN PROPER
MASK USAGE AT ALL TIMES. PLEASE
DO NOT REMOVE OR LOWER YOUR
MASK WHEN SPEAKING WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COOPERATION.
TODAY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMUM
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND ELEVEN
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA. SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACE. THERE ARE
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE IN THIS ROOM. I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL. PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. RIGHT. SO
YOU CAN ACCEPT HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU'RE DONE TEST A RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
RECENTLY WE EXPERIENCED
DISRUPTIONS. INCIDENTS IN
LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS ANY
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED- WE WILL GIVE ONE
MORNING AND THEN ASK THE
SERGEANTS TO ESCORT YOU OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WORST WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR WITNESSES VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM- WHICH IS
pWELL AS THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS YEAH THOSE DEALS
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS. WE
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED.
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY IN THE
BILL. CALL IN NUMBERS FOR THIS
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN SO AGAIN THAT'S. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO AGAIN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THESE NUMBERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. JUST SEARCH FOR C.
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY-
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND YOU'LL
FIND IT. AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. YOU'RE CALLING AND
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. ARE YOUR
TESTIFYING IS BEGINNING THEIR
BILL PRESENTATION SO DIAL IN AT
THAT TIME. WE'RE GOING TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT- PEOPLE ARE
ON THE LINE IN TIME TO TESTIFY.
ALL FROM TESTIMONY WILL BE
TAKEN TOGETHER AFTER BOTH SIDES
PRIMARY WITNESSES HAVE
PRESENTED. SO I'LL BE CALLING
FOR BOTH THE OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES AT
THE SAME TIME. AFTER BOTH OF
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES HAVE
SPOKEN. YOU'RE CALLING AND
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MOOD MOOD
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED IF YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST BILL YOU
WILL REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE
AND WILL NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF
UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE. AT.
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE.
THREE NINE SIX FIVE THAT'S.
THREE NINE SIX FIVE AND
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LET LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AND I READ
ALL OF THOSE- THAT COMMAND.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. I WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH AS OUR NEW VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY TO THE
COMMITTEE AT OUR FIRST. BILL
HEARING AND WELCOME BACK ALL
THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
ANOTHER YEAR ES TìM. WE ALSO
ADOPTER COMMITTEE REELS TODAY
FIFTEEN BILLS WILL BE HEARD SIX
THANK GOD ARE PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. IN FAIRNESS TO
EVERYONE WILL NEED TO BE
ESPECIALLY STRICT ON THE TIME
LIMITS. ANOTHER COMMITTEE WILL
BE USING THIS ROOM AFTER US
THIS AFTERNOON AND THERE HAS TO
BE TIME FOR CLEANING. TESTIMONY
IS A LITTLE LIMITED TO FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH SIDE OF
THE L. AND I WILL BE TIME.
AFTER THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY
I WILL FIRST ASK FOR SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM. THIS IS
CONTRADICTORY TO WHAT ISIS WHAT
THE- ALL RIGHT WELL FIRST
ACTIVE SUPPORT CARD- WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM AND THEN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS DO THE SAME
FOR THE OPPOSITION. AT ALL I
SEE AND THEN THE PHONE
TESTIMONY ONLY WILL BE COMBINED
FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
SO IF YOU'RE TESTIFYING BY
PHONE MAKE SURE YOU SAY YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. SO WE'LL
DO. AFTER THE MAIN SPEAKERS
SPEAK WE'LL HEAR FROM PEOPLE
ARE IN THE ROOM OR REMOTE AT
THE REMOTE STATION- FOR SUPPORT
THEN AFTER THE OP MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL DO
THE SAME FOR OPPOSITION THEN
FOR THE PHONE FOLKS WILL ASK
YOU FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
AFTER BOTH OF THOSE HAVE
OCCURRED I GOT THAT RIGHT OKAY.
ALL ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL
BE LIMITED TO PLEASE STATE
THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION. AND IF
THEY REPRESENT ONE AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK YOU-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL TO ESTABLISH QUORUM. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM. DR CORK HERE AFTER WORK
HERE. VICE CHAIR SMITH HERE
MISTER SMITH IS HERE. DOCTOR
UNLESS YOU'RE HERE. I CAN'T
HEAR. DALY HERE. CRISTINA
GARCIA. HOLDEN MATHIS WE'RE
HERE WHAT IT SAID SHE WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU- LET ME
APOLOGIZE I WASN'T HERE AT MY
USUAL PROMPT TIME THAT I HAD TO
BE IN APPROPRIATIONS TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM. I AM VOTE FOR
A BILL. BUT NOW WE WILL ADOPT
THE COMMITTEE RULES ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE
RULES BEFORE WE START. ALL
RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE COMMITTEE RULES. THIS
IS ON THE MOTION TO ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES WORK YES
PORTEUS SMITH YES SMITH YES I
DON'T BELONG AYE ARAMBULA AYE
BARRICADE HAND HOW CAN I DALY
HI DALY I. GARCIA I HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE AYE MATHIS MATHIS I
WANTED TO G. SO THAT'S OUT WE
HAVE ADOPTED THE COMMITTEE
RULES GREAT AND THANK YOU ALL
FOR ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE-
YOU KNOW I GET MY MIND CHANGE
SOMETIMES WHEN I HEAR THE- THE
TESTIMONY. AND SO I REALLY
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT FOR ALL
OF US TO BE HERE AS MUCH AS WE
CAN- IT BOTH AS A COURTESY TO
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE. WORKED FOR
HOURS ON THE PRESENTATION AND
ALSO JUST TO. I GET A FULL HE
GIVE A FULL HEARING AND BE
PREPARED- WHEN THINGS HAPPEN
THAT. THAT SURPRISE YOU TO- TO
CHANGE YOUR MIND I KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS TO ME. SO WE'VE DONE
THE COMMITTEE HEARING AND
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT'S ALL
DONE- SO THE NEXT THING IS AB
ONE CHRIS NOW WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR HURDLE LATER BECAUSE SHE'S
PART OF THE COMMITTEE OR- HOW
WE HAVEN'T DONE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR I'M SORRY. THIS IS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
ITEM TEN WHICH IS AB THREE
THREE TO ITEM ELEVEN AB FOUR
FOUR ZERO ITEM TWELVE. SIX NINE
EIGHTY SIX NINE EIGHT ITEM
FOURTEEN AB TEN TWENTY FOUR AND
THEY ALL ARE DO PASSED TO RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE ITEM THIRTEEN
IT'S AB EIGHT EIGHTEEN THAT IS
DUE PASSED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ADD ON ITEM FIFTEEN
IT'S AB TWELVE NINETY EIGHT AND
THAT IS DO YOU PASS AND ROUTE
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE WITH A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. QUIRK HIGH COURT HI
SMITH. SMITHII ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I'D BARRICADE HAN.
OKAY HAD HI DALLY. DALLI I.
GARCIA S. CI HOLDEN. HOLDEN I
MATHIS. MATH AYE WHAT I TO G.
OKAY CONSENT CALENDARS OUT OKAY
SO USUALLY WE DELAY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS UNTIL LATER HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANT NATURE
OF AB ONE. AND THE FACT THAT IT
WAS ALREADY UP PRIOR- I WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR THAT ONE FIRST-
YES PLEASE AND FOR THOSE
PRESENTING FROM THE COMMITTEE
IF YOU CAN GO UP TO THE
LECTERN. OF RABBIT THAT WAY YOU
CAN SEE ALL OF US AT ONCE AND-
IT'S EASY FOR THE TV TO SEE YOU
AS WELL SO. ALL RIGHT- MADAM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE- WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU DR CORK
AND MEMBERS I'M HERE 2% AB ONE
I LIKE TO THINK THAT IT'S THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY FOR THE
ASSEMBLY I DON'T KNOW THAT
EVERYONE AGREES WITH ME- BUT AN
IMPORTANT BILL THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR YEARS. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN RACINE A
WIDE RANGE OF ISSUES WITH THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE TSC INCLUDE
AN EXTREMELY LONG PERMIT
PROCESS TIMES. POINT FOR SPENT
THE LATE SITES REMEDIATION AND
FAILURE TO RESPOND TO PUBLIC
CONCERNS. WE HAVE MADE NUMEROUS
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS OVER THE
YEARS I TO IMPROVE DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THE TNC. BUT
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE
EITHER VETO TO SUCH EFFORTS ARE
**** TO HOLD OFF ON INTERNAL
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE. THE
DEPARTMENT WERE UNDER WAY. OUR
FIRST NONE OF THESE A HAVE. IN
SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVE TO ITS
OPERATIONS WHICH IS MY LAST
YEAR WE INTRODUCED AND PASSED
AB NINE NINE FIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE GOVERNOR
VETOED AB NINE NINE FIVE. I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE TO
FURTHER FISCAL FOR FURTHER
FISCAL RESOURCES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. WE'VE INTRODUCED AB
ONE WITH THE SAME IDENTICAL
LANGUAGE LAST YEAR SYNDICATE
OUR COMMITMENT TO THE REFORMS
WE NEGOTIATED AS A BASELINE FOR
NEGOTIATIONS. AB ONE STARTS
HIGH LEVEL ACCESS TO RESET THE
TNC INTO DEPARTMENT THAT IS
MORE TRANSPARENT AND
ACCOUNTABLE. THE BILL MAKES
FOUR CATEGORIES THE PARTY GOT
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES THAT
IMPLEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL TO
IMPROVE DGSE. NUMBER ONE IT
CREATES A BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY WHICH IS A
POLICY SAID IN A PRIMITIVE
HILLS BODY L. CONSIST OF FIVE
MEMBERS. NUMBER TWO TAKES
ACTION TO HELP REFOCUS DGSE ON
ITS CORE. MISSION CRITICAL
RESPONSIBILITIES OF PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC AND THE ENVIRONMENT
FROM TOXIC SUBSTANCES. NUMBER
THREE IT REESTABLISHES THAT THE
TASK FORCE TO SET UP A PATHWAY
TO VALIDATE THE TACC STRUCTURE
AND IDENTIFY FUNDING STRUCTURE
THAT WOULD PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
TO CARRY OUT ITS MANDATE.
NUMBER FOUR MAKE STATUTORY
CHANGES TO IMPROVE AND SPEED UP
PERMITTING PROCESS THIS. THAT
ALSO ENSURES PROPER FINANCIAL
ASSURANCES ARE IN PLACE. I DO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS BEFORE THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR THAT ASPECT
THAT MANY OF THE ELEMENTS OF AB
ONE BUT AS IDENTIFIED IN THE
ANALYSIS THERE ARE STILL
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES.
ADMINISTRATION IS CURRENTLY
ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE NEGOTIATIONS TO
WORK THROUGH THESE DIFFERENCES
I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL GET
TO A LOT OF COMMON GROUND AND
TO- TO THE SAME PAGE IN THE
NEAR FUTURE. THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS ALSO PROVIDED THE
LEGISLATURE WITH INFORMATION
UNDER FISCAL SHORTFALLS
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR TWO FOR. THIRTY TWO
YEARS AND ARE APPRECIATIVE OF
THIS INFORMATION. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS I'M HOPEFUL
THAT WE FINALLY CAN GET
SIGNIFICANT EVENT STARTS
IMPROVING DGSE AND PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH. THIS BILL WILL
NOT SOLVE ALL OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT THAT'LL
HELP PLACE THE TO SEE A MORE
SOLID FISCAL GROUND. I TO
ENSURE COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE- MY
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN A POSTER
TILE ON TOXICS FOR A WHILE
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT EXCITED
THOUGHT THE ONLY THING PLAGUING
US AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE DO NOT HAVE ANYMORE
EXCEPT IN THE FUTURE WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
WILL. I THANK. MATT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I TO SAY THE- THIS IS
EVEN IF THIS BECOMES A- A- THE
ATTACHED TO THE BUDGET THAT.
THIS IS THE MOST WHAT THIS MAY
BE THE ONE POLICY HEARING THAT
WE HAVE SO WHEN WEEK AFTER
WE'VE HEARD THE WITNESSES I
REALLY DO WANT TO HEAR. IN
DETAIL. HOPEFULLY SHORT DETAIL
BUT IN DETAIL BECAUSE WE ONLY
HAVE THREE HOURS OR TWO AND A
HALF HOURS LEFT I MAY GO TO
TWELVE THIRTY SO PERHAPS WE
HAVE THREE HOURS WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF TIME BUT I STILL THIS
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IT
PROBABLY IS THE ONLY POLICY
HEARING. AND- I'M VERY GRATEFUL
THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA HAS
WORKED ON THIS BILL GIVING US A
CHANCE TO COMMENT ON IT IT'S
BEEN A TWO YEAR EFFORT TO-
WHILE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IS SIMILAR TO THIS-
DIRT THERE ARE DIFFERENCES BUT
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR
US IN THIS HEARING TO GIVE THE
ADMINISTRATION FEEDBACK IN FACT
THEY WANT THAT FEEDBACK. THEY
WANT TO HEAR FROM US SO YOUR-
TESTIMONY TODAY IS GOING TO BE
DOUBLY IMPORTANT- SO. AND THE
OTHER POINT THAT HAS BEEN MADE
TO BY MANY OF YOU IS WELL D.
TSC HAS HAD PROBLEMS HOW CAN WE
BE ASSURED THAT- D. TSC WILL
USE ADDITIONAL MONIES PROPERLY-
AND- I'LL JUST SAY THAT THAT
WITHOUT THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
STILL NEVER RECOVERED- TODAY WE
WILL BE JOINED BY MEMBERS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT CAN
SPEAK TO THE POLICIES BEING PUT
FORWARD BY THE BILL. AS WELL AS
THE SIMILAR POLICIES BEING PUT
FORWARD THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
CHAU PHONE MODERATOR WE WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. WELL NOTHING. WE
HAVE A WITNESS IN THE BUILDING
OR NOT YEAH. OKAY SO OUR PHONE
MONITOR WE WISH TO HEAR FROM
THE IT THE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT FIRST ON KEPT EIGHT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE NOW LET'S SEE C. B. C.
D. E. B. UP. MADAM KEPT KEEP
PLEASE- BOB BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY. GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DON CAP
HE MCCUE CAPTAIN EXISTENCE I'M
HAPPY CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE SHEET IS PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB ONE- BY THE NUMBER
YOU KNOW BECAUSE- AS YOU MAY BE
AWARE SIVA WHAT CAUSED AND THEN
FAITH THE PATH TWO A HALF YEARS
WITH THIS WOMAN AMBIENT ON FOR
REFORM PRODUCCI TO SEE MOST
NOTABLY VIA HER EIGHT NINE NINE
FIVE TWENTY TWO. WHICH WAS
PLEASED WITH THE CALL AMEND MY
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE KEY
CONCERN AND CRY ALL OF OUR-
WHILE MUCH WORK WILL STREETS A
AB ONE AS OF STEP TO FULLY
ADDRESS ISSUES RAISED BY THE
AND OTHER STATES OF TRENT.
ACCOUNTABILITY RESPOND UNTIMELY
OF THE ACROSS AT A GRAND AREA
QUIPPER TO BE ESTABLISHED OF A
DE GOVERNING SHE WAS WRONG
COMPUTER WITH THE TO POLITICAL
OF HOW WHICH GENERATES
MANAGEMENT REMEDIATION AND UP
AFTER IN THE STATE ISSUES
RELATED TO HAZARDOUS WASTE
MANAGEMENT AND CLEANUP COMP
ISSUE THAT WEREN'T ALLOWED UP
TAX AND PROFESSIONAL. AND
MEMBERSHIP OF ANY PROPOSED
BOARD EVEN NOW THE THIS ARE YOU
THE SUB OF MUCH COMP AND
CONCERN FROM CAN AND BUSINESS
SECTOR- LIKE IT IS IMPAIR AND
ESTABLISHING THE BORDER
ENVIRONMENT SAFETY UNDER AB ONE
MM OF TO SERVE ON THE BOARD
HAVE ACTS WERE TO THE COMPLEX
ISSUES THAT APPOINTMENT BE MADE
POLITICAL CHEN. WE BELIEVE AB
ONE HAS STRUCK THE RIGHT
BALANCE TO THAT THAT MEANS IN
ADDITION TO THE STRUCTURAL
PROGRAMMATIC AND REGULATORY
REFORMS AB ONE SEEKS TO MAKE
WHICH ARE IMPORTANT TO SEE THE
IF MEMBERS IT WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE FOR SHORT TERM FEE
INCREASES WITHIN HELPLESSLY
CONTROL ACCOUNT TO SUPPORT THE
DEPARTMENT ACTIVITIES AND
DEVELOPMENT OF THE HOUSES WHICH
MANAGEMENT PLAN AND FREE TAX
COURSE. NOTABLY A GREEN CHEVY
SHORT TERM FEE INCREASES NOT
COME LIGHTLY FOR STEVEN IT'S
NOT WHO ALREADY STRADDLED WITH
INCREASED COSTS WITH THOSE WITH
PTSD- OVERSIGHT PERMITTING
WITHOUT COURSE. FOR DGSE EFFORT
WERE THAT ANTI HAS OF. AND
OTHER RIGHT. DECISION MADE A
RECORD. NOT STEVEN HAMBURG
TECHNIC THE IMPORTANCE OF
UNFUNDED BTS BEACH MAKE
PROGRESS ON THE ISSUES. BUT A
CLEAR AMERICA PATIENTS FOR.
PROGRESS TO DRASTIC. WERE ALL
IN ALL AB ONE ATTEMPT FIRST
MEANING STAFF TOWARD PROGRESS
EACH YEAR. AND IF NOT THE END
OF THE ROAD FOR WORK ON HOUSING
WASTE CLEANUP AND FUNDING IS
AND CAL. BUT A FIRST STEP WILL
MISS A THE- DTS. A LETTER. AND
STATE COMMITTING TO TOGETHER
OVER THE YEAR TO COME TO
TOWARDS. THE COMP AND-
GOVERNMENT. PROGRAMMATIC RIGHT.
AND TWO. THAT WILL CONCLUDE.
WORK STEPHEN IT'S MEMBERS
CONNECT THAT WORK AND WHAT CAN
OUR TO BE SOLUTION DORIAN. AS
IT RELATES TO ALL DAY HAPPEN
WEEKEND WILL NOT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR-
CUSTOMER WAS VERY COOL- NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM CAROLINE FOR. A
BEHALF OF. THE CENTRE FOR ON
RACE POWER IN THE IN- MADAM
FARRELLY PURSUE WITH YOUR-
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING KEVIN
CORKE CHAIR SMITH AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M CAROLINE
FERRELL WITH THE CENTER AND
REYES PYRENEAN VARMINT I
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA'S EFFORTS TO ADVANCE A
LONG OVER DUE PROCESS. TO HOLD
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNTABLE
TO MEET ITS FUNDAMENTAL
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH. DGFT HAS FAILED IN ITS
IN ITS SIGNIFICANT LEGAL
MANDATE TO ENFORCE HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE INSIGNIFICANT CHANGES ARE
NEEDED FOR THE AGENCY. FOR
EIGHT YEARS CRP IS BEEN WORKING
WITH MEMBERS OF THE PEOPLE
SENATE PARTICULARLY GROUPS LIKE
COMMITTEE FOR BETTER ARVIN
COMMITTEE FOR BETTER SHAFTER
AND DELINO GUARDIANS FOR
GOVERNANCE CHANGES LIKE A BOARD
TO INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE KNOW THOUGH
THAT FOR THE BOARD TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT TO
THE AGENCY IT NEEDS TO BE
THOUGHTFULLY COMPOSED AND
ADDITIONAL REPORTING AND
ACCOUNTABILITY STRUCTURES NEED
TO BE PUT IN PLACE. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT ANY INCREASE IN FEE
OF FORTY NEEDS TO BE PRECEDED
BY ONGOING OVERSIGHT BY THE
PUBLIC IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
REFLECT THE POLLUTER PAYS
PRINCIPLE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
THE ADMINISTRATION AND IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES TO INFORM YOU TNC
IS ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESS
AND PRIORITIZE THE NEEDS OF
THOSE WHO HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN HARMED BY HAZARDOUS WASTE
MISMANAGEMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND ALSO FOR
BEING IN TIME. UP NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM A JARED
BLUMENFELD OF THE SECRETARY OF
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY MR
BLUMENFELD- COULD YOU COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU CHECK
WORK- THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS GERRY
BLUMENFELD I'M THE SECRETARY OF
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY- AND THE T.
S. C. IS ONE OF THE BOARDS
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES THAT
I'VE SPENT. THE MOST AMOUNT OF
TIME FROM DAY ONE ON THIS
ISSUE- DOES TO FRAME IT FROM A
CRITICAL PERSPECTIVE IF YOU
THINK ABOUT COMMUNITIES AROUND
CALIFORNIA- AND WHAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT IF YOU LIVE
NEXT TO- OLD HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITY THAT HASN'T BEEN
CLEANED UP. THINK ABOUT THE
IMPACT THAT HAS ON YOUR
PROPERTY VALUES ON THE-
PSYCHOLOGY ON WORRY ABOUT YOUR
KIDS PLAYING OUT THAT THERE IS
BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. AND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND SITES THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN CLEANED UP IN CALIFORNIA
SO THE MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM
REALLY DEMANDS AS ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE- I REALLY WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA WE
WORKED IN COLLABORATION WITH
HOW OFFICE AND MANY OF THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU HAD TESTIFYING
TODAY. THIS IS- AT
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY I WANT TO SAY THAT
THAT WE TAKE THIS INCREDIBLY
SERIOUSLY- FROM DAY ONE YOU'LL
HEAR FROM MEREDITH WILLIAMS DR
WILLIAMS I'M HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE
INCOMPETENT LEAD- IN MAKING
SURE ALL WE DON'T WAIT FOR
CHANGES TO COME THAT WE MAKE
THEM AND MAKE THAT. THE
ORGANIZATION AS EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE AS IT POSSIBLY CAN BE
BUT THESE CHANGES INSTITUTIONAL
REFORM CHANGES THAT MANY PEOPLE
WOULD SAY WOW WE COULDN'T WE
JUST DO SOMETHING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT ACT I WANT TO POSIT
THAT THIS IS THE TIME TO HELP
THIS AGENCY CHANGE THERE'S A
LOT RIGHT WITH THE T. S. C. AND
THE LAW. THAT WE STILL NEED IN
TIMES OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT THAT I THINK WE'RE IN
AGREEMENT ON SO I WOULD SAY
THAT THE- THE TRAILER BILL
WHICH IS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX PAGES- AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA SAID IT
INCORPORATES A GREAT DEAL OF
THE NEGOTIATION THE- BEEN
WORKING ON. TOGETHER I DIDN'T
HAVE AND IN THE HUNT OF OUR OF
ME ON THE DS REFORM I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF AND
CONSULTANTS THAT WEB FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
BEEN ENGAGED IN THAT. THE
TRAILER BILL- ALSO HAS THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO STOP
THE PROCESS OF INVESTIGATING
THOSE SITES I WAS DESCRIBING OF
STARTING TO CLEAN THEM UP. THE
BUILDING ECONOMIC RECOVERY WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE BIDEN-
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S BUILD BACK
BETTER PLAN. THERE'S A WHOLE
SECTION ON HOW WE HELP
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
ONE OF THOSE. IS TO GET RID OF
THE BLIGHT. OF TOXIC SITES.
DGSE ALSO NEEDS TO MAKE SURE
ALL THAT IN THE FUTURE.
CALIFORNIA IS LEADING SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS AND CHEMICALS IN THE
PRODUCTS THAT WE BUY YOU
SHOULDN'T NEED A PHD LIKE
MEREDITH. IN ORDER TO BUY
SHAMPOO OR SOAP ALL THINGS FEEL
FAMILY AND UNFORTUNATELY. WE DO
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATION IS AND-
AND THE TNCS AUTHORITY COULD
COULD REALLY BE DAHLE SAID IN
THIS CASE SO FOR ME. THIS IS
THE YEAR TO GET IT DONE. RIGHT
WE CANNOT WAIT. I REALLY LIKE
FROM FROM MY HOT MY PRIORITY.
LIKE I WILL DO EVERYTHING THAT
I CAN DO WHAT WITH YOU AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE WE
GET THIS DONE BECAUSE IT
CANNOT. LANGUAGE ANOTHER YEAR
AND I'M LIKE. YOU KNOW HOW THE
ISSUES WITH A SPECIFIC FACILITY
LIKE EXIDE. THIS IS THE WHOLE
KIT AND CABOODLE THIS IS
EVERYTHING- AND WE WILL BE
PUTTING PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
COMMUNITIES AT RISK IF WE DON'T
ACHIEVE REFORM THIS YET SO. I
WILL WORK THROUGHOUT. ANY
PROCESS THAT ANYONE ENGAGES- IN
ORDER TO SELL SOME OF THESE
ISSUES. THE ONLY DISTINCTION
BETWEEN WHAT ASSEMBLY MAN GOT-
ASSEMBLY WHEN WE GOT TO SEE A
SAID OF MYSELF IS I FEEL LIKE
THE BRIDGE HAS BEEN REALLY
NARROWED TO A FEW. KEY ISSUES
AND I CAN SEE THE LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE TUNNEL. TO THE D. S.
C. REFORM SO I JUST WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU AND ADVANCE.
FOR HELPING MAKE THIS HAPPEN I
THINK WHEN WE LOOK BACK ON THIS
VICTORY. WE CAN BE REALLY PROUD
THAT WE BUILD A BETTER AGENCY
THAT WE GOT GOOD GOVERNANCE IN
PLACE AND THAT WE PROTECT IT
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE. WAITED A VERY VERY LONG
TIME FOR THIS THANK YOU. THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT THERE'S BEEN IN
MOTION AND A SECOND. WELL NOW
HERE- FOR FIRST AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR SECRETARY FOR
TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY
DAY. OTHER SHOWS YOUR
DEDICATION TO GETTING THINGS
RIGHT TO DTS SAY. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM DR MEREDITH
WILLIAMS DIRECTOR OF DTS SEE-
PLEASE- TESTIFY. AND IF YOU CAN
WHEN YOU TESTIFY IF YOU COULD
TALK ABOUT- THE DIFFERENCES OR
PERHAPS A SECRETARY WANT TO DO
THAT. BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL AND
WHAT YOU HEAR. HAVE HERE SO WE
CAN GIVE FEEDBACK ON IT. THANK
YOU CHAIR CORK THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND A SPECIAL
THANKS TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA. I THINK YOU NEED TO GET
CLOSER TO THE MICROPHONE. IS
THAT BETTER. THAT'S MUCH BETTER
OKAY SO- THANK YOU CHAIR CORK
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND A
SPECIAL THANKS TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA. FOR KEEPING THIS
ISSUE IN FRONT OF YOU IN FRONT
OF THE PUBLIC IN FRONT OF. ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS SO THAT WE
CAN TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO
REALLY RESOLVE THE ISSUES WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OR TAKE THIS
MAJOR STEP TOWARD RESOLVING
ISSUES. AS YOU ALL KNOW WE
STARTED THIS PROCESS LAST YEAR
COVERT CAME ALONG WE'VE- MADE
GREAT PROGRESS THROUGH EIGHTY
NINE NINE FIVE AND LEARNED A
LOT FROM THAT AND AS A RESULT.
THE PROPOSAL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PUT FORTH IN THE
TRAILER BILL THIS YEAR. DOES
ADDRESS MANY OF THE THINGS WE
LEARNED FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS
LAST YEAR AND MANY OF THE
ELEMENTS OF NINE NINE FIVE.
THERE ARE SOME SOME DIFFERENCES
THAT WE ARE- BETWEEN LAST YEAR
AND THIS YEAR AND I WILL
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THEM
NUMBER ONE. WE HAVE NOW
COMPLETED THOSE WORKLOAD
ANALYSES THAT REALLY TELL THE
WORLD WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH
OUR RESOURCES. WHAT IS IT THAT
WE- ARE ABLE TO ADDRESS IN
TERMS OF OUR STATUTORY MANDATES
AND REQUIREMENTS AND WHAT WE
CAN'T DO BECAUSE WE LACK THE
RESOURCES AND IN. KEEPING WITH
THAT D. ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IS COMPREHENSIVE IT IS
THE TRANSPARENCY IT IS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY BUT IT'S ALSO
THE FULL FISCAL ACCOUNT FULL.
FISCAL STABILITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT BOTH IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING VERY. CRITICAL NEED
IN THE SHORT TERM. THANK LIKE
MAKING SURE WE MAINTAIN OUR
FEDERAL DELEGATION TO IMPLEMENT
AND PROVIDE OVERSIGHT FOR
REGRET- THINGS LIKE MAKING SURE
WE'RE ENFORCING IN THESE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WE'VE
PUT IN ENOUGH. WE'RE WE'RE NOT
JUST CLOSING THAT GENERAL FUND
GAP. WE'RE ALSO INCREASING
ENOUGH OF THE RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE CRITICAL
NEEDS IT IS NOT THE FULL
SOLUTION FOR THE LONG TERM BUT-
WE WOULD NOW HAVE A BOARD THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT FEEL
FLORIDA E. TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT THE MANDATES THAT WE HAVE.
AND MAKE THOSE DECISIONS ABOUT
WHAT THE PRIORITIES ARE AND
WHERE THE FUNDING SHOULD BE TO
MEET THOSE PRIORITIES. SO IT'S
A GOOD START IN THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS A IS
A- TERRIFIC DOWN PAYMENT IT
WOULD ACCELERATE OUR ABILITY.
TO BUILD THE CAPACITY FOR AN
INVESTIGATION INSIGHT DISCOVERY
PROGRAM. AND HAVE THAT IN PLACE
SO THAT IF WE GET THE LONG TERM
FUNDING WE CAN THEN BUILD ON
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND START TO CHIP AWAY.
AT THAT- AT THAT. THAT HUGE
NUMBER OF SITES AROUND THE
STATE SO ONE OF THE BIG
DIFFERENCES IS THAT WE ARE NOT
CALLING FOR A FEW TASK FORCE
BECAUSE WE DONE THE ANALYSIS.
ON THE FEES WE'VE PUT FORTH A
FEE STRUCTURE THAT SIMPLIFIED
IT STREAMLINED. IT IT HOW HE
KEEPS IN MIND SOME OF THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND THE BURDENS AND
MAKING AND WE'RE MINDFUL OF
THAT TOO IT'S BASED ON A
POLLUTER PAYS PRINCIPLE. AND
AND IT IT WILL SERVE US IT WILL
SERVE US TILL SUCH TIME AS A
BOARD CAN DECIDE WHAT
ADDITIONAL CHANGES MIGHT NEED
TO BE MADE DOWN THE ROAD. AND
INCLUDING- JUST CONTINUE YOU
KNOW OUR FEES HAVE NOT BEEN
ADJUSTED SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT AND I THINK YOU ALL KNOW
THAT BUT IT BEARS REPEATING.
THAT IT YOU KNOW WE CAN'T WAIT.
WE WE'RE ALREADY A YEAR LATE
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC. AND
NOW TO WAIT AGAIN FOR A FEW
TASK FORCE TO COME UP WITH AN
ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL WE THINK
WOULD BE. QUITE CHALLENGING FOR
US AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE BURDENS ON THE
GENERAL FUND. SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCES- AND THEN I WOULD I
WOULD ONLY HIGHLIGHT THAT- WE
ARE HAVING ONGOING ENGAGEMENT
WITH YOU I'VE NEVER HAD THE%
OPPORTUNITY MAYBE MEET WITH
SOME OF YOU ONE ON ONE. THE
LEDGE THAT HAS MADE THEMSELVES
AVAILABLE FOR WEEKLY DETAILED
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
ISSUES ARE AND WHERE THEY KEEP
POINTS OF CONCERN ARE WE'RE
HAVING SIMILAR MEETINGS. WITH
COMMUNITY BASED JUST THE
ORGANIZATIONS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS AND WITH
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY AND
IT'S THROUGH THAT PROCESS THAT
WE WILL REALLY UNDERSTAND. WHAT
ELSE NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN ORDER
FOR US TO HAVE ENOUGH ALIGNMENT
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS. WITH THAT I
WILL STOP THERE AND HAPPY TO BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. THAT YOU PROVIDED
FOR THE ENGAGEMENT FOR THE LEAD
STAFF ENGAGEMENT AND FOR FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS TO KEEP KEEP THE
PROCESS MOVING SO DR MEREDITH
IF YOU COULD STAY UP FOR
MANAGER. SO WHAT ARE THE MAIN
DIFFERENCES RIGHT NOW BETWEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL AND
THE PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US IN AB ONE. WELL
NUMBER ONE FIRST AND FOREMOST I
WOULD SAY IS THAT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE FEW TASK
FORCE- WE ARE NOT CALLING FOR A
FEW TASK FORCE BECAUSE WE FEEL
CONFIDENT ABOUT THE ANALYSIS
WE'VE DONE IN THE BASIS FOR
RAISING THE FEES- AND- AND WE
LOOKED AT A NUMBER. OF POSSIBLE
MODELS TO STRUCTURE THE FEES
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BOTH
TASK AT HAND TO SPEAK MORE
DIRECTLY INTO THE WE'RE TOUGH
WE'RE WE ARE PROPOSING CHANGES
TO BOTH TOSCA AND THE HEAT H.
W. CA. FUNDING SO IT'S MORE
COMPREHENSIVE IN THAT SENSE- SO
THAT I THINK THAT THE FEE
STRUCTURE IS THE BIGGEST-
DIFFERENCE THERE ARE
DIFFERENCES IN TERMS OF THE
CONSTITUENCIES IN THE BOARDS
AND SOME OF THE DETAILS BUT
HONESTLY.I DON'T SEE THOSE AS
BEING- AS- I ICS IS HAVING VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES AND I'M I'M
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT RESOLUTION.
ALL RIGHT SO FOR THE MEMBERS IF
YOU HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
PARTICULARLY THE FEE TASK FORCE
NOT BEING HANDLED WILL WANT TO
HEAR FROM YOU ABOUT THAT- I
WILL ADD THAT I THINK THAT THE
ADDITIONAL- PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR ESSENTIAL AND THAT
YOU CAN'T GET YOUR JOB DONE
WITHOUT THEM. HOWEVER I KNOW
THAT- MANY OF THE MEMBERS HERE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE MONEY BE
WELL SPENT. AND THAT- GIVEN THE
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE OCCURRED IN
THE PAST HOW CAN WE BE ASSURED
THAT THAT MONEY WILL BE WELL
SPENT. WELL I THINK THE
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS REALLY TELLS
A STORY ABOUT HOW WE ARE
SPENDING THE MONEY AND WHAT
RESOURCES WE ARE- WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THE RESOURCES AND WE
CAN NOW BUILD ON THAT TO
PROVIDE ONGOING TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT OUR USE OF RESOURCES SO.
NUMBER ONE THAT EFFORT IS NOT A
ONE AND DONE IT WILL BE AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION- I'M
NUMBER TWO I THINK THERE ARE.
SOME DIFFERENCES BETWEEN LAST
YEAR AND THIS YEAR NUMBER ONE
THERE WAS SOME CONCERN THAT WE
WEREN'T INCREASING THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
NOW WE'RE PROPOSING TO DO THAT.
BUT NUMBER TWO WE HEARD THAT
THERE WASN'T ENOUGH
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE PROPOSAL
THAT WE PUT FORTH LAST YEAR AND
A LOT OF THOSE ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES WERE TAKEN. INTO
ACCOUNT. IN NINE NINE FIVE AND
WE HAVE ADOPTED A LOT OF THOSE
AND WE'RE TRYING TO SEE IF
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO GO
EVEN FURTHER INCLUDING.
DEADLINES IN PLACE REPORTING
OUT TO THE BOARD WHETHER OR NOT
WE ARE MEETING OUR COMMITMENTS
FOR PERMIT DECISIONS- TACKLING.
JUST JUST. SHARING WHAT OUR
STRATEGY IS WHAT WE'RE WORKING
ON. AND THEN I WILL SAY THAT
INTERNALLY EVEN WITHOUT A BOARD
I AM WORKING HARD TO FIND THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY. I WILL
SAY THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS
HIGHLIGHTED OPPORTUNITIES AND
PITFALLS. OF REMOTE MEETINGS
FOR INSTANCE SO IT PROVIDES A
LOT OF TRANSPARENCY IT TOOK US
AWHILE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
COULD HAVE THOSE MEETINGS IN A
WAY THAT COMMUNITY MEMBERS
COULD BE HEARD- BUT WE ARE ABLE
TO DO THAT WE ARE ABLE TO HEAR
CONCERNS AND ADDRESS THEM- SAID
AND WE'VE- WE'VE REESTABLISHED
OUR PUBLIC MEETINGS INDEPENDENT
AGAIN OF A BOARD AND THOSE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO. TO GET
FEEDBACK FROM OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
OKAY AND I WILL NOTE THAT C.
WHICH REPRESENTS- MANY OF THOSE
BUSINESS INTERESTS THAT WILL BE
TAXED OR- HAVE INCREASED IN
FEES. I IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. OKAY NEXT. SO. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN- IN THE ROOM MOTION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. OR IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM. ALL RIGHT AND
THEN IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM ARE ON THE- CONFERENCE WHO
IS A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE WHO WANTS TO BE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR MINUTES.
AT&T WILL YOU ASK THE PEOPLE ON
THE PHONE IF THEY WANT TO BE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OTHER PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
AGAIN NOT COMMANDED ONE
QUALIFIES- ALL. ONE HAS QUEUED
UP SINCE THE INSTRUCTIONS WERE
GIVEN HOWEVER I DO HAVE FOR
ALREADY QUEUED UP TO GIVE
SIMPLE COMMENT. ALL RIGHT SO IF
YOUR- IN OPPOSITION OR IN
SUPPORT PLEASE LET US KNOW AND
GIVE YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
IF ANY. THANK YOU. AS A
REMINDER ON THE PHONE IF YOU
WISH TO SHARE YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WILL BEGIN WITH LINE FORTY
THREE FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MORNING CHAIRED BY
HEARING MEMBERS MELISSA ROMERO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA GET
CONSERVATION VOTERS ACTUALLY
MAKE. MADE BY MICHAEL CAROL
WITH ACTION. AND OFFERING
GENERAL FOR THE CREDIT COVERAGE
THAT ONE AT THE KEY. OF BOB THE
PROBLEM THAT AFFECT THE STATE
NOT GOING TO QUIT
RESPONSIBILITY AT PROTECTING
PEOPLE FROM. POLLUTION THANK
YOU. NEXUS FIFTH BY ZERO YOUR
LINE OPEN. GOOD MORNING DONNA
THANK REPRESENT A LOCK IN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY SIX FIVE SIX ONE MOMENT.
OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON THE LINE
FIFTY NINE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU TURN NUMBER
NIKITA CROWDY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
CALLING TO EXPRESS IF YOU QUIT
AB ONE AS PART OF A BROADER
JUST AROUND. GOVERNANCE IN
FISCAL EIGHTY EACH I'D REALLY
LIKE TO THANK YOU MEMBER FOR
HER CAN TO LEADERSHIP IN PERSON.
OF THE PAST FEW YEARS AND
DEMOCRATICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
WELL TO HEAR FROM SECTOR
PLYMOUTH THE DIRECTOR WILLIAM
AT THE TO THE TOP PRIORITY
COULD EVEN. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH ALL OF THE GET
THE SIX ACROSS THE FINISH THIS
YEAR THANKS MUCH. FIND SEVEN
THREES. EURO IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING NAME'S JOHN I HERE
TODAY BEHALF OF THE WORLD RED
OF. WORK NEITHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO A ONE WE DO HAVE
SIGNAL AND WITH ASKED OF THE
ROOF COMPONENT OF THE- AND I
HOPE YOU'LL FORGIVE JUSTIN OR
TWO THOSE CONCERNS YES UP IN OF
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY PRIMARY
OPPOSITION I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I APPRECIATE THAT ALL I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF SO FIRST LET ME
THINK WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
AUTHORS EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THE
GOVERNANCE. AND STABILIZE THE
FISCAL PUTTING OF DTS GOING
FORWARD WE STRONGLY AGREE WITH
THOSE EFFORTS AND WANT TO HELP
SUPPORT AB ONE IN THAT RESPECT.
BUT ON BEHALF OF OUR THIRTY
SEVEN RURAL COUNTIES WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS THAT AB ONE TO REPEAL
OF SEVERAL LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THE EXEMPTIONS WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE COST AND
COULD PUSH THOSE LOCAL
HAZARDOUS WASTE HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND USED OIL
COLLECTION PROGRAMS. PAST THEIR
BREAKING POINTS. NEED COST
INCREASES WILL BE WORN BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT DON'T CONTROL
THE GENERATION OF THOSE WASTE
AND OFTEN OPERATE ON LIMITED
BUDGETS ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS WITH LOW POPULATIONS. WE
HEAR THESE INCREASED OPERATING
COSTS AND GATE FEES COULD
REDUCE THE CONVENIENCE OF SAFE
DISPOSAL OPPORTUNITIES.
ESPECIALLY WITH RESPECT USED
OIL AND RESULT IN INCREASED
THIS BOOK AND LEGAL DISPOSAL.
SO WE LOOK FOR TO COME TO WORK
WITH ASSEMBLY CARS. AS WE
WORKED WITH HER LAST YEAR AND
EARLIER THIS YEAR IN THIS
COMMITTEE- ESPECIALLY THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT WHO HAS BEEN
WONDERFUL ON THIS BILL. TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS AND
ENSURE THAT AB ONE DOESN'T
DESTABILIZE LOCAL HAZARDOUS
WASTE HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE
AND USED OIL COLLECTION
PROGRAMS. WE'D ALSO LIKE TO
MENTION THAT WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
DTS THE FISCAL REFORM TRAILER
BILL. WITH THAT POSITION
REFLECT MANY OF THE SAME
REASONS THAT I JUST MENTIONED
BUT WE KNOW THAT THOSE CONCERNS
ARE MAGNIFIED BY THE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER FEE
INCREASES CONTAINED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR LETTING
ME SPEAK TO OUR CONCERNS TODAY
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YOUR COMMENTS
ARE HEARD- LET'S SEE SO THE
NEXT STEP. WOULD BE FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- TO VOICE
WHATEVER CONCERNS THEY HAVE.
APOLOGIZE MISTER JR THERE ARE
STILL SEVERAL ON THE FIRE ALARM
SO OF THE COMMISSION. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU WHAT ONLINE
FIFTY FOUR FIVE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFETT
ON BEHALF OF WASTE MANAGEMENT-
CALLING INTO SUPPORT AB ONE
TODAY THANK. NEXT WE'RE GONNA
LINE FIFTY FIVE FIVE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN RESPECT MARIN WITH
ERIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS. WE REPRESENT THREE
THOUSAND SCIENTISTS WHO WORK
FOR THE STATE INCLUDING THE
ONES THAT WORK AT THE TSC AND
WE JUST WANT TO APPLAUD THE
EFFORTS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AND OF COURSE YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND- WE APPLAUD THE
EFFORTS OF SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
DIRECTOR WILLIAMS AS WELL-
THEY'VE ALWAYS HAD AN OPEN DOOR
POLICY- FOR MEMBERS- WE SUPPORT
THE BILL- AS WE OUTLINED IN OUR
LETTER WE HAVE SOME ISSUES-
THAT WE HOPE TO- ADDRESS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
EIGHT THREE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS GERRIT
SLICE WITH THE NAVY ON BEHALF
OF THE MILITARY SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE. SHE H. AS YOU KNOW WE'RE A
UNIQUE STATE TO THE STATE CAN
THE FEATHER. FISCAL LAW ANOTHER
COULD OF FEDERAL RELATIONS
REALLY YOUR TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE ADMINISTRATION-
ON THIS IMPORTANT. OKAY IS THE
IT ME EIGHTEEN T. WE HAVE THREE
MORE THREE MORE OKAY WHAT MORE
THAN FOUR LINES GOT IT. LINE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU THIS IS ANDREA
VENTURA WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION
WE TO- HAVE WRITTEN IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA FOR HER CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP WE DO BELIEVE THAT
ANY FINANCIAL AID TO THE CHAIR
THE- NEEDS TO CALM WITH
STRUCTURAL CHANGE THIS IS A
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO A GREATER
CONVERSATION PARTICULARLY WITH
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. WE'LL GO
TO LINE FIFTY FIVE THREE LINE
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
ZERO SIX ANON ON BEHALF OF THE
ARE THE AND LEARN MORE SERVICE.
AND SEE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
ALSO WAS DIRECTLY. AND ASSESS
ON. CONTINUE ON IMPORTANT ISSUE
THANK YOU. AND THEN FINAL COM
WILL COME FOR NINE THIRTY NINE
THREE NINE YEAH LINE IS UP.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS KID OFF ON
THE OF THE BASIC. OF NORTH
AMERICA. A LEGISLATIVE FOR ME A
LINE OR CALL. WE ARE ARE IN CAN
SESSION WE HAVE. IT I REMEMBER.
CRISTINA GARCIA LEADERSHIP THE
ISSUE AND CONTINUE. WITH THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND AT THIS
THEY'RE NOT FOR THE LINE IN Q.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. NOW WILL
HAVE A- FOR THE- MEMBERS IF WE
COULD TRY GET THIS DONE BY WITH
COMMON AND- BY TEN- IN LIGHT OF
ALL THE OTHER BILLS THAT WE
HAVE TO DO WOULD BE. SO PLEASE
TRY AND BE AS BRIEF AS CAN BUT
PLEASE GET YOUR POINT ACROSS
WELL- MISTER- DEVON MATHIS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN COURT- I REALLY WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR I KNOW ON.
GARCIA YOU WORKED ON TACKLING
SOME TOUGH ISSUES OVER THE
YEARS AND I KNOW WE'VE WORKED-
WELL TOGETHER ON SOME OF THOSE-
I WANT TO THANK SECRETARY.
BLUMENFELD FOR THE COMMENTS. I
DO TO HAVE CONCERNS- COMING
FROM A ROLL DISTRICT IT IT
ALWAYS KINDA. THROWS THAT RED
FLAG OF CAUTION- WHEN- WE HEAR
FROM OUR ROLE COUNTY SUCH.
BLOOD IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO I UNDERSTAND IT'S IS A
VERY TOUGH NEEDLE TO THREAD I
KNOW ANYTIME THAT WE LOOK AT.
CHANGING HOW FEES ARE DONE AND
HOW WE CONDUCT THINGS IN AND
WE'VE SEEN THIS WITH DIFFERENT
PIECES OF LEGISLATION. OVER OUR
TEN YEAR HERE- EVERYBODY ALWAYS
GETS WORRIED THAT EVERYBODY
ALWAYS GETS NERVOUS. AND I KNOW
THIS ISN'T AN EASY TASK AND I
LIKE TO JOINT AUTHORS THIS
ENDEAVOR WITH YOU- I'M SURE
I'LL GET FLAK FOR IT. BUT FOLKS
TRUST US WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR AWHILE- LET'S WORK OUT THE
KINKS LET'S ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS FROM OUR ROLE
COUNTIES. I DO REPRESENT THE
THIRD LARGEST DISTRICT IN THE
STATE. ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
AND- I KNOW THERE'S CONCERNS
AND I KNOW TOGETHER WE CAN WORK
THROUGH THOSE- SO IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO HAVE ME AND HAVE ME
BE UP A LITTLE BIT ON THOSE
CONCERNS- MORE THAN HAPPY TO
JOIN AUTHOR THIS. AND PUSH
BACK- ON THE ADMINISTRATION A
LITTLE BIT AND GET GET THIS
TORRENT ACTUALLY NEEDS TO BE.
BEFORE WE BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
THE OURS ADD THEY HAVE GREAT
PART AGREE ADVOCATE AND- AM WHO.
THAT WE GET TO A COMMON GROUND
THAT IS WITH THEM ALL WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS. AND DISCOUNT
WAIT I WILL SAY WELL THIS IS
PERSONAL I LIVE IN ONE OF THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT'S HIGHLY
IMPACTED. THESE COMMUNITIES ARE
ACROSS THE WHOLE STATE THIS
APARTMENT SERVICES THE WHOLE
STATE- AND SO IT'S REALLY
SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS ALL OF
US SENATE SHORTENS OUR LIFE IT
MAKES A SICK OUT THERE AND SO.
I WELCOME ALL THE SUPPORT- AND
YOU KNOW I LIKE TO THINK THAT
WE'RE IN THE- BUSINESS OF
MAKING THE IMPOSSIBLE POSSIBLE
AND THIS IS FILE IMPOSSIBLE FOR
FIVE YEARS ACTUALLY- BUT I DO
WANT TO APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION THEIR
COMMITMENT- BOTTOM SECRETARY
BLUMENTHAL AND DR WILLIAMS. TO
TRY TO GET THERE ON AND SO I
HAVE SEEN THEY GOT CLOSE FROM
WHERE WE WERE AT. TO WHERE
WE'RE AT TODAY I DO THINK THAT
THE TASK FORCE IS AN IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON. OUT THERE
AS WELL AND SO I AM I AM
HOPEFUL THAT IT'LL GET DONE AND
IF THEY GET FUN IN AB ONE OR IN
A BILL. I'M HOPEFUL THAT
WHATEVER GETS THEM WILL BE EVER
STILL OF THE- COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT THAT WE'VE HAD OVER THE
YEARS AND DEFINITELY WALKING
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS THANK
YOU AFTER. ALL. SO IF THE- BILL
AUTHORED COULD. ANSWERED JUST
TO QUESTION- AND THEN YOU'RE A
REMARKS CAN COME IN CLOTHES AT
LOW EBB ONES YOU ADDED BY YOU
TALK ABOUT COOPERATE OF OTHERS-
SO I SAW DOCTOR RANDY NOW. THEN
BY BE RIVER. MADAM REBEKAH BY
K. THANK YOU MISTER- SO I WANT
TO READ- I GRATITUDE FOR THE
AUTHOR WHO HAS WORKED. IS
MENTION ON THIS AND TO REALLY
GET US A PLACE WHERE WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO A DTS C.
THAT IS. MORE SUCCESSFUL AND I
ALSO WANT TO REITERATE MY
GUIDED EVEN. SPECIAL DOCTOR
WILL WHO'S BEEN BEFORE THIS
NEWMAN TIMES. TO TALK TO US
ABOUT OUR CONCERS WITH T. S.
C. N. N. O. YOU HAVE CONTINUED
TO WORK BOTH ON THIS EFFORT AND
WITH INTERNALLY TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS MORE WORK BEING DONE
FOR THESE COMMUNITIES THAT SO
DOES THERE AT AND THE
SECRETARIES DEDICATION TO THAT
IS ALSO. REALLY COMMENDABLE AND
IMPORTANT AND I WANT TO TOUCH
ON. AGAIN SOMETHING THAT THE
CHURCH SAID WHICH AND DOCTOR
WILLIAMS ADDRESSED BRIEFLY
WHICH IS. THIS OVERSIGHT PIECE
I MEAN THIS FEE STRUCTURE
INCREASES SIGNIFICANT AND I
THINK WE SHOULD- BE COGNIZANT
OF WHAT WE'RE ASKING BUSINESSES
TO DO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT I
APPRECIATE THE POLLUTERS PAY
MODEL I THINK- BUT I MY CONCERN
REALLY LIES IN. HANDING MONEY
TO OUR DEPARTMENT THAT
HISTORICALLY HASN'T DONE WHAT
WE NEED IT TO DO FOR THE
COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW THERE'S
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
SITES THAT NEED TO BE CLEANED
UP AND I WANT TO UNDERSTAND
JUST. ON A DEEPER LEVEL AND
IT'S LIKE THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS
THIS AND DOCTOR WILLIAMS IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO AS WELL. HOW WE
ARE REALLY ON A GRANULAR LEVEL
MAKING SURE WE'RE HITTING THOSE
MILESTONES ARE NOT MONEY IS
BEING SPENT TO GET THOSE
COMMUNITIES. THE OUTCOMES THAT
THEY NEED- AT AND I THINK THE
THAT GETS THE- GAP STILL NEED
TO CLOSE I THINK THAT SOME-
DEADLINES HAVE BEEN INCLUDED IN
THE BILL AND HAVING A BOARD
HEALTH TO CREATE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY AS WELL ON THE
TRANSPARENCY. AND THE ABILITY
FOR THE PUBLIC OR THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO PARTICIPATE.
BUT I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
SPEED TEST VERSUS QUESTION YOU
KNOW IS. IS PART OF THAT ALSO
THERE'S A LOT AS A PATIENT. I
WILL SAY THAT I ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS NOT
PROPERLY FUNDED AND SO THAT IS
A PIECE OF THE PROBLEM. BUT
THAT CAN BE THAT'S NOT THE ONLY
PROBLEM WE HAVE SERIOUS
GOVERNANCE REFORM THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN- AND SO I THINK THAT
THIS IS WHERE THIS RESTRUCTURE
THIS QUESTION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. SO THAT THOSE THAT
ARE PAINTED DIGITAL PHILLY
FEES. FILL THAT THEY'RE GETTING
THIS MONEY WE'RE STILL THAT
THEY'RE NOT WAITING FOR YEARS
FOR A PER MAP I'VE TALKED TO
FOLKS HAVE BEEN. WAITING FOR A
PERMIT APPROVAL FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE-
IT MAKES US WONDER WHAT ELSE
ARE HOLDING OFF ON UNTIL. I
THINK THAT THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE PIECES I WOULD SAY THAT.
STAFF FROM- COMMITTEE HERE HAS
BEEN. A REALLY ESSENTIAL IN
THIS AN IF THAT DOESN'T ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION CLEARLY. THEY CAN
ADD TO THAT. I'M NOT GOING TO
DO. TO DRESS IN A- SURE. SO I
WOULD. FOR OF ALL THAT THE FEE
AUTHORITY. BEING SICK
RECOMMENDED. THE BOARD. MUST
MODELED AFTER OTHERS. OR ARE
AROUND THIS. WATER BOARD FOR A-
DO. ANY PER. FEATURE WOULD GO
THROUGH THE BUDGET AND
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS SO
ULTIMATELY. THE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE- THE FINAL SAY ON WHETHER
OR NOT ANY FUTURE CHANGES. GO
THROUGH SO THERE ARE PROVISIONS
AND MAX THE MEANS THAT THE THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE- THE
SENATE. USES TO KEEP US
ACCOUNTABLE. AND TO- AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ON TRACK
AND THAT WE'RE- TRUSTWORTHY
WITH THE FUNDS. I WILL SAY I
WISH I HAD TIME TO TELL SOME OF
THE SUCCESS STORIES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TODAY I DO NOT-
HOWEVER. I CAN SAY ONE OF THE
SECRETARIES HIGHEST PRIORITIES
HAS BEEN ENFORCEMENT. AND WE
HAVE TAKEN THAT VERY MUCH TO
HEART AND WE HAVE TAKEN STRONG
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS- WEEKLY.
AGAINST AGAIN SOME OF THE MOST
PROBLEMATIC TYPES OF FACILITIES
IN THE STATE THAT ARE. IN THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES. AND THAT'S JUST
ONE PLACE WHERE I CAN HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF OUR SUCCESS. AND SOME
OF THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING-
THAT THAT SHOWS THAT THIS IS
NOT. THE SAME D. TSC IT HAS
EVOLVED IT'S RESPONDED TO THE
PEOPLE SENATE. IT'S A NUMBER OF
ISSUES IN THE PEOPLE SENATE
REPORT. IT HAS RESPONDED TO
MANY MANY OF THE FINDINGS WITH
THE INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL.
WE TAKE THE SAY HOT ANNUAL
REPORT ON ENVIRONMENTAL JUSICE
PERFORMANCE VERY MUCH TO HEART.
AND WE USE THAT TO MEASURE OUR
PROGRESS AND DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT WE'RE- WE'RE- HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AND I
THINK. I'LL NIELSEN SECRETARY.
I WOULD JUST SAY HAVING THE
POINT OF THE CALLIE PA AND
LOOKING AT THE DAY BETWEEN THE-
TILL. BOARD OF THE WATER BOARD
AND THEN THE D. S. C. HAVE. A
PUBLIC AB OVERSIGHT HEARING
PROCESS WHERE. I WE'RE VERY
FOCUSED- THE UNDERSECRETARY-
SERENA MAXPOINT AND I ON KEY
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS THAT THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS WHAT IS THE
METRIC. WHAT IS THE METRIC WE
LOOKING AT SO IS IT THE NUMBER
OF INSPECTIONS IS THE POUNDS OF
POLLUTION REDUCED IS THE
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF IS IT THAT-
THE FUNDS GOING TO COMMUNITIES.
LIKE WE NEED DOES CLEARLY
ARTICULATED ON A WEBSITE THAT
SAYS HOW ARE WE DOING AGAINST
OUR BENCHMARKS. THAT THEN. IN A
PUBLIC SETTING LIKE THIS.
MEREDITH WILL GO UP AND SAY
THIS IS WALK WITH. DOING THIS
IS WHAT WE HAVEN'T ACHIEVED WE
DON'T HAVE THAT PROCESS. SO THE
TRANSFORMATIVE POT HERE REALLY
IS TO SAY. WE NEED WE NEED THE
METRICS WE NEED PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT. AND THEN WE NEED TO
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THOSE
CHALLENGES ARE. THE ANALYSIS
THAT CRISTINA- THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN GARCIA HELPED US. WITH
MERIT IT'S REALLY PUSH FALL
WITH TO LOOK AT THAT WHAT LED
AN HOURS AS WHAT DOES IT TAKE
TO HAVE AN INSPECTOR GO OUT AND
THEN COME BACK AND BRING THAT
CASE TO FRUITION SO WE NOW HAVE
ALL THE PIECES THAT WE NEED.
WHICH WE DIDN'T HAVE LAST YEAR
OR THE YEAR BEFORE. TO PUT IN
PLACE A SYSTEM DEAL POINT THAT
WAX IS NOT JUST ONE ELEMENT.
IT'S A SYSTEMIC APPROACH TO
ACCOUNTABILITY- AND WILL THEY
BE PROBLEMS YET BUT WILL KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE IN REAL TIME. AS
OPPOSED TO PUBLIC MEETINGS THAT
I WENT TO PEOPLE LIKE. JARED
YOU LAST WE ASK YOU TO DO THIS
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WE'VE
NEVER HAD FROM THE DEPARTMENT.
THAT WILL NOT BE ALLOWED TO
HAPPEN AGAIN. VERY GOOD- DO YOU
HAVE UP FOR THE COURT FOR THE
FOLLOW UPS. OKAY WHO ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE QUESTIONS. WELL IN
THAT CASE. WE GET WE HAVE HAD A
MOTION AND A SECOND. AND
THEREFORE WE CAN CALL THE ROLL
AND- I AM OF COURSE RECOMMENDED
AND I FELT. THE MADAM SECRETARY.
THIS IS ITEM ONE AB ONE
CRISTINA GARCIA THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CORK BY CORK ICE SMITH-
APPRECIATE TO WORK WITH THIS
BILL BUT WITH ALL THE CONCERNS
THAT ARE COMING FORWARD AND
LIKE TO SEE IT MOVE A LITTLE
BIT FURTHER DOWN THE LINE SO I
WITHHOLD MY VOTE FOR RIGHT NOW.
OKAY SO I DO NOT VOTING
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I. OUR CAN.
BE OUR CAN I. DALY NOT PUTTING
DALLY NOT VOTING. I GARCIA HOLD.
HOLDEN ICE MATHIS I MATHIS AT
WHAT A TO G. WHAT'S THE GI.
THAT ENJOYS VOTES SO IT'S- ALL
RIGHT BILLS OUT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DR
MATH- MISS SECRETARY WE REALLY
THE TIME THE HERE AND ANSWERING
THE QUESTIONS THANK YOU. OF THE
NEXT PER. WHO ARE WHO IS LEARN
A LOT FROM THE PRECEDING THIS.
DO I SEE A LISA. THANK DO I SEE
AT LEAST CALDERON HERE. YES.
YOU'VE GOTTEN A RELIGION ON DTE
C. SO THANK U. S. MEMBER CAL.
AS NOTED ME NOW OF THIS BILL IS
VERY SIMILAR TO A B. SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHIU THERE WE PASSED OUT OF OUR
COMMITTEE IN TWENTY NINETEEN-
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. YEAH EXCELLENT I THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- I'M-
YOU ALL ABBREVIATE MY COMMENTS-
AB TWELVE FIFTY WOULD SET
STATUTORY TIMELINES FOR THE
COMPLETION OF SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS CONSOLIDATIONS THAT
REQUIRE CPUC APPROVAL- THE
WATER SYSTEM CONSOLIDATION
WHICH MUST BE REVIEWED BY THE
CPC HAS PROVEN TO BE A SOLUTION
TO MAKING SURE THESE
COMMUNITIES RECEIVE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER- THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. DOES DETAIL CONCERNS
ABOUT POTENTIAL IMPACTS ON RACE
IN ON TRANSPARENCY AND IF THE
BILL PASSES COMMITTEE TODAY I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS. IN THE
ASSEMBLY UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE FIFTY ARE EVAN
JACOBS FROM CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
WATER AND DON WHITE FROM GOLDEN
STATE WATER. ALL RIGHT CHAU
THANK YOU- PHONE MODERATOR-
COULD WE HEAR FROM EVAN JACOBS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN WATER- ON THE PHONE
LINE- PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. AND WE CAN HEAR YOU
MORNING DR APARTMENT. YOU CAN'T
WORST ACTOR CORNELIA. GREAT
THANK YOU HI GOOD MORNING EVAN
JACOBS HERE WITH CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN WATER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE PEPSI- WE
BELIEVE AB TWELVE FIFTY IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THE FUTURE
CONSOLIDATION PROPOSALS ARE
PROCESSED BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION OF A
MANNER WHILE STILL PROVIDING.
SAFEGUARDS FOR RATE PAYERS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS THE BILL
DOES RETAIN IF YOU SEE THE
PROCESS OF ITS ME THAT- JUST TO
GIVE WILL BECOME OF THIS USER
CAL MERRICK WATER BEEN A WE IN
SUPPORT STATE. OF CONSOLIDATING
SMALL MAY SO. NEEDED TO PULL
CALL IN. TWENTY TWENTY-
REMEMBER TO SERVED UP TO
THOUSAND HOMES AND- AS A RESULT
OF THE CUSTOMER IN THOSE. NOW
HAVE ACCESS TO CUSTOM
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THAT
PROVIDE BUILDERS CAL TO THE IN
THE- XP IN THE CULTURE SIR. AND
WE NEEDED OF A TO PROVIDE SAFE
RELIABLE SIR AT THE FOR PRICE.
I AB TWELVE FIFTY WILL HELP THE
STATE'S GOAL SYSTEM. MAN'S THE
HUMAN LAW FOR ALL CAL ARE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
BACK THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER. AND NOW HERE FOR.
DON JUAN ON BEHALF GOLDEN WATER.
ARE ON THE PHONE LINE UP PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
BOB GOOD MORNING- IN THE
MORNING CARE COURTNEY THE
NUMBERS MY NAME IS DON WHITE
I'M ACTUALLY TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE FIFTY THE CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION- I AM GONNA
WATER QUALITY MAY FOR BOTH
STATE WHY COMPANY. AND WORKING
WITH SMALL THE TRUMP WATERS.
LOCATE NEAR START AREA. I KNOW
FIRST HAND THE PITCH FEELING
SUCH ARE IN. AND THE BY FACE
WELCOME THIRTY DOLLAR. I ALSO
ON THE STATE WATER. CONTROL
SAFER AND GROUP WHICH IS
HELPING DESTROY TO MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO ENSURE THE
TECH. FINANCIAL AND MANAGER
NEED TO STRUGGLING TO STEM.
CONFOUNDED IS A CRIME OF PRO TO
ENSURE LONG TERM FIFTEEN. OF A
LOT OF WATER. INVESTORS WATER
UTILITIES ARE UNIQUE THE TO
HELP ADVANCE THE EIGHT GOAL.
AND TIMELY TO BY THE WILL THAT.
AB TWELVE FIFTY WOULD HAVE
ACHIEVE THE STATE GOALS
CONSOLIDATE IN THIS RIGHT TO
WATER FOR AND I ASK YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- NOW IS THERE. IN THE
WHO WISHED IT'S TO TEST.
INSTEAD OF A TWELVE FIFTY. AND
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE REMOTE-
TESTIMONY TO AREA WHO TO SPEAK.
THEY'RE BEING NINE WE WILL NOW
GO TO OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM OR- IN THE
REMOTE- TESTIMONY AREA WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. OKAY WE HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM ANY PRIMARY
OPPOSITION I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE IS ANY BUT IF THERE IS-
PRIMARY OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE- OPERATOR PLEASE- PLEASE
ASK. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK AS PRIMARY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD ONE AND THEN
ZERO PLEASE. WE DO HAVE.
SOMEONE WHO IS QUEUED UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE OKAY.
BUT ONLINE
SIXTY FIVE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI RYAN THEY'RE
JACKING WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY AND I AM NOT IN
OPPOSITION I AM AND SUPPORT MY
APOLOGIES HAD A LITTLE GLITCH
IN THE SYSTEM SO AGAIN RYAN AND
JACK AND REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WHO WAS
ON THE PHONE LINE- PLEASE-
OPERATOR ASKED THEM TO- TO COME
FORWARD. YOU STATE YOUR
POSITION WHAT WHETHER IT BE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN ME PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. OURINITIAL QS THREE
LINES. AND IT WILL PROCEED WITH
LINE FIFTY SIX FIVE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MY APOLOGIES.
THAT'S AN AIRLINE FROM EARLIER-
SO WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY THREE
SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
JULIA HOLIDAY SUFFICIENT
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN OUR FINAL
LINE IN QUEUES LINE SIXTY SIX
SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NOT FOR
THE LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NOW
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE-
MISTER VICE CHAIR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MRS CALDERON
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. BUT
MY PREVIOUS LIFE ON MOJAVE
WATER AGENCY SERVICE AREA FIVE
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES I'VE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR THIS FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS. HOLLYSYS PART OF
OUR WOULD RECEIVE YOU COULD
CONSIDER ME AS A JOINT AUTHORS
FOR THIS BILL LIKE TO SEE IT
GET ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE END
YES I WOULD LOVE THAT. THANK
YOU. SOME OTHERS. MISTER MATHIS
YOU WISH TO COMMENT. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO JOIN AUTHOR IF YOU HAVE
ME AS WELL. THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT IT'S ABOUT TIME QC
GUESSES RIGHT. YES THANK YOU.
OKAY MR HOLDEN- THIS IS MORE
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF A
DISCLAIMER I SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY THAT ELEMENT THAT
OBVIOUSLY FALLS IN THE
JURISDICTION OF THIS COMMITTEE
AS IT MOVES TO YOU ANY WILL
WORK WITH YOU AND OBVIOUSLY DO
OUR ANALYSIS BUT WE'RE VERY
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER HOPE MY
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE NOW. OKAY
I'M IN VIEW OF THIS I'M VERY
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE'LL GET AN
AYE VOTE- THEN IT WILL GET OUT
HERE- SO MR HOLDEN AND I- AS
CHAIR OF UTILITIES. THE PROBLEM
WE HAVE WE PASSED BILLS LIKE
THIS IS A FAKE THEY USUALLY GET
IGNORED. PERHAPS NEXT YEAR WE
CAN HAVE OVERSIGHT TAKE A LOOK
AT ALL OF THE THINGS- THAT WE
HAVE ASKED THEM TO DO THAT ARE
GETTING DONE ON TIME AND- FIND
OUT IF WE CAN GET TO THE BASIS
OF THIS. BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T
DO IT THERE'S NOT MUCH WE CAN
DO. BUT WE SHOULD LOOK I AM
HOPING WE CAN LOOK AT ALL OF
THESE BILLS THAT WE'VE PASSED
OVER THE YEARS AND TRY AND FIND
OUT AND WILL NEED TO HEAR FROM
THE RATEPAYER ADVOCATES AS WELL-
BECAUSE THEY ARE. SOMETIMES
VERY CONCERNED AT ANOTHER TIME
BE GIVEN TO THESE. SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS- AND- THIS
COMMITTEES ALSO CONCERNED WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES
WHICH IS AGAIN ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT THE RATEPAYER
ADVOCATES HAVE- AND THEY'RE
ALWAYS OF COURSE CONCERNED
ABOUT FEES AS WELL. SO AGAIN AS
YOU'VE HEARD WE'RE GOING TO BE
HEARING THIS AGAIN I WILL I'M
ALSO ON- CHAIR HOLDINGS
COMMITTEE- AND IF THERE ARE ANY
OTHER ISSUES SAID TO BE BROUGHT
UP WILL BRING THEM UP THEN I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE. THIS
IS ITEM TWO AB TWELVE FIFTY
CALDERON. THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS AND RE REFER TO CHAIR
HOLDEN'S COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES
AND ENERGY. DR CORK I. THANK
THE COURT BY SMITH SMITH I
ARAMBULA. OUR CAN OUR QUE HAN
HI DALY HI SALLY I. GARCIA
GARCIA I'D HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS SIDE MURATSUCHI
WHEN I TO GI. SO THAT HAS-
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT ALL
RIGHT. YOU VERY MUCH- WE HAVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO ARE MEET
WHO HAVE OTHER COMMITTEES GOING
ON AT THE SAME TIME DR
AMBULANCE CHECK. SO ALSO ON-
ANOTHER COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME
SO- WE WILL LOVE HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN SO THAT HE CAN ADD ON
LATER THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. RIGHT
NOW WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO- ON AB
FOR EIGHTY- HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES TO RE INTRODUCTION
OF AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED ALBEIT
SLIGHTLY MODIFIED FROM THAT
VERSION WHICH THIS COMMITTEE
HEARD AND APPROVED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN- PLEASE SHARE PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. WELL. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU I KEEP
MY COMMENTS BRIEF THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE 2% EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY A
MEASURE THAT WILL STRAIN LOCAL
AUTHORITIES AND TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTIONS AGAINST LOCAL
THREATS TO THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH
AND SAFETY INCLUDING THE
ABILITY FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO DIRECT A FACILITY OR PORTION
OF THE FACILITY TO BE
TEMPORARILY DISCONTINUED AT TO
TEMPORARILY DISCONTINUE THE
OPERATIONS THAT HAVE COST AND
EXPOSURE- THIS IS A BILL THAT
CAME ABOUT AFTER SEVERAL
MEETINGS- REGARDING THE EXITE
CONTAMINATION WHICH THIS
COMMITTEE HAS HEARD QUITE OFTEN
AND I WANNA THANK MY COLLEAGUE
IS A MEMBER CRISTINA FOR BEING
SUCH A CRISTINA GARCIA FOR
BEING SUCH A CHAMPION. ON THAT
ISSUE I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AB FOUR
EIGHTY IS SUBSTANTIALLY A
NARROWED VERSION- THAN ITS
PREVIOUS VERSIONS CONSIDERED IN
THIS COMMITTEE HOWEVER I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN
ADDITION TO BEING AMENDMENTS
REFLECTED IN THE LANGUAGE
TODAY. IN CALIFORNIA MULTIPLE
REGULATORY AUTHORITIES HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER BUSINESSES
THAT HANDLE OR GENERATE
HAZARDOUS WASTE MATERIALS AND
THAT POSE A RISK TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY LOCALLY A
CERTIFIED UNIFIED PROGRAM
AGENCY ALSO KNOWN AS COOPER IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING
AND ENFORCING HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS AND WASTE LOSS AND
THE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER HAS
GENERAL AUTHORITY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND EXPAND
AUTHORITY ONLY AFTER A COUNTY
WIDE EMERGENCY IS DECLARED
CURRENTLY SOME FACILITIES THAT
EMIT HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES
CONTINUE TO OPERATE BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT MEET REGULATORY
MINIMUM STANDARDS TO CEASE
OPERATIONS IMMEDIATELY. A PRIME
EXAMPLE OF THIS TYPE OF
ATROCITY IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITY BEING THE EXIDE
BATTERY RECYCLING FACILITY IN
VERNON CALIFORNIA WHICH
CONTINUOUSLY EXPOSED FAMILIES
AND RESIDENTS ALONG SIDE MY
DISTRICT AND SEVERAL OTHERS AND
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES TO DENT
DANGEROUS LEVELS OF TOXIC LEAD
CONTAMINATION THE DELAY TO SHUT
THIS FACILITY DOWN LEAD TO
EMISSIONS FOR THE PLANT CAN.
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND. OF A
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES ACROSS
NUMEROUS COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
BOYLE HEIGHTS IN EAST LOS
ANGELES AND SOUTHEAST L. A. AB
FOUR EIGHTY WILL ENABLE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO DIRECT THE
FACILITY OR A PORTION OF THE
FACILITY TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE. THE OPERATIONS
THAT HAVE EXPOSED OUR
COMMUNITIES TO HARMFUL TOXIC
MATERIALS UNTIL THAT ISSUE IS
CORRECTED. AGAIN I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. OUT PARTICULARLY
ADDRESSING THE DEFINITION OF
IMMINENT AND SUBSTANTIAL HERE
TO TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE. R.
ROYCE LONG A CUBA A PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. AND MY MARIO DRESS
IDEAS WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO THE
CARE. MANY MEMBERS HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MARA STREET
EUROPE BY AND THE DIVISION
CHIEF FOR THE HEALTH HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS DIVISION OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR EIGHTY WE
ARE THE CERTIFIED UNIFIED
PROGRAM AGENCY OR COOPER AND
MINISTER THE HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS UNIFIED PROGRAMS IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. I
SERVED AS A SUPERVISOR FOR
SEVEN YEARS ON THE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS SECTION AND
RESPONDED TO NUMEROUS HAZARDOUS
MATERIAL INCIDENTS INCLUDING
THE AT LEAST- CANYON METHANE
GAS LEAK. IN JUNE OF TWO. SIX I
ALSO RESPONDED TO THE FRUITLAND
INCIDENT. OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
THE MAY WITH MAGNESIUM
EXPLOSION AND FIRE. THIS
INCIDENT INVOLVED THE METAL
RECYCLER THAT HAD A SECOND
UNPERMITTED BUSINESS ON SITE.
THE BUSINESS WAS STRIPPING
PRECIOUS METALS AND HANDLING
LARGE VOLUMES OF NITRIC AND
HYDROCHLORIC ACID WITHOUT A
PERMIT. ONE WEEK PRIOR TO THE
FIRE REACTION BURKE OCCURRED
WITH INCOMPATIBLE. THE FACILITY
WAS ISSUED A NOTICE OF
VIOLATION BUT THE AUTHORITY TO
CLOSE A PORTION OF THE FACILITY
WAS NOT AVAILABLE TO THE
COOPER. ALTHOUGH THE ARSON
INVESTIGATION WAS UNABLE TO
DETERMINE THE SOURCE OF
IGNITION. IT HAS AFFECTED THAT
THE SECOND ILLEGAL BUSINESS MAY
HAVE CONTRIBUTED ALL THEN THE
COP WITH THE FIRE. THIS
INCIDENT RESULTED IN THE
EVACUATION OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE WITH TOXIC HEAVY METAL
CONTAMINATION FOUND THROUGHOUT
THE COMMUNITY. ULTIMATELY THIS
RESULTED IN UPWARDS OF A THREE
MILLION SUPERFUND CLEANUP
PROVIDED BY THE UNITED STATES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY. HAD THE AUTHORITY BEEN
AVAILABLE WHICH IS BEING SOUGHT
AFTER TODAY IT IS VERY POSSIBLE
THAT THE ENTIRE INCIDENT COULD
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED. I'M HERE
TODAY TO URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
PASS A BEFORE EIGHTY. THIS
AUTHORITY WILL ENHANCE THE
GROUP'S ABILITY TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY FROM
RELEASES. OF HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS. THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD- THE PHONE MODERATOR COULD
WE NOW HEAR FROM MR ROYCE LONG
ON BEHALF OF. THE CERTIFIED
UNIFIED- PROGRAM AGENCY COOPER
FORUM BOARD. GOOD MORNING AND-
THANK YOU CHECK WORKING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
VOICE MOM AND I'M LIKE YOU THE
PROGRAM MANAGER ONE OF THE
LARGEST CITIES IN THE NATION
TODAY I'M TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ON
BOARD THE BOARD REPRESENTS ONE
HUNDRED FIVE UNIFIED PROGRAM
AGENCIES STATEWIDE WITH MISSION
TODAY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. COOPER IS
REGULATE OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND BUSINESSES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT HANDLES
WILL GENERATE HAS IS THE
MATERNAL AND HAS WHITE THE
BUSINESS'S RANGE IN SIZE FROM
SMALL BUSINESSES SUCH AS AUTO
REPAIR AND DRY CLEANING IN JULY
THE BUSINESSES INVOLVED IN
METAL PLATING CHEMICAL
FORMULATION AND REFINERY.
CURRENTLY SERVICE LIKE THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO DIRECT
ADMITTED ON NON COMMITTED
BUSINESSES JUSTICE OPERATION
MERELY WHEN THEY PASSED THE
THREAT TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY THE LACK OF AUTHORITY
JEOPARDIZES THE ABILITY OF
SWIFTLY TAKE ACTION TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITY. IT'S APPLIED TO
THE EXAMPLE THAT CHEAPEST AREAS
PROVIDED BY THE MAY WOULD MAKE
USING HIGH SPEED TOXIC HEAVY
METALS ALL OF THE DATES AND
FINAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY THIS
MIGHT HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
PREVENTABLE AND TWO OTHER
INCIDENTS INCLUDING COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE TAKE CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY WHERE THEY HAD A
VASILY REGENERATING STOP YOUR
EXACT. THAT HAD RELEASED FROM A
RAIL CAR CONTAINING ALL YOUNG
AS A RESULT OF LOCAL TRIOXIDE
REACTED WITH THE WATER IN THE
AIR TO REDUCE ALSO APPEARED
PASSAGE CLOUT I WOULD TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE SOUGHT MEDICAL
ATTENTION FROM THIS RELIEF
AFTER THIS RELEASE OCCURRED
THERE WERE A SERIES OF OTHER
SMALLER RELEASES FROM THE SAME
FACILITY THAT IMPACTED THE
THANK YOU THAT YOU. A RIDE
BECAUSE DURING THE VAN CONTRA
COSTA- BUT LACKS THE ABILITY TO
REQUIRE THIS FACILITY TO STOP
THE OPERATION UNTIL AFFECT THE
EVALUATION COULD BE PERFORMED
AB FOUR EIGHT WOULD PROVIDE THE
STOCK ALREADY. INDUSTRY HAS
RAISED A CONCERN REGARDING THE
POTENTIAL FOR A DEPRECIATION
APERTURE USE OF THIS THE PARTY
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE TASK
GIVEN THE X. OF STANCIL. AT THE
REQUEST OF INDUSTRY THANK YOU
FOR ON BOARD IS MADE THE FOR A
MAY. NUMBER ONE TO LIMITED
AUTHORITY WHERE THERE IS
IMMINENT AND SINCE ANTI.
INSTEAD OF THE INTERNET ALL THE
POTENTIAL AND I. NUMBER TWO.
JOHN SHOW TO CONSULT WITH
PROVIDE. OF WORKING WITH A
LOCAL BUT THE- AND LAUGHING
THREE. GEN COOPER WELL
ACCORDING TO WITH PARTS.
WITHOUT APPROPRIATE RIGOR
EIGHT. WHEN WE- BAR BEST. AND
RELY IN. OF ALL WILL CONTINUE
TO WITHIN TO A THESE. AND SO
THIS IMPORTANT EITHER. WITHIN
THEIR COMMUNITY. POPPING AB I
WILL INITIAL AUTHORITIES HAVE
AUTHORITY TO ACT IN INTEREST OF
THE POSTED. ONE SUCH MISTER
FOR. THE HEALTH EFFECT. THANK
YOU. UP THANK YOU VERY. IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WAS TO SUPPORT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR EIGHTY. IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY AREA WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. FOUR
EIGHTY. THERE BE NONE WILL NOW
GO TO THE OPPOSITION. FIRST
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM DAWN
KEPT THE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE- PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DONNED
KHAKI WITH MCCUE KAKINYA
CIRCUITS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BOUNCE. STEPHEN THEN THE
UNFORTUNATE POSITION OF
OPPOSING AB FOR EDM ACCREDITED
AMOUNTED TO ADDRESS A COUPLE O
ARMENIAN FUNDAMENTAL CONCERNS.
EVEN IF MEMBERS HAVE ENGAGED IN
A MULTITUDE OF CONVERSATION
EFFORTS TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
TWO THOUSAND L. A. COUNTY OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS TO GET TO
MORE WORKABLE PLACE ON THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH WAS ALSO THE
PRIOR SUBJECT OF EIGHTY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY EIGHT.
TWENTY UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE
ITS GOOD FAITH AMENDMENTS
OFFERED AND COMMITMENT TO GO SO
FAR AS TO EVEN CO SPONSORED
BILLS ON THIS TOPIC WITH
AMENDMENTS AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO REINSTATE AN
APPEAL PROCESS AS PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED IN THE PRIOR BILL. WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CHIU
SIGNIFICANT FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERNS OF THE BILL RELATIVE
TO A LACK OF CLARITY AND
CERTAINTY FOR WHAT RISES TO THE
LEVEL OF THREAT THAT WARRANTS
BECAUSE EUROPE WITH THE SAUDIS.
GIVEN THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE
EXPANDED AUTHORITY TO THE
COUPONS TO CLOSE FACILITIES OR
A PORTION THEREOF IT IS
IMPERATIVE THE ISSUE THE
CLARITY AND CERTAINTY BE
ADDRESSED. AS AN OVER ARCHING
MATTER OF CLARITY THE REQUESTED
THE AUTHORED SPONSORS CLARIFY
WHETHER IT IS THE COMMITMENT
CHANCE THAT DEFINITIONS OF
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES AND HAZARDOUS WASTE
AS REFERENCED IN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE SECTION CHU FIVE
FIVE ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO ONE
ZERO FIVE SEVEN FIVE AND TWO
FIVE THREE ONE SIX RESPECTIVELY
HERE'S TO GUIDE QUANTITY
DETERMINATIONS FOR TRIGGERING
WHETHER A SUBSTANTIVE RECORDED
UNDER THE BILL'S PROPOSED
LANGUAGE. UNFORTUNATELY SUCH
CLARITY HAS NOT BEEN A DROPS
WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT DIDN'T GO
AND NOT MUCH LESS WHETHER IT'S
A MINIMUM QUANTITY WHICH
TRIGGERED REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND POTENTIAL FOR
POLITICAL MEASURE. IN THE
ABSENCE OF CLEAR THRESHOLD
PROVISIONS FROM WHICH TO BASE
CONCERNS LIKE INTO A FACILITY
CLOSURE BASED ON IMMINENT
THREAT SHE WAS CONCERNED THE
BILL SCOPE RELATIVE TO HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE TWO FIVE FIVE
ONE ZERO EIGHT ONE. ENCOMPASSES
ANY RELEASED HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
HAVE NEVER THRESHOLD WHATSOEVER
WHICH COULD RESULT IN A DROP OF
THE REGULATED CHEMICAL OUR
PRODUCTS HITTING THE GROUND
REQUIRING AGENCY NOTIFICATION
SUCH AS MINERAL. OIL FROM AN
OVERWEIGHT TRUCK THE FORKLIFT
OR DELIVERY TRUCK ON THE PROPER
THAT MAKE A GAS LEAK THE IN
TURN. COULD LEAD TO THAT BUT
CLOSURE. FINALLY HEALTH AND
CODE SECTION CHU FIVE FIVE ONE
ZERO HE- BLACKLISTED. IMMINENT
AND TO. ENDANGERMENT TO POP
HEALTH WITHOUT JAPONAIS OR ANY
STUFF TOOK THE RESULTING IMPACT.
FOR INTER. AND THAT'S- TO SHOW
CRYSTAL. ARE POTENTIAL DEMAND
RELIEF AS- WE PRE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS WORK ON PROVIDE
CLEAR ON THESE TRIPS BE A
DOCTOR ISSUE THIS. HAD
MENTIONED THAT- OKAY DAYS. WE
BELIEVE IT IS OF COURSE TO
PROVIDE A CLEAR SO THAT
REGULATE TO IS QUITE OUT WHAT.
TO ABOUT MY- THAT COULD RESULT
IN MEMPHIS SO BEING CLOSED. SHE
CALPERS SHE NEEDED A VOICE
SPEAK. ARE MEANS WE WORK AT THE
AUTHORED. TO ADDRESS ISSUE
THANK YOU. LET'S SEE THEN THAT
PERSON TO SPEAK IS- IN
OPPOSITION IS MARCOS BARK
PARKS. ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION-
PLEASE PROCEED. YOU CAN
MANAGEMENT YOUR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
MARGOT PARKS WITH THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
I'M HERE TODAY AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY. AND AS SOME OF YOU MAY
RECALL HE HAD SOME TIME ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS THE THIRD
TIME THAT THE BILL HAS BEEN
INTRODUCED AND TWENTY NINETEEN
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY
AS MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS TO
REACH CONSENSUS ON SOME
OUTSTANDING ISSUES. THE LAST
TIME YOUR BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
WHICH WITHIN TWENTY NINETEEN WE
EXPRESSED CONCERN THAT BELIEVE
THAT THE PROGRESS ON THE BELL
WAS ON GOING AND SEARCH RESULTS
AND RESOLUTION. UNFORTUNATELY
TWO YEARS LATER WE ARE BACK
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE WITH THE
MAJOR ISSUES STILL UNRESOLVED-
AS PREVIOUSLY OUTLINED BY MY
COLLEAGUE NICK CASKEY- AND
FUNDAMENTALLY WE HAVE CONCERNS
THAT THE BILL WHICH ALLOWS FOR
THAT EXTENDED ITS ALREADY- BUT-
STILL LACKS THE IMPORTANT
CLARITY THAT WE SEEK TO ENSURE
THAT OUR- COMPANIES AND MEMBERS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FULLY
COMPLY. AND UNDERSTAND- THE
RULES AND REGULATIONS FOR THEM
IN ORDER TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
IT'S BILL MUST BE AMENDED TO
PROVIDE AND TO KEEP WITH
CONSISTENT. THRESHOLD AND
PARAMETERS AS- HE O. Q. AND I
BELIEVE THERE IS REASON AT ALL
SHOULD NOT WANT AND THAT. FROM
SUCH YOUR GUIDE AND- SO AB
THOSE THREE I'M NOT WE BURKE- I
KNOW VOTE ON THAT. THE YOU.
VERY GOOD. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. AND IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE REMOTE AREA TESTIMONY
AREA WISHES TO SPEAK. THEY'RE
BEING NINE WILL NOW OPEN THE
PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND
WHETHER YOU IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AND PLEASE TRY TO
KEEP IT TO THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO SHARE YOUR
POSITION ON AB FOR AIDING ME
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
FOR THE FIRST TIME LINE TWENTY
SIX TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CATCHCAN BURGER WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NEXT IN
LINE SEVENTY THREE SEVEN THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ARIANA RODRIGUEZ I'M A
LONG TERM RESIDENT OF EAST
DELHI- WHICH IS SEPARATE A LONG
HISTORY OF ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE AND PART OF COMMUNITY
GROUPS FIFTY ON CITY TERRACE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FORTY
EIGHTY. THANK YOU FOR IT THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY SEVEN SIX SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY SEAN ONE
TINY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION IN ALIGNMENT WITH
THE LEAD OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
OPPOSING AND THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY NINE SEVEN NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HI THIS IS
KARINA SANCHEZ LONGTIME
pFIRE MEDICAL- JUSTICE-
ACTIVISTS ARE A PART OF ALSO A
CITY TERRACE- VISION OUR
RESIDENT GROUP AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS WE LIVE
IN A COMMUNITY THAT HAS BEEN
AFFECTED. BY ENVIRONMENTAL
RACISM SO AGAIN I DO. SUPPORT
THE DETAIL. LINE SEVENTY FOUR
SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KATHARINE GRAHAM AND ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. LINE
SIXTY NINE SIX NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SORRY THE PARTY ONLINE
SIXTY NINE ARE YOU THERE- START
YET JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE OUT
THE CALIFORNIA FUELS AND
CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE ALSO
BECAUSE MOST AMENDED. ONE
SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. STE YES THIS IS BARBARA
WITH PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY ECONOMIST AND
WEARING SUPPORTING ALONG WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THE MONEY AS
WELL THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DAVID BOUDIA
A LONG TIME RESIDENT OF CITY
TERRACE- ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
SHOWN THREE CHAIRS I- STRONGLY
STRONGLY STRONGLY SUPPORT. NINE
FORTY EIGHT FOUR EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR JUST
TO MALIGN ON BEHALF OF THE
COOPERS AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL ARE VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT AND THANK YOU
ALSO PUT CARRYING THIS AGAIN I
HAVE ALSO BEEN OFFICE TO
REGISTER THE SUPPORTER OF THE
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS ON THIS BILL AS WELL.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ARMS OF ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WAS
RELATED TO REPORTABLE
QUANTITIES- OR LEAVE IT TO ONE
OF THE PRINCIPAL TESTIFIES TO
DO SO IF YOU IF YOU WISH ME TO.
ISSUE WILL- WILL LEAVE THAT. TO
THE AUTHOR AND THE PRINCIPLES.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO NEXT ONLINE
SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS A RUDY PEREZ
I'M A LONG TIME RESIDENT OF
EAST LOS ANGELES- BOYLE
HEIGHTS- A MEMBER OF THE STORES
YOU START I AM FULLY
SUPPORTING. EIGHTY B. FOUR
EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU. FIND
FORTY ONE FOUR ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I LINE FORTY ONE HELLO.
YES YOU MAY GIVE YOUR POSITION.
HI THIS IS ANDREA EVAN TURNER
UP WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION IN
SUPPORT. HER FINAL LEARNING
QUEUE LINE SIXTY SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SIXTIES
YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. WILL MOVE
ON AND AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO FOR THE LANSING Q. ALL
RIGHT. SO WE'VE NOW HEARD FROM
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION LET ME
SAY THAT ARM I'VE HEARD WHAT
THE OPPOSITION HAS TO SAY IT IS
MY POSITION AND THE POSITION.
OF THE- OF THIS COMMITTEE
STAFF. THAT THESE TERMS WHICH
THE OPPOSITION SAYS ARE NOT
WELL DEFINED ARE IN FACT WELL
DEFINED. YOU CAN READ- IN THE-
ANALYSIS HERE THAT. EMITTED
SUBSTANTIAL HAS IT. VERY WELL
UNDERSTOOD LIEU THE LEGAL
MEETING AND BRIEFLY READ
RELEASED THRESHOLD PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT THE MENACE TO MINIMIZE.
THAT ALSO HOUSES. I WOULD
ADVISE THE OPPOSITION TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH STAFF. WE
THINK THESE ARE TO FIND IF
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT ISN'T
DEFINED. YOU KNOW GIVE US THE
DETAILS AND WE'LL WORK WITH YOU
BUT I REALLY THINK THAT THESE
ARE WELL DEFINED- SO-
STRENGTHENING NO. REBEKAH BAUR
QUE HAN THANK YOU. AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS I
THINK THE INTENT OF THIS BILL
WHICH IS TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THESE EVENTS ON
GOING WHEN WE KNOW THAT THERE
IS. AN IMMINENT HARM TO
COMMUNITY IS CRITICAL AND SO
AND I WILL BE TWENTY M. L. I.
TODAY I HAVE A QUESTION THOUGH
FOR THE LOS ANGELES- BUT IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND IF YOU'RE STILL
ON THE LINE. I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS PEACE AND IF THERE
IS A CHANGE BEING MADE IN THIS
BILL TWO. A RELEASE OR A SPILL.
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
RELATES TO RELEASE OUR SPELLERS
THAT REQUIREMENT REMAIN THE
SAME. UNDER THIS LEGISLATION.
THE QUESTION A SEMESTER LONG
THANK YOU. I FORGOT HIS NAME. I
YEAH I CAN AT THE QUESTIONS
RIGHT HERE WELL AS LONG. SO IT
DOESN'T THAT SO THIS BILL IS
REALLY A FUNDAMENTAL
FUNDAMENTALLY SEPARATE- FROM
THE THIS BILL WHILE REPORTING
ISSUE AND WE'RE TRYING
INTRODUCE. ITS ABILITY TO CLOSE
THE FACILITY OR AN ACTIVITY IF
THERE THE INTERNET AND
SUBSTANTIAL DANGER TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. THAT'S
THAT'S THE FUNDAMENTAL TO WHAT
WE TRY TO GET YOU THROUGH THE
BILL THE ISSUE THAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW THAT YOU HAVE FROM
THE OPPOSITION IS ABOUT SPECIAL
QUANTITY THE LIST AND I AGREE
THIS IS BEING A PROBLEM THAT'S
BEEN GOING ON FOR MANY MANY
YEARS- ACROSS THE STATE. AND
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IS WORKING ON SOME
DROPS BILL- REPORTING
REGULATIONS TO CORRECT THIS AND
SO. THAT DROPPED AS BEING-
DRAWFUL MANY YEARS RIGHT NOW
AND WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO TRY AND GET THAT ALONG
BUT- THAT WILL ADDRESS THE.
THRESHOLD REPORTING QUALITY.
THANK YOU MISTER. TIME AND I
APOLOGIZE AGAIN FOR FORGETTING
YOUR NAME- I THINK THAT'S
REALLY CRITICAL I THAT YOU
ACTUALLY OPENED OUR STATEMENTS
MISTER LONG SPEAKING ABOUT THE
VAST ARRAY OF ENTITIES THAT ARE
REGULATED UNDER THIS AND SOME
OF THEM ARE THESE LARGE
FACILITIES. THAT BECAUSE
HUMONGOUS DAMAGED OUR
COMMUNITIES ONLY THE SPELLS AND
I KNOW THAT'S VERY MUCH WHAT
AND MISS CARILLO IS FOCUSED ON
BUT WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT AT
TIMES VERY SMALL RETAILERS TO
DROP TO MINIMUS AMOUNTS OF
CHEMICALS THAT ALL OF US HAVE
IN OUR HOMES- AND SO I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE PAY
ATTENTION TO SORT OF. THE
VARYING I'M TYPES OF ENTITIES
THAT ARE BEING REGULATED HERE
ENSURE WE'RE NOT- PUTTING
BURDENSOME REGULATIONS ON THOSE
WHEN THERE ISN'T NECESSARILY A
PUBLIC BENEFIT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. MISTER MURATSUCHI. THANK
YOU I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO DIRECT
MY QUESTION TO MR LONG THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY COOPER
REPRESENTATIVE- AS A SOME OF
THOSE GUYS KNOW- I HAVE AN
ISSUE IN MY DISTRICT A
LONGSTANDING GOOD A CONCERN
WITH THE TORRANCE REFINERY
USING A HIGHLY TOXIC CHEMICAL
MODIFIED HYDROFLUORIC ACID I
WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY COOPER
REPRESENTATIVE- I WOULD
APPRECIATE IF YOU CAN CONFIRM
THAT THIS WOULD- IF THERE WAS
A- IMMINENT AND SUBSTANTIAL
THREAT OF HARM TO THE PUBLIC-
IN IN MY DISTRICT AS A RESULT
OF THE RELEASE OF THE MODIFIED
HYDROCHLORIC ACID THAT THIS
BILL WOULD GIVE THE AUTHORITY
TO SHUT DOWN A PORTION. OF OR
THE ENTIRE REFINERY- TO
ADDRESS- THIS THREAT.
MURATSUCHI THIS IS MARIO FIGURA
DIVISION KEEP THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT IN FACT
I DID RESPOND- TO THE TORRANCE
REFINERY RELEASED- MANY YEARS
AGO THERE ARE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN I BELIEVE. AND AGAIN
WE'VE BEEN WORKING JOINTLY TO
REGARDING ANY RELEASES THAT
IMPACT THE COMMUNITY WITH
REGARDS TO EIGHTY SIXTEEN FORTY
SIX IMPROPER NOTIFICATION IT'S
HARD TO CROSS JURISDICTIONAL
NOTIFICATION AS WELL BUT TO BE
CLEAR AND ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
YES THIS WOULD PROVIDE THE
AUTHORITY THAT IN THE EVENT OF
A RELEASE- THAT IMPACT THE
COMMUNITY NOTIFICATION IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BUT THERE
FOR HAVING THE AUTHORITY. TO
ADDRESS THE MAJOR ISSUES AT A
FACILITY TO ENSURE THAT IT IS
SHUT DOWN UNTIL INVESTIGATION
IS COMPLETED BOB THIS IS WHERE
THIS. AUTHORIZATION WOULD
PROVIDE US. THANKS FOR THE CALL.
ALL I'M ASH A- THIS. IS
SURPRISE TO THE- LEARN THAT.
YOU DON'T ALREADY HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY TO SHUT DOWN. YOU
KNOW THE REFINERY FOR SUCH A- A
THREAT TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
IT IS THAT IS OUT OF ORDER TO
SHUT DOWN THE REFINERY
CURRENTLY NONEXISTENT. THERE IS
A LOT OF ISSUES THAT ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO ADDRESS AND THIS
WOULD CLARIFY THAT AUTHORITY-
I'M ON THE COOPER SIDE WE HAVE
A FIRE PREVENTION SIDE
DEPENDING UPON SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT COULD OCCUR THERE.
THAT THE FIRE PREVENTION SO I
COULD READ TAG SOME OF THE
EQUIPMENT AT THAT POINT IN
ESSENCE YOU KNOW ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE THERE AS WELL. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MS CARDIO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR. A ONCE AGAIN
BRING IN THIS THIS BILL FOR. I
DON'T WANT TO BE A- AS
PRESUMPTUOUS TO- YOU KNOW TO-
SIGN ON AS A JOINT AUTHORS
GIVEN THAT YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
SO HARD ON THIS BILL. BUT IF
YOU'RE NICE ENOUGH TO CONSIDER
ME TO BE A JOINT AUTHORS ON
THIS BILL. FOR IF NOT A CO
AUTHOR. I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. VERY GOOD ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. HUH MISTER
MATHIS NO SURPRISE RECKLESS
RETIREMENT OF COURSE OKAY I ASK
A LOT OF QUESTIONS TO. MISS
CARRILLO I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS ON THIS I KNOW
IT'S BEEN YEARS I KNOW CO IT'S
MATH A LOT OF THE SOFT- I THINK
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT MORE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE I'D BE
WILLING TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU
AND- THE OPPOSITION TO TRY TO
HELP. FIND THAT. THAT LAST
LITTLE BIT TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS SO I'M WILLING TO GO
GO OUT WITH YOU ON THAT WOMEN
AND HELPED BROKER THAT PIECE-
BUT WE NEED TO GET THERE ONCE
WE GET THERE I'D BE HAPPY TO
JOIN AUTHOR OF THIS WITH YOU.
BUT AT THIS TIME OF THAT AWAY
OFF. THANK YOU A VERY GOOD-
ANYONE ELSE. ALL RIGHT ARM THEN.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- SUMMER C. TO YOUR MORE
THAN WELCOME TO COME ON TO THE
LEGISLATION AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS I
KNOW HOW HARD YOU'VE WORKED AND
ISSUES REGARDING THE REFINERIES
IN YOUR DISTRICT AND I KNOW
THAT ALL OF US HERE CARE ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT CARE ABOUT THE
WORKERS THAT WORK AT THESE
FACILITIES CARE ABOUT THE
HEALTH AND IMPACT TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. CARE ABOUT
ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
STRONG ECONOMY WITH INDUSTRIES
THAT THRIVE- THAT IS NOT THE
ONLY REASON WHY WE'RE HERE OUR
JOB IS ALSO TO PROTECT AND
ENSURE COMMUNITIES HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE WHEN THERE
IS A SPILL OR HAZARDOUS WASTE
MATERIALS THAT ARE IMPACTING
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WE KNOW
THERE'S A USC STUDY THAT CAME
OUT JUST A FEW YEARS AGO WORD
THAT THE BABY TEETH OF CHILDREN
AND MY DISTRICT ALONG SIDE
SOUTHEAST L. A. IN NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES WERE TESTED. TO
HAVE LEAD IN THEM BABY TEETH
BECAUSE THAT IS THE LEVEL OF
THREAT THAT MY COMMUNITY AND
SEVERAL OTHERS HAVE FACED DUE
TO LEAD CONTAMINATION I HAVE
BEEN WORKING SINCE I GOT HERE
TO THE LEGISLATURE AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED BEING THE FIRST VERSION
OF THIS BILL WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND I'M GLAD THAT
THEY'RE ON THE PHONE AND I'M
GLAD THAT THEY'VE SHARED THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT EVERY
TIME THAT THEY PRESENT- A
PROBLEM. WE'VE TRIED TO ADDRESS
IT AND THEN THEY PRESENT A NEW
PROBLEM AND A NEW PROBLEM AND A
NEW PROBLEM UNTIL WE DON'T GET
IT DONE. AND SO MISTER MATHIS.
IF YOU ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH
ME IN THE OPPOSITION TO ENSURE
THAT WE GET TO A FINAL STOP. NO
MORE AMENDMENTS. NO MORE
PROBLEMS. NO MORE ADDITIONAL
THINGS THAT YOU WANT TO BRING
TO THE TABLE TO CHANGE THE BILL
AND STOP THE BILL OR HOLD THE
BILL. THEN LET'S DO IT. BUT
THIS CONTINUING CHANGING OF THE
GOAL POST. IS NOT HOW WE
OPERATE IN GOOD FAITH. SO I AM
MORE THAN WILLING I THINK I'VE
SHOWN AND DEMONSTRATED THAT I'M
MORE THAN WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO GET TO A GOOD
PLACE TO UNDERSTAND. THEIR
CONCERNS WELL THEY ALSO
UNDERSTAND. OUR CONCERNS
BECAUSE GUESS WHAT.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE FOLKS AND
FOLKS THAT HAVE CANCER IN MY
COMMUNITY AND FOLKS THAT. HAVE
BABIES WITH. AT THE B. TEETH
WITH LETTING THEM THEY DON'T
HAVE LOBBYIST UP HERE. THEY
HAVE ME. THEY HAVE ALL OF YOU.
AND IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE. THAT THESE AGENCIES AND
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES ON
THE FIRE DEPARTMENTS. THAT HAVE
TESTIFIED TODAY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE TO DO
THEIR JOB THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
THAT'S WHY I'VE BEEN. FIGHTING
FOR THIS. CASH FOR THREE YEARS
NOW. TRYING TO GET TO A GOOD
PLACE. AND I HOPE THAT WE GET
THERE. BUT WE CANNOT CONTINUE
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS THAT
CONTINUE TO CHANGE THE GOAL
POSTS AND NOTHING GETS DONE. SO
THIS IS A COMMONSENSE
pABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
IT'S ABOUT DOING WHAT'S RIGHT
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT WILL A
NEIGHBOR A LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO
ACT. IN THE INTEREST OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND BETTER PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES HEALTH AND
SAFETY. WHILE COORDINATING WITH
THE PROPER AGENCIES AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I AND
I VOTE. AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
THIS ALONG THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ELEGANT QUOTE CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I'M A COUPLE
OF THINGS HERE FIRST OF ALL
IT'S ODD TO ME THAT THE
OPPOSITION DIDN'T MENTION
SOMETHING THAT'S IN OUR
ANALYSIS. UP WHICH IS THAT WE
THINK IT WOULD BE BEST IF YOU-
MADE THE APPEALS PROCESS- MORE
CLEAR. SO IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T
THINK THAT THIS IS- AND- HE-
IMMINENT- THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
APPEAL WILL YOU BE WORKING ON
THAT YES ABSOLUTELY. ALL RIGHT.
WE REALLY THINK. THAT THIS TO
MINIMIZE QUESTION WHAT THE
THRESHOLD MEANS IS WELL
RESOLVED BY THE BILL THE BILL
STILL LEAKS DEAR CLEARLY STATES
AS I READ FROM THE ANALYSIS THE
COOPER AND CONSULTANT IN
CONSULTATION WITH A LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER MOST RECENTLY
DETERMINED THAT TE RELEASE
BILL ESCAPE OR ENTRY POSES AN
IMMINENT AND SUBSTANTIAL
ENDANGERMENT TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
NOTE IMMINENT AND SUBSTANTIAL.
AND THE TERM REASONABLE MEANS
HAVING SOUND JUDGMENT TO BE
FAIR SENSIBLE INJUDICIOUS THIS
TERM REASONABLE IS USED
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA LAW AND
IS WIDELY UNDERSTOOD. IF BOTH
THE COOPER AND A LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICE SHOULD DETERMINE A
RELEASE OR SPELL THIS IS A
THRESHOLD THAT THE BUSINESS
OWNER FEELS IS NOT REASONABLE.
THEN THEN THEIR SH WE WILL HAVE
A- AN APPEALS PROCESS
DETERMINED- WHICH WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO THE BUSINESS
OWNER. I THINK THAT THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION A
BITMAP THAT WE'RE CERTAINLY
WILLING AS AS COMMITTEE STAFF
AND COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM- AND- WHEN I
HAVE- AGREEMENT. FROM- DON'T
KEPT THE ON OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC BALANCE. AND MARGO'S
PARKS ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN%
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION-
TO AGREE TO THESE TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH US ON THESE ISSUES.
ARE YOU STILL ON THE IF YOU'RE
STILL ON THE LINE COULD WE HEAR.
YES LIFTED THAT MARGOT PARKS
WITH LET YOU THINK TRYING TO
DEDICATION ABSOLUTELY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADAM AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ENCOURAGEMENT AND THE
POLLUTION HONESTLY THINK SHE
THAT. YEAH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
STAFF BOB ALL RIGHT SO PLEASE.
DONT HAPPY EVER AFTER THAT
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LOOKED IT. WE THINK THAT
THINGS HAVE BEEN DEFINED.
PLEASE IF YOU DON'T THINK SO
GIVE US SOMETHING SUBSTANTIAL
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT THAT'S WHAT
WE NEED FROM YOU RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT THESE
HAVE BEEN DONE. SO WITH THAT.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
CARILLO THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK HI CORP
HI SMITH I WILL BE UNKNOWN
UNTIL CONSIDER OF. AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU SMITH NO ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN. OUR QUE HAN HI
DALLY. CRISTINA GARCIA. GARCIA
I HOLDEN HOLDEN HI MATHIS. NOT
VOTING MATHIS NOT VOTING WITH A
TO G. WHEN I TO XII. THAT HAS
FIVE VOTES NEEDED TO PASS UP
OKAY SO THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH EVERYONE
ON THIS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL. ALL RIGHT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN SPILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED. WE'RE
HEARING A. B. R. SIX FIVE TWO.
ALEX SAFETY JUVENILE PRODUCTS
CHEMICALS- MMHM. PERFLUOROALKYL
AND POLYFLUOROALKYL SUBSTANCES
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
THIS IS A BILL ABOUT P. FOSS
WHICH IS USED UNFORTUNATELY IN
A LOT OF CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS I
HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT SOMETIMES
IN THE LEGISLATURE WE FIND
THINGS OUT. ABOUT OUR OWN LIVES
THAT ARE DISTRESSING AND THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENED TO ME IN THIS
CASE AS THE MOM OF A SEVEN YEAR
OLD I HAD NO IDEA. THAT FOR HER
ENTIRE LIFE. I PROBABLY BEEN
PUTTING HER IN BE IN CHILDREN'S
CLOTHING AND BABY CLOTHING
PUTTING HER ON CHANGING MATS.
THAT WERE CONTAMINATED WITH A
KNOWN CARCINOGENIC MATERIAL P.
FOSS. FOR NO GOOD REASON.
THERE'S NO REASON AT ALL THAT
THESE MATERIALS TO BE USED. I
BELIEVE ANYWHERE BUT CERTAINLY
NOT IN CHILDREN'S CLOTHING. AND
CHILDREN'S TOYS. THIS BILL
WOULD FOLLOW THE LEAD TAKEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOMS BILL
FROM A FEW YEARS AGO ABOUT
FLAME RETARDANT CHEMICALS USED
IN CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS. AND SAY
THAT IN CALIFORNIA. WE REALLY
WANT OUR CONSTITUENTS KNOW THAT
IF THEY'RE BUYING BABY PRODUCTS
IN CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE DONE OUR
BEST TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
THOSE ITEMS ARE FREE OF CANCER
CAUSING ADDITIVES. NOW ANOTHER
PROBLEM THAT I DO WANT TO BRING
UP WITH THE P. FOSSE'S THAT
WE'VE ALL BEEN AWARE OF BESIDES
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE NOW
BEING DETECTED IN HUMAN BLOOD.
AND THAT WE KNOW THAT THEIR
ENDOCRINE DISRUPTORS AND
CARCINOGENIC I THAT IT'S ALSO
BEING FOUND WHEN LARGE AMOUNTS
IN WATER. I HAD A MEETING JUST
YESTERDAY WITH METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT TO SAYING THAT
THEIR BIGGEST CONCERN RIGHT NOW
IS NOT DROUGHT. THEIR BIGGEST
CONCERN IS THE AMOUNT OF
CONTAMINANTS OF EMERGING
CONTAMINANTS THEY'RE FINDING IN
THE WATER. OTHER MANUFACTURERS
IN THE OPPOSITION'S. MAY COME
ON TODAY. AND TALK TO ABOUT.
HOW IMPORTANT THESE CHEMICALS
ARE NOT REALLY SURE WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA SAY. BUT I WOULD
LOVE FOR SOMEONE TO ASK THEM AS
THE ONES WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR POLLUTING OUR WATER WITH
THESE MATERIALS HOW MUCH
THEY'RE GOING TO PAY. OUR WATER
DISTRICTS. SO THAT OUR RATE
PAYERS DON'T HAVE TO PAY TO
CLEAN THESE CHEMICALS OUT OF
WATER. WHICH ALSO WERE LEACHING
OUT OF THE SAME CLOTHING.
THROUGH WHEN WE WASH OUR- OUR
CLOTHING WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
COMING OFF IN THE FIBERS. AND
GETTING INTO OUR GROUNDWATER
AND OUR WATER SUPPLY. SO WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. OH AND ONE
OTHER THING I WANT TO MENTION.
WE ARE WILLING TO. AMEND THE
BILL AS WE MOVE FORWARD SO THAT
IT'S NARROWED DOWN TO MATERIALS
THAT DON'T INCLUDE ELECTRONICS.
AND MEDICAL SUPPLIES. VERY
GOOD. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT NEXT
TO- WE HAVE SOME WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM SO CAN WE HAVE
THAT TO TURN TO ON. AND THEN
WE'LL HEAR FROM BILL L. A. R.
D. OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP. MAY TAKE A MINUTE TO GET
EXTRA OKAY GO AHEAD. MMHM YEAH
JUST START SPEAKING. DOCTOR
RANDY SHOULD BE ON THE PHONE-
YES BUT WHERE YOU AT WE FIRST
WANT TO HEAR FROM DEL- ALLEY
ART. L. OKAY I'M FILL OUT LEO-
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
ENVIRONMENT WORKING GROUP IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M GONNA DRESS OF
THE OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS AND
DR DAVID ANDREWS WILL BE
ADDRESSING THE STOCK. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK. THE
CLAIM THAT PEACE AS CHEMICALS
THE ADDRESSED INDIVIDUALLY HAS
ALREADY BEEN JUST THE DECIDED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE HOLES AND THEY'RE
WORKING PAID ON P. FAST
DIFFERENT CONCERT AUTOX. IF IT
IS SIX EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY TWO
BAND FOR EXAMPLE FIVE
INDIVIDUAL FORMS OF P. THOUSAND
JUVENILE PRODUCTS THE INDUSTRY
WOULD SIMPLY CREATE FIVE MORE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF
THE CHEMICALS TO PUT ON THEIR
PRODUCTS. THE OPPOSITION IS
RAISED CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DEFINITION OF JUVENILE PRODUCTS
BUT AS THE AUTHOR ACKNOWLEDGING
YOUR STATEMENT WE ARE EMINENTLY
PREPARED TO APPROPRIATELY
NARROW THAT DEFINITION. THE
OPPONENTS SAY THE EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY TWO IS NOT NEEDED BECAUSE
PTSD SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM WILL GET TO THESE
PRODUCTS SOONER THAN LATER AND
ALSO THIS SENATOR ALLEN HAS
INTRODUCED SB FIVE OH TWO.
WHICH HAS SOME FEATURES MEANT
TO MAKE THE PROGRAM MORE
EFFICIENT THREE THINGS SB FIVE
OH TWO IS AN IMPORTANT BILL BUT
IT'S NOT A SILVER BULLET THAT
FIXES ALL THE PROGRAMS ISSUES
OF TIMELINESS. AND THAT BILL
MAY NOT EVEN MAKE IT TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR SIGNATURE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY ALTHOUGH DGSE
RECENTLY INCLUDED CHILDREN'S
PRODUCTS IN A DRAFT WORK PLAN.
THEY WILL NOT NECESSARILY ADOPT
THAT CATEGORY INTO A FINAL WORK
PLAN AND EVEN IF THEY DO. THE
PUBLIC IN THIS LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKELY WAIT UNTIL THE
NEXT DECADE TO SEE ANY ACTION.
LASTLY THE OPPONENTS RAISE THE
SPECTER OF INCREASED THIRD
PARTY LAWSUITS IF THIS BILL
BECAME LAW I KNOW THAT SOME OF
THE VERY OPPONENTS OF AB SIX
FIFTY TWO SUPPORTED PROP SIXTY
FOUR. BACK IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WHICH PUT A MAJOR
CHILLING EFFECT ON THIRD PARTY
LAWSUITS THE MAIN PROVISION OF
THAT LAW PROHIBITS ANY PERSON
OTHER THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
LOCAL PUBLIC PROSECUTORS. FROM
BRINGING A LAWSUIT FOR UNFAIR
COMPETITION UNLESS THAT PERSON
HAS PERSONALLY SUFFERED INJURY
AND LOST MONEY OR PROPERTY THIS
HIGH HURDLE HAS WORKED FOR THE
INTENT OF THOSE WHO BROUGHT THE
MEASURE TO THE BALLOT IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. IN CONCLUSION WE
CANNOT WAIT FOR DTS THE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS PROBLEM BY
PASSING EIGHTY SIX FIFTY TWO
NOW OUR CHILDREN WILL HAVE LESS
HEALTH. IMPACTS DOWN THE ROAD
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD THANK YOU-
MISTER ANDREWS- YOU'RE ON THE
PHONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CHECK WHERE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS DAVID ANDREWS
A SENIOR SCIENTIST AT
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
I HAVE A PHD IN CHEMISTRY. I
HAVE PUBLISHED NUMEROUS REPORTS
AND WORKED ON PER AND POLY
FLORAL ALQUILER P. FIVE
CONTAMINATION THAT. HAVE ALSO
BEEN A CO AUTHOR ON FIVE PEER
REVIEWED PUBLICATIONS REGARDING
P. FOUGHT THE CURRENT. AND
HEALTH RISKS. CONTAMINATION
FROM Q. FIVE IS THE NATIONAL
PUBLIC AN ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
EMERGENCY AND URGENT ACTION IS
NEEDED TO REDUCE. AND ELIMINATE
EXPOSURE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
RESEARCH STUDIES HAVE INDICATED
THAT HUMANS BOTH ADULTS AND
CHILDREN ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
NUMEROUS HARMS FROM EXPOSURE TO
BE FIVE. CHILDREN ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO KEEP
OFF IMPACTS TO THE IMMUNE
SYSTEM INCLUDING THE REDUCED
EFFECTIVENESS OF VACCINES AND
HARM DURING CRITICAL PERIODS OF
DEVELOPMENT. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM HAS ALREADY CONFIRMED
THAT P. FIVE ARE A THREAT TO
HEALTH. DETERMINES THAT P. FIVE
SHOULD BE REGULATED AS AN
ENTIRE CLASS NOT JUST CHEMICAL
BY CHEMICAL THAT THE OPPOSITION
HAS SUGGESTED. THIS INCLUDES
THE FLOOR PALMER IN THE SHORT
CHAIN REPLACEMENT CHEMICALS
THAT NUMBER IN THE HUNDREDS TO
THOUSANDS. IT IS BECAUSE OF THE
URGENT HEALTH PRIORITY OF
PROTECTING CHILDREN THAT HE WG
IS PROUD TO SPONSOR EIGHTY SIX
FIFTY TWO. HELLO ELIMINATE THE
UNNECESSARY AND POTENTIALLY
HARMFUL USE OF P. FIVE IN
CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS. THESE
PRODUCTS LEAD TO EXPOSURE TO
CONTACT WITH THE SKIN AND
INHALATION OF DUST. GIVE US A
CALL FOREVER CHEMICALS BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT BREAK APART IN THE
ENVIRONMENT OR IN PEOPLE EITHER
NOT CHEMICALS THAT BELONG IN
OUR CHILDREN. MANY PEOPLE
ACCUMULATE IN BLOOD. IS
CHEMICAL THEY'RE DETECTED IN
NEARLY EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN
THE COUNTRY. INCLUDING INCENSE
PASSING EIGHTY SIX FIFTY TWO IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD. IN
REDUCING UNNECESSARY EXPOSURE.
TO CHILDREN AND INFANTS AND
WOULD PUT CALIFORNIA IN THE
LEAD UP PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR BOTH AUTHORS- FOR
KEEPING TO THETIME PERIODS FOR
CHEESE ME BOTH WITNESSES- FOR
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RARE. THIS BILL. AND THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE- ANYONE IN
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM IF SO
SPEAK UP NOW. THERE BE NONE ARE
WE THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION- WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
SPEAKING REMOTELY THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD MISS LITTLE.
THANK YOU- ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS OF EIGHT SB **** AB
SIX FIFTY TO INCLUDE BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS DISTRICT NINE THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION CONSUMER FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICTS
CALPERS. CLEAN WATER ACTION
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY SAN FRANCISCO
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA. THE
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL. SHE
IS WITH THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA
AND ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MISS LITTLE. I HAVE THAT WHAT
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK REMOTELY TO THE TO THE
VIDEO. YES NOW OKAY THEN WHERE
ARE WE NOW GOING TO HEAR FROM
THE OPPOSITION. IN ORDER TO
WITNESSES FIRST I'D LIKE TO
HEAR FROM- TIM CHAU STACK ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL- PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING DOCTOR
CORE. OKAY YEAH. THANK YOU-
SHERMAN NUMBERS WITH MANY I
THINK I THINK WITH THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY AND- SAY I DO APPRECIATE-
THE COMMENTS BY PHONE THREE MAN
AND HIS FATHER WHO THE BILL YOU.
THE KIND OF WORK ON I EIGHT
MORE NARROWING THE DEFINITION
OF AROUND A GIVEN OUR PRODUCT-
AS WE HAVE STATED THERE ARE.
SOME VERY- WIDESPREAD USES OF
SOME OF THESE- CHEMISTRY THEY
DO PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
APPLICATIONS SMARTPHONES
TABLETS MEDICAL DEVICES.
PACKAGING FOR PHARMACEUTICALS
SO WE DO BELIEVE THAT A MORE
CLEARLY DEFINED DEFINITION OF
JUVENILE PRODUCTS WOULD BE
IMPORTANT I WILL BE IMPORTANT
TO AVOID A POTENTIAL.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. WELL I
DO WANT TO ALSO MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT. ABOUT PTSD PROGRAM-
YEAH THAT WAS MENTIONED BY
MISTER ALLEY- THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS IDENTIFIED
CHILDREN PRODUCT AS PART OF IT
UPDATED. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WORKPLAN-
SENATE ALLEN ALSO IS MOVING SB
FIVE OH TO A BILL THAT NEARLY
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE LAST
THAT CAN- THAT WILL PROVIDE THE
NEW TOOLS YOU. FOR THE
APARTMENT THE VICTIM IDENTIFIED
ADDRESS THEM UNSAFE CHEMICAL
INGREDIENTS IN EVERYDAY
PRODUCTS. FRANKLY WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THAT VENUE DOES PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT
ISSUES AROUND SCOPE IMPACTED
PRODUCTS- AND ANY POTENTIAL
FUND AND IT CAN IMPACT. FUTURE
THAT THOSE ARE PROPERLY DRAFT
SO I JUST DON'T REPORT- WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING. WITH
THE US SPONSORED- AND THE
AUTHORED THE PHOTOGRAPHS OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED
FINDING IT PROCEEDS AFTER. YOU
PASS BY TODAY THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM MR
J. WEST ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL AS
WELL- IS A DOCTOR WEST. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU CHAIR COURT
CAN YOU HEAR ME YEAH YEAH.
GREAT SO THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTY SIX
FIFTY TWO ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL'S
PERFORMANCE FLUORO POLYMER
PARTNERSHIP- WE OPPOSE THE BILL
BECAUSE IT OVERLY BROAD
DEFINITIONS OF P. HAPPENED
YOU'RE GONNA PRODUCTS. ON
PIZZA- AS YOU HAVE HEARD FROM
THE- SPONSORS THE BILL WOULD
TREAT ALL PEOPLE AFTER THE
SINGLE SUBSTANCE WHEN IT IS
ACTUALLY A LARGE DIVERSE GROUP
OF COMPOUND. THAT HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED BY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COUNCIL THE STATE ABOUT.
PROMOTE DEPARTMENT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSERVATION AND
A RECENT WORKSHOP CONVENED BY
THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES- FLOOR. SPECIFICALLY
ARE SUB CLASS OF P. FACT THAT
ARE LARGE STABLE INSIDE THE
MALL KILLS AND THEY DON'T RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT DEGRADATION AND
MOVEMENT. BETWEEN ENVIRONMENTAL
MEDIA LIKE SOME OF THE- SMALLER
LEGACY CHEMICALS. THEY ARE
NEITHER BIOAVAILABLE NOR VAIO
CUMULATIVE AND THEY ARE NOT P.
FOLLOW UP OR P. FOX AND THEY DO
NOT TRANSFORM INTO PEOPLE ARE
PEOPLE THE ENVIRONMENT. ON
HUMAN PRODUCTS THE BILL WOULD
BE PDF MEDICAL. THAT INCLUDE
CLOCKS POLYMERS AND ARE ALREADY
APPROVED BY FDA WHEN IN FACT
FLUOROPOLYMERS HAVE BEEN USED
SAFELY IN MEDICAL DEVICES FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS. THEY ARE
PART OF OUR QUALITIES LIKE LIKE
THAT THE LAST COULD BE
INSTABILITY AND THEY'RE
EXTREMELY LOW CHEMICAL
REACTIVITY REDUCES THE BODY'S
REACTION TO REJECT FOREIGN
MATERIALS. THEY ALSO HELP
PREVENT MICROORGANISMS FROM
COLONIZING SURGICAL INSTRUMENTS
STENTS CATHETERS MEDICAL
FILTERS INTO BEING WHICH COULD
POTENTIALLY LEAD TO INFECTIONS
AND OTHER COMPLICATIONS- ALSO
THE BILL WOULD BAN MANY
JUVENILE ON A TONIC DEVICES
WITH INSULATED WIRES PRINTED
CIRCUIT BOARDS OR TOUCH SCREENS
THINGS LIKE A CHILD'S LEARNING
TOY A BABY MONITOR. A READING
TABLET OR HANDHELD GAMING
DEVICE- THERE USED IN THOSE
DEVICES BECAUSE THEY ARE HIGHLY
RESISTANT TO TEMPERATURE AND
HAVE SUPERIOR OF LEXICAL
PROPERTIES. AND TIME IS- UP TO
PREVENT DAMAGE FROM MOISTURE.
OKAY YOUR TIME IS UP AND YOU
KNOW YOU REALLY HAVE TO LISTEN
TO THE TESTIMONY YOU JUST CAN'T
COME WITH A- SOMETHING YOU'VE
MADE UP AHEAD OF TIME AND READ
IT LISTEN TO THE TESTIMONY.
THESE YOU SPENT TWO MINUTES
TALKING ABOUT THINGS THAT THE
OFFER IS ALREADY CONCEDED ON.
I'VE HEARD ENOUGH AND YOU DID
GO TO YOUR TWO MINUTES. BUT
PLEASE LISTEN TO MY APOLOGIES-
I WAS I WAS READING FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BUT I DIDN'T MEAN TO
WHAT. TIME THE AUTHOR. THAT
THEY WERE NOT INCLUDED THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HEARD THIS
YOU COULD HAVE AT LEAST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY WERE
ALREADY EXCLUDED AND LEFT IT
THERE AND GIVE US SOMETHING
MORE SUBSTANTIAL. THANK YOU
NOW- IS FAR AS THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT- THE TSC AND GREEN
CHEMISTRY TAKING THIS ON. THIS
ISSUE FIRST CAME TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR YEARS AGO THERE'S
BEEN NO PROGRESS CENTS FOR
YEARS IS FOUR YEARS TOO LONG.
SECOND THE TSC SAID HAS SAID
THAT ALL OF THESE CHEMICALS
THAT WE TALK ABOUT THAT WOULD
BE IN JUVENILE PRODUCTS. SHOULD
BE TREATED AS A CLASS THAT'S
SOMETHING WE DIDN'T KNOW FOUR
YEARS AGO THERE WAS A BIG
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE VARIOUS
TYPES AND SHOULD THEY BE
CONSIDERED DIFFERENTLY. THERE
WAS NOT A CONSENSUS ON THAT
THAT CONSENSUS HAS BEEN REACHED
THEY SHOULD BE TREATED AS A
CLASS. ALL RIGHT. ANY QUESTIONS.
YES- CRISTINA GARCIA THANK YOU
ADD JUST A SHORT COMMENT- WHEN
I THINK THE UP THERE FOR
WORKING ON THIS- ON THE P. FAST
IN THE CLASS ISSUE WE KNOW THAT
IS THE FIRST CHANGE BEHAVE MUCH
LIKE THE LONG TEAMS AS THEY
BREAK DOWN- AND SO WHEN WE DID
AB SEVEN FIFTY SIX I WAS THERE
TO TAKE THAT STEP FORWARD TO
CALL THESE OF THE CLASS AND I
THINK THE LESSON HERE IS THAT
MY MOM WE DON'T KNOW EVERYTHING
THAT IN THE FUTURE WE KNOW THAT
THESE ARE PROBABLY GOING TO BE
PROBLEMS AND SO WE SHOULD BE
PROACTIVE AND SELF. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL.
MATAMATA REBEKKA BAY REFACTOR
BAUER K. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR HOME FOR THE BILL LIKE
YOU OF MANY OF THE THINGS I
FIND OUT IN THIS COMMITTEE
SPECIFICALLY MAKE ME VERY
FREAKED OUT OF THE MOTHER
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH WE CAN DO
SO THE GOVERNMENT HAS TO HELP
AND I GUESS THAT'S US. SO I
APPRECIATE THIS I. I'VE I
APPRECIATE A COUPLE THINGS ONE
IS. YEAH I STARTED ON THIS
COMMITTEE TWO YEARS AGO REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY DEPARTMENT AND THEIR
WORK YOU KNOW I. WE ALSO AS
PARENTS ABOUT EVERYTHING
WITHOUT BPA BECAUSE WE KNEW BPA
WAS BAD AND THEN WE LEARN. THE
PS IS JUST AS BAD AND IT TURNS
OUT WE'VE BEEN LETTING THEIR
KIDS USE THAT. SO THERE IS I
MEAN THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
DIVISION IS REALLY IMPORTANT IN
ENSURING WE DON'T MAKE THOSE
MISTAKES OF CREATING ORE
DANGEROUS ALTERNATIVES. BUT TO
THE CHAIRS POINTS. THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY DIVISION HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR OVER A DECADE. AND
BAD AND MADE THREE ROLES. RURAL
SO CLEARLYTHEY'RE NOT MOVING
FAST ENOUGH AND IT'S OUR
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT.
CALIFORNIANS WHERE THEY ARE
FAILING SO WE STARTED OUR DAY
WORKING ON DTS YOU'RE GOING TO
GET THERE BUT FOR NOW I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK. I WOULD
LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHY I MEAN A
LOT OF TIME WAS SPENT IN THE
OPPOSITION. TALKING ABOUT THE
PRODUCTS THAT YOU HAVE ALREADY
CONCEDED YOU WILL EMANATE SO WE
DON'T NEED TO WORRY ABOUT
MEDICAL DEVICES THAT I THINK
ALL OF US. THINK MEDICAL
DEVICES. GREEN AUTHOR SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE- SO FOR THE REMAINING
PRODUCTS THE CLOTHING THE
BASSINETS THE THINGS ARE
PUTTING OUR. CHILDREN AND WHY
ARE THESE EVEN IN THAT. WELL I
WOULD THEY SHOULDN'T BE OKAY
FULL STOP. BUT THEY TYPICALLY
PUT IN AS A STAIN RESISTANT
DEVICES SIMILAR TO WHAT WHY
THEY USE TOUGH ON- STANDS COME
OFF EASIER SO. THE MANUFACTURER
SAYS I HAVE DECIDED THAT FOR
THAT CONVENIENCE YOU WERE
WILLING TO RISK THE HEALTH OF
YOUR CHILD. AND I WOULD CONTEND
THAT IF WE SHOWED PARENTS THE
EVIDENCE OF THE PUMP CHEMICALS
THAT THEY'RE EVEN OUR THIS
ARRAY OF CHEMICALS ON THESE
PRODUCTS. THE BE HORRIFIED THAT
WE ALLOW IT I HAD NO IDEA THAT
THESE WERE ALLOWED. YOU GOT A
BABY CHEWING ON THE SIDE OF THE
BASSINET THERE CHEWING ON KEY
FOSS THAT WAS PUT THERE JUST SO
YOU COULD WIPE IT. CLEAN A
LITTLE BIT EASIER I TAKE THE
SAME. OVER THE TOXIC EXPOSURE
ANY DAY OF THE WEEK. THANK YOU
YES AND I THINK THAT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT TO MAKE WHICH
IS. MY KIDS CLOTHES WERE ALWAYS
ST STE NO MATTER WHAT THEY'RE
PUTTING ON THEM. I'LL TAKE THE
STAND- BUT YOU KNOW WE- IT'S
JUST INCOME AND I'M HONESTLY WE
DON'T REPLACE IT. WITH AN AD
THE OTHER DANGEROUS ALTERNATIVE
BECAUSE THAT IS ALWAYS MY FEAR
IN THESE BILLS BUT- OBVIOUSLY I
THINK THIS IS CRITICAL WORK AND
I'M- SUPPORT AS PART. THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD- MISTER MURATSUCHI
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST
WANTED TO- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS A
PARENT AND- APPRECIATE IF YOU
CAN ADD ME AS A CO AUTHOR. I
WOULD BE HONORED TO THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD ANYONE ELSE. ALL
RIGHT I THINK WE'VE GOT IT DONE
LET'S SEE THERE WAS AN EARLY.
OUR MOTION AND A SECOND SO
WEEKEND- ARE ASKED FOR CLOSE.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE
TO ASK YOUR CHAIR I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE ABLE
TO OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FONG YEAH.
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA- PLEASE-
PHONE LINES FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND AT ANY ONE HAS COMMENT
AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME BUT EIGHTY
ANTI SPECIALIST WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER ONE
THROUGH WHICH OF THE IDENTIFIED
WITH. WELL FIRST CORDYLINE
EIGHTY FIVE JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE OPEN UP YOUR
LINE HERE. NINE EIGHTY FIVE
YEAR OLD GO AHEAD PLEASE. YES
HELLO LAFAYETTE AND THE
PROGRESS CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS- ARE MEETING ALREADY
TAKEN EARLIER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL GO NEXT TO LINE SIXTY
FOUR LINE SIXTY FOR YOUR OPEN.
GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
PRESS OCULUS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS YOUR SHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE WILL NEXT
TO LINE SIXTY TWO. GOOD AFTER A
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS
OUT OF RECKLESS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WANTED TO. THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR- AGREED TO NARROW THE
DEFINITION THAT WAS OUR PRIMARY
OPPOSITION THAT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND-
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MISTER CHAMBERS JOHN LINGER ON
THE AFTER THE ADVANCED MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ADVAMED
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S COMMENT
BY NARROWING THE DEFINITION WE
HAVE NOT SEEN THE AMENDMENTS
YET AND WILL BE REVIEWING THEM
BUT CURRENTLY DO HAVE AN OPPOSE
ON THE- ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING I CAP THE WENCH
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LANGUAGE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BY. NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS OF THE BAR AND I
GO ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
JUVENILE PRODUCTS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION WE AS WELL WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THE UPCOMING AMENDMENTS AND WE
ARE WE THOUGHT A FEW CONCERNS
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH IT BUT THE AUTHOR AND THE
NEXT THING. NEXUS LINE FORTY
EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE. THIS IS
YOUR MEMBERS JUSTIN MALONE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS WITH
PARTICULAR CONCERN OVER THE
DRINKING WATER PROBLEMS AND
ALSO THEY CLEAN SEAS LOBBY
COALITION BECAUSE THE STAFF IS
ENDING UP IN OUR OCEANS AS WELL
THE ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU.
THAT'S YOUR MIND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO HAVE
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. WE'LL GO TO LINE. NINETY
FIVE. JOHN CAP TEMA Q. CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA. I WILL BE CURRENTLY
HAVING A POLITICAL POSITION ON
THE BILL AND WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO REVIEWING IT AND MENTION. HI
AND A HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORK
THE COUNTER THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. VERY GOOD-
SO I WAS A LITTLE PREMATURE.
BUT NOW YOU CAN CLOSE THIS RISK
I THINK THAT THIS IS REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND FOR FUTURE I HOPE
THAT THE INDUSTRY TAKES IT AS A
SIGNAL TO LOOK AT A WIDER RANGE
OF PRODUCTS- FOR ADULTS AS
WELL. WITH THAT I REQUEST FULLY.
QUESTION FIVE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU-
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN TO THESE ISSUES AND-
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER
BILL FOR US LATER. THAT I'LL BE
ANXIOUS TO SEE AS WELL SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND- I KNOW THAT
YOU'LL BE WORKING. WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO- PERHAPS REFINE
THE BILLS. AND YOU SAID YES AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT. AND NOW
WE CAN HAVE MADAM SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS ITEM FOR
AB SIX FIFTY TWO FRIEDMAN. THE
MOTION AS DO PASSED TO THE
FLOOR QUIRK ALL RIGHT WORK HI
SMITH WILL BE OPPOSE UNTIL I
SEE THE LANGUAGE OF YOUR
CHANGES FOR THE AMENDMENTS I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING IT
BUT THOSE CHANGES WHEN I READ.
SMITH NO ARAMBULA. OUR QUE HAN
OUR QUE HAN HI. DALLY GARCIA
GARCIA I HOLDEN HOLDEN I MATHIS.
MATHIS IS NOT VOTING WHEN I TO
CHANGE. WHAT TO G. I. WE HAVE
FIVE OF SIX ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBER. NOW WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVY. WHO IS
GOING TO GIVE AN EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION. AND HIS I BELIEVE
HIS FIRST ONE AT A COMMITTEE.
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
EXCELLENT BILL FORD. THIS. WELL
THE QUESTION IS A CLOSE NOW
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL I ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
FOR A JOINT AUTHORS THIS
IMPORTANT BILL- THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIX TWO SIX
FOR TECH STUDENTS FROM AIR
POLLUTION AND DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS IN YOUR SCHOOLS NO
MATTER WHAT SCHOOL THEY GO TO
PRIVATE PUBLIC OR CHARTER
EIGHTY SEVEN SIX TWO REQUIRES
PRIVATE CHARTER SCHOOLS TO MEET
THE SAME SAFETY REQUIREMENTS AS
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHEN CHOOSING A
NEW SCHOOL SITE. IN MY DISTRICT
A PRIVATE SCHOOL CALLED
STRATFORD SCHOOL WAS BUILT
RIGHT NEXT TO A CEMENT FACTORY
WITHIN FEET OF A PLAYGROUND IS
LATELY CEMENT PILES I DON'T
RECALL THEM BUT IN MY DISTRICT
A PART OF THE PROCESS OF MAKING
CONCRETE TO PUT CHEMICALS INTO
THE AIR AND THE CHILDREN ARE
SPECIALLY ESPECIALLY AT RISK
FOR HEALTH PROBLEMS I'M
THANKFUL FOR THE SUPPORT AND
ADVOCACY OF PARENTS FOR MY
DISTRICT. WHO SHOULD BE ON THE
LINE TODAY INCLUDING A SHENG
**** TO FONG SHELL AND CRYSTAL
DIED WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE
ATTENDED SHEPHERD SCHOOL AND
WILL BE CALLING AND HOPEFULLY
TO SUPPORT AND SHOULD OF
STORIES ASSEMBLY THIS ISN'T THE
ONLY EXAMPLE IN SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THERE ARE PLANS
TO BUILD A CHARTER SCHOOL IN A
PSYCH CONTAINING LEAD AND
ARSENIC STUDENTS SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO PUT THEIR HEALTH AT
RISK BY GOING TO CLASS SIMPLY.
AB SEVEN SIX TWO WILL ENSURE
THAT POTENTIAL HAZARDS AND
SOURCES OF POLLUTION YOUR
PRIVATE AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
SITES OR DEFIED INVESTIGATED SO
THAT SCHOOLS CAN BE BUILT IN
SAFE LOCATIONS I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE CALIFORNIA SURF YOUR
PRIDE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE SCHOOL
ORGANIZATIONS FOR CALLING THIS
BILL A SENSIBLE REASONABLE AND
PRACTICABLE MEASURE SO VERY
NICE. I THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
HELLO IT'S AN I WILL BE HAVE.
ALLEN ABS FROM THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AS
OUR TESTIMONY SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
SO THIS WITNESSES IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM- ALL YOU HAVE
TO DO IS START SPEAKING AND THE
SYSTEM WILL COME ON. MISTER
WORKING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS ALAN
ABSENT THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICER
WITH THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WHICH WORKS
TO PROVIDE A HEALTHIER
ENVIRONMENT TO NEARLY EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE NINE
COUNTY BAY AREA REGION. THE BAY
AREA AT&T IS A PROUD SPONSOR OF
AB SEVEN SIXTY TWO AND WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EARLY FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TO PROTECT
CHILDREN'S HEALTH. IN CURRENT
LAW PRIOR TO CONSTRUCTING A NEW
PUBLIC SCHOOL OR PUBLICLY
FUNDED CHARTER SCHOOL SCHOOL
AUTHORITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
PERFORM SEVERAL ACTS OF DUE
DILIGENCE TO BETTER ENSURE THE
HEALTH OF THEIR FUTURE STUDENTS
AND SCHOOL STAFF. THEY
DETERMINE THAT THE PROPERTY TO
BE BUILT UPON IS NOT A FORMER.
A CURRENT OR FORMER HAZARDOUS
WASTE SITE OR HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES RELEASE SITE. AND
THEY CONSULT WITH STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES AND MAKE A
FINDING THAT THE HEALTH RISKS
OR OTHER POLLUTION SOURCES DO
NOT AND WILL NOT CONSTITUTE. AN
ACTUAL OR POTENTIAL
ENDANGERMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TO PERSONS WHO WOULD ATTEND OR
BE EMPLOYED AT THE SCHOOL. THIS
INCLUDES WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
OR AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT TO IDENTIFY BOTH
PERMITTED AND NON PERMITTED
FACILITIES WITHIN THAT
DISTRICTS AUTHORITY. INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO FREEWAYS AND
OTHER BUSY TRAFFIC CORRIDORS
LARGE AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS
AND RAILYARDS WITHIN ONE FOURTH
OF A MILE OF THE PROPOSED
SCHOOL SITE. THAT MIGHT
REASONABLY BE ANTICIPATED TO
ADMIT HAZARDOUS AIR EMISSIONS.
THIS IS A REQUIREMENT THAT DOES
NOT CURRENTLY APPLY TO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS AND SOME CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND WHILE WE ARE NOT
CLAIMING THAT A LARGE NUMBER OF
THE SCHOOLS ARE POORLY CITED.
INCREASING LAND USE DENSITY AND
RE PURPOSING INFILL SITES
RAISES THE POSSIBILITY THAT
WITHOUT SIMILAR DUE DILIGENCE.
FUTURE SCHOOLS MAY BE
CONSTRUCTED IN THE VICINITY OF
POLLUTION SOURCES THAT
UNNECESSARILY EXPOSE CHILDREN.
IN SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AND CREATE
AN UNHEALTHY WORK ENVIRONMENT.
EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO REQUIRES
THE SCHOOL AUTHORITIES TO
ASSESS THE HAZARDOUS WASTE AND
AIR POLLUTION CONDITIONS. ON
AND IN THE VICINITY OF THE
PROPOSED SCHOOL. TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS INFORMATION AND IF
NECESSARY TO USE IT IN THEIR
DECISION MAKING PROCESS WHEN
CONSTRUCTING THEIR SCHOOL. ON
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT I AGAIN
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAVE FOR
OFFERING THIS BILL. AND I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU- SO WE- IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE ARE ON VIDEO
COM IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCE
AREA WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. OR IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BELL. NOW I WILL GET TO THE
PHONE LINES LATER- IS THERE ANY
PRIMARY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
I DON'T SEE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE JERRY WHOSE PRIMARY
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES WHO IS- WISHES
TO TAKE TIME IS PRIMARY
OPPOSITION. MR OUT WE HAVE TO
KEEP IT UP ON THE- YES SIR
HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
TO CUED UP WE'RE NOT CERTAIN OF
THEIR STANCE ON FORTUNATELY- AS
WELL AS THEY WERE QUEUING UP
WITH THEIR TURNOUT NUMBERS
ALREADY GIVEN ALL RIGHT WHY
DON'T YOU STOP THEIR LINES WHY
DON'T WE JUST OPENED THEIR
LINES AND STATE WHETHER YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AND
WHETHER YOU WANT MORE THAN JUST
TO STATE YOUR NAME AND- YOUR IN
OPPOSITION AND YOU WANTED
STATE. TO MORE THAN STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION LET ME
NOW. SO WILL GO FIRST TO LINE.
SIXTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST RENDON TO LIKE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE- THIRTY FIVE
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM THE
THIRTY FIVE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE- TWO ONE ZERO TWO GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU
JONATHAN CLAY ON TOP OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
A SCENE NO ONE ELSE ON THE LINE
OH WAIT YOU HAVE ANOTHER LINE.
I HAVE TWO MORE LINES ONE LINE
ONE ELEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KATHY VAN OSTERN REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA- IN
STRONG SUPPORT. IT WILL GO TO
LINE ONE ALL FOUR THAT'S ONE
ZERO FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS A SOUND ONE
I FULLY SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BUILD
SEVEN SIXTY TWO A AND I
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
USE ADWORDS ENOUGH. INTRODUCED
IN THE BILL AND THE PROTECTED
CHILDREN. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
A LOT FOR THEIR- BUDGET YOU. NO
MORE IN Q. OKAY THEN WE WILL
GET TO QUESTIONS. NOT VERY GOOD
TO MISS GARCIA IS THE JOINT
AUTHORS AT THAT THANK YOU TO
MISTER LEE OF THOSE WORKING ON
THIS- THE SOUTHEAST SCHOOL THAT
YOU MENTION IT IN MY DISTRICT
AND ONE OF THE LEAD IT'S JUST
SUCH A FIGHT THAT WHILE IT'S
NOT. COMMON PRACTICE THERE'S A
CONCERN THAT YOU'LL SEE MORE OF
THAT AND I SEE YOU'RE SEEING
THAT WHILE NOW I HAVE TO
ADDITIONAL CHARTER SCHOOLS
LOOKING TO BUILD ON TO
ADDITIONAL BROWNFIELDS IN MY
DISTRICT I LIVE IN ONE OF THE
DENTIST OF CULTS AND THE
COUNTRY AND THE SPONSORS ARE
SOME OF THE ONLY SPACE WE HAVE
LEFT AND IT'S- PRETTY INSULTING
THAT. WE ARE CONSIDERING-
OPENING SCHOOLS ON TOP OF THE
STATE'S WHEN THEY'RE NOT
PROPERLY REMEDIATED AND SO I
ENCOURAGE THIS TO MOVE QUICKLY
AND TO BE A BIPARTISAN EFFORT
TO PROTECT OUR KIDS. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. K. HAVE. ALL
THIS CAN MR LEON FOR A
PRESENTATION BEFORE US AND THAT
THANK YOU THIS WORK IS I'VE
REALLY WE HAD A PUBLIC SCHOOL
THAT WAS BEING BUILT ON- I SITE
THAT HAD WITH FORMER TOXIC
INFILL IT WAS PROPERLY CLEANED
INTERMEDIATE AND THEY WORK WITH
LOCAL AGENCIES AND DID EXACTLY
WHAT YOU HEAR HAPPENS A PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IT IS CRITICAL THAT ALL
CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
WORK AGAIN NO MATTER WHERE THEY
LIVE. WHAT THERE'S A CODE IS OR
WHAT THE NATURE OF THE SCHOOL
ITSELF WOULD LOVE TO JOIN YEARS
AGO AROUND SOMETHING LIKE.
EXCELLENT ANYONE ELSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR REPRESENTATION
FOR FIRST TIMER NON. AND LIKE
WHERE YOU'RE GOING WITH THIS
ITEM WHEN I SEE. OPPOSITION AND
CONCERNS GET ADDRESSED MORE SO
ONCE WE GET TO THAT POINT FOR
TO SEE WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE A
YEAR YOUR DROPPED A GOOD START
GOOD THANK. OKAY SO WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN ANY LETTERS IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
SURPRISE ANYTHING ELSE. OKAY MR
LEE EXCELLENT PRESENTATION THAT
PERIOD THANK YOU- JUST WANT TO
SAY REALLY QUICKLY AGAIN WANT
TO THANK ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THANK AS YOU HEARD
ONE OF THE PARENTS TAKE THE
TIME ANOTHER DAY TO EXPRESS
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
PERSONAL TO A LOT OF FAMILIES
IN OUR DISTRICT AND FREMONT AS
WELL AS CRISTINA GARCIA'S
DISTRICT AS WELL I'M CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW THIS WHOLE AN
AMBIGUITY IN LAW HAS ALLOWED
UNFORTUNATELY THESE EXAMPLES
EXIST AND BY CLARIFYING AND I
HOPE THAT NO MORE CHILDREN WILL
BE ENDANGERED BY HAVING THEIR
SCHOOL SIMPLY PUT. A DANGER
SIGN SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. SOME THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD I RECOMMENDED HI. AND
MADAM SECRETARY MAY CALL CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB SEVEN SIXTY TWO LEE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
CORK BY CORK ICE SMITH THAT'S A
FELLOW FRESHMAN GOOD JOB TODAY
LEAVE BUT I'M GOING TO HOLD OFF
UNTIL WE HEAR THESE OPPOSITION
LEADERS BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH KIDS IT'S ALL
ABOUT THE KIDS RIGHT. HELLO
OKAY SMITH NOT VOTING. ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN. BARRICADE HANNAH
HI DALLY. CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA I HOLDEN HOLDEN HI
MATHIS. MATHIS NOT VOTING. WHAT
I TO CHANGE. I'M GONNA TO GI.
WE HAVE FIVE VOTES THE TOP.
THANK YOU. HELLO OKAY THE WAY-
THANK NUMBER HAS A LONG TIME.
OKAY THE NEW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- LET ME JUST FIRST THANK
YOU AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL
THE HELP. ON THIS BILL REALLY
APPRECIATED- SO AB TWELVE
HUNDRED THREE FOR FOOD
PACKAGING COOKWARE ACT PROTECTS
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENCE.
ENVIRONMENT BY REDUCING HUMAN
EXPOSURE TO AN ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTAMINATION FROM P. FAST AND
HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS- I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT THIS THIS
FALLS ALREADY WITH NEW YORK'S
DONE. MCDONALD'S AND CHIPOTLE
HAVE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT HOW
TO PHASE OUT OR BAN PEOPLE OUT
FROM PAPER BASED TO FOOD
PACKAGING. I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
HERE TO PRESENT- ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF ARE SAFE FOR FOOD
PACKAGING INCORRECT FIRST WE
HAVE ANNA READ. A STAFF
SCIENTIST WITHIN OUR DC AS WELL
AS NANCY BROOKMYRE SENIOR
POLICY STRATEGIST WITH BREAST.
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS.
VERY GOOD. SO YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH OR YOU CAN SPLIT
IT UP A DIFFERENT WAY. FIRST
LET'S HEAR FROM ANNA REED OF
NRDC. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIR CREEK AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS MARRIED AND I
AM NOT RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL'S LEAD SCIENTIST ON
PIZZA. AND ARGUE THESE THE
COURT AB TWELVE HUNDRED TO
RESTRICT THE UNNECESSARY USE OF
PEOPLE PASSING PRE PACKAGING.
INDEPENDENT SCIENTISTS NOT
THIRTY TO BODIES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIANS AND PARKS
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL HAVE CONCLUDED THAT P.
FAST AFTER CLASS BUDGETARY
CONFINEMENT ONE PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS AND LAST YEAR. THE
LEGISLATURE FAITH OUT. THE USE
OF ALL P. AND THIRD PARTY. AS
COVERED EARLIER BY DR ANDREWS
PEOPLE ARE SEARCHING. CAN BUILD
UP IN OUR BODIES NOW SYSTEM
WITH A Y. ARRAY OF. HEALTH
EFFECTS. STUDIES HAVE
IDENTIFIED A HIGH PROBLEMS AS-
I JUST MODIFIED AND OTHER BASED
PRODUCTS CONTAIN P. FAST. THESE
PRODUCTS CAN EXPOSE CONSUMERS
TO ACTIVATE EACH ENTER
CONTAMINATION OF WATER AND FOOD
PRODUCTS THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIFECYCLE. ESPECIALLY DURING
PRODUCTION AND END OF LIFE FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN ACCOMPLISHED CAN-
CONTAMINATED WITH THE FACT
FINDING TRIP PACKAGING.
PHARMACY USES COMPOST IN THEIR
FIELDS CAN INADVERTENTLY
CONTAMINATE THE GROUNDWATER
CROPS AND LIVESTOCK. THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT MULTIPLE COMPANIES
CURRENTLY PRODUCED BE FAST
FOOD. PACKAGING SITE P. FAST
FREAK THREE PACKAGING AND
INDUSTRY IS FALLING OR LEAD
MAJOR CHAINS LIKE MCDONALD'S
CHIPOTLE AND WHOLE FOODS. AND
SMALLER CHAINS LIKE SWEETGREEN
HAVE MADE COMMITMENTS TO AND
THE USE OF P. FASCINATED
PACKAGING. FOR LOCAL SIX TO
SUCH A SAN FRANCISCO BERKELEY
HAVE ALREADY FOR OUT THE THAT
THE CONTAIN FEEDBACK. AND MOST
ROAD TO THIS YOUR- STATE
RECENTLY BANNED PEOPLE AFTER
CRAPPIE SWEET PACKAGE STARTING
DECEMBER TWENTY. GIVEN THE
EXTREME CHRISTOPHER OF THE
CHEMICALS YOU NOW HAVE CAUGHT.
FOR DECADES COME. GIVEN ME A-
OF ALTERNATIVE IT'S TIME TO
THINK ABOUT THE UNNECESSARY USE
OF P. PASS KEY PRODUCT CATEGORY.
YEAH FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OF YOU MISTER- WILL NOW HEAR
FROM NANCY- BUT MEYER. THANK
YOU WORKING MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY MY
NAME IS NANCY B. R. MEYER AND I
WORK FOR BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS AND I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL CO SPONSORS. PPP
CENTER PERRIN BERMAN HOW CLEAN
WATER ACTION ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP AND AN RTC. AB
TWELVE HUNDRED BANS THE SALE
AND DISTRIBUTION OF FOOD
PACKAGING CONTAINING
INTENTIONALLY OUT OF PEACE
HOUSE. YEAH JUST LAID OUT ABOUT
THIS IS SO I WILL FOCUS ON THE
COOKWARE PORTION OF THE BILL.
WHICH REQUIRES COMPANIES TO
DISCLOSE CHEMICALS OF CONCERN
COOKWARE AND PROHIBITS
MARKETING CLAIMS THAT MISLEAD
CONSUMERS INTO THINKING A
PRODUCT IS FREE A PROBLEMATIC
CLASSES OF CHEMICALS. SUCH AS
PIZZA. RECENT TESTING SOUND
CHEMICALS IN BOTH COOK AND
BAKEWARE SPECIFICALLY P. FAST
CHEMICALS SUCH AS PTSD OFTEN
KNOWN BY THE BRAND NAME TEFLON.
IN THE HORMONE DISRUPTING
CHEMICAL CALLED ISRAEL AND IT
WILL BE PA. YOU CAN BE REAL
INTO THE AIR WHEN HANDS REACH
HIGH TEMPERATURES WHICH EXPOSES
CONSUMERS. AND CONSUMERS HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW THIS TOXIC
CHEMICALS ARE IN THE COOK WHERE
THEY USED TO PREPARE FOOD FOR
THEIR FAMILIES. AND WHEN BUYING
PANS OFTEN THE CLAIM PFOA OR
PFOS FREE OR OTHER SIMILAR
CLAIMS ON PACKAGING. GIVING
THEM THE FALSE IMPRESSION THE
PRODUCT IS FREE OF ALL SIMILAR
TOXIC CHEMICALS. IN FACT HE
CELEBRATE PANS ARE OFTEN MADE
WITH ANOTHER FORM OF PEACE US.
MANUFACTURER SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO MISLEAD CONSUMERS AB
TWELVE HUNDRED PROHIBIT A CLAIM
A CLAIM THAT THE PANDAS FREE OF
A PARTICULAR CHEMICAL THAT'S
ANOTHER AZARDOUS CHEMICALS.
FROM THE SAME CLASS AS PRESENT.
I WANT TO THANK SOMEONE TING'S
HIS LONG TERM THE ON ISSUE AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CO SPONSORS
AND OVER FIFTY NGO COMPANY AND
PUBLIC AGENCIES SUPPORTERS I
ASK FOR YOUR ON. VERY GOOD NOW
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
WHO IS IN THIS ROOM AND I DON'T
SEE ANYONE. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE WHO- IS IN
SUPPORT IF SO SPEAK UP NOW.
THEN SEEN NO ONE- WILL GO TO
THE OPPOSITION. FIRST WE'LL
HEAR FROM HIM CHAU STACK ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL- PLEASE
PROCEED ARE ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU DR CORK- NEVER THAT MANY
THINK DEFINITELY AND THE
COUNCIL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY. I
WANT TO FOCUS MY COMMENTS. ON
THAT THE SECOND HALF OF THE
BILL THE PROPOSED LABELING
REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR COOKWARE.
THE BILL REQUIRING A NEW LABEL
ESSENTIALLY TO HELP LABEL. ON
PRODUCTS THAT WILL CONTAIN ONE
OR MORE CHEMICALS OF CONCERN
FOR HUMAN HEALTH OR THE
ENVIRONMENT AT THE END OF BY BY
THE STATE CALIFORNIA. AT
BACKGROUND- THE BILL USES THE
HE CAN'T HE CAN'T A CHEMICAL
LIST WHICH IS ONLY BOUT THREE
THOUSAND SO CHEMICAL. COMPILED
FROM VARIOUS AUTHORITATIVE
LIST. THAT MAKE THAT A CERTAIN
HAVE OR TRADE. I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THIS IS NOT A FAN
LIST. NOR DOES IT INDICATE THAT
YOU COUNTLESS PROS A POTENTIAL
THREAT TO HUMAN HEALTH THE
ENVIRONMENT AS THEY MIGHT BE
USED. IN PACIFIC PRODUCT
APPLICATION. AND THAT WITH THIS
IS WELL BEYOND JUST. FOCUSING
ON. THE BALLOT IN THE STREET.
EVEN UNDER PROP SIXTY. PRODUCT
WITH THE DISCOUNT. THAT MAY
RESULT IN EXPO BELOW SIR
THRESHOLD. THEY LEVEL OF YOU
WILL ARE NOT OBLIGATED TO
PROVIDE A WARM. AND OUR VIEW
THIS BILL DOES NOT APPEAR TO
HAVE ANY SORT OF SIMILAR
PROVISION- NOR TAKING ACCOUNT
ANY SORT OF- THE MINIMUM LEVEL.
WE THINK IT WOULD BE A
TROUBLING PRECEDENT REQUIRE A
WARNING LABEL- THAT IN OUR VIEW
INAPPROPRIATELY- HEALTH AND
HUMAN THE PRODUCT THEY MAY BE
USING- IS NOT IT POTENTIAL RISK
TO HUMAN HEALTH THE ENVIRONMENT
SO. WE LOOK FORWARD TO MINISTER
PAYING THE SPONSORS THE
PROGRESS ON THESE ISSUES- THAT
WE'VE OUTLINED IN OUR- WRITTEN
ON IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY DOESN'T. VERY
GOOD- LET'S SEE NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM. SEAN US WERE INJURED ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL PLEASE
PROCEED. INTERMENT MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SEAN
SWEAR ENGINE I'M THE DIRECTOR
FOR THE ALLIANCE FOR
TELEMARKETERS TO STEWARDSHIP.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE- AB
TWELVE HUNDRED BECAUSE THE
FOLLOWING NEEDS THE LANGUAGE I
ONE AND AN UPDATED THE FACT
THAT MISSION- AGREE BY THE END
OF THE TIME WANTED TO BE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE FDA WITH THE
PROHIBITION COMMENCE IN JANUARY
ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND
THEN ALSO EIGHT. ALLOWANCE OF
THOSE ITEMS ALREADY IN COMMERCE
IN CALIFORNIA AT. ONCE THEY
AFFECT. THE ACT TAKES PLACE- AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED P. FASTER
DIVERSE UNIVERSITY CHEMISTRY
WITH THE WIDE RANGE CRITICAL
USES. AN ACCURATE DEFINITION OF
A P. PASSED UP FOR THE DAILY
CAMPUS TREES IS NEEDED-
PACKAGES REGULATED BY THE FDA.
MANUFACTURES THE MAJORITY HE
PASSED PRODUCT USED IN FOOD
PACKAGING AGREED TO A VOLUNTARY
PHASE OUT OF SALE OF THESE
PRODUCTS FOR USE IN FOOD
PACKAGING. AS OF JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AS YOU LIKE
IT ADVANCEMENT FTA CONCLUDED
DESPAIGNE UPGRADED NEEDED TO
AVOID UNNECESSARY. SUPPLY CHAIN
MARKET DISRUPTIONS. AS
MENTIONED BY THE SPONSOR AND
OTHERS- THERE ARE ACT CONSUMERS
AND USERS THAT ARE LOOKING TO-
MAKE THIS PHASE OUT POSSIBLE A
MCDONALD'S- TIMELINES TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. SO THE REQUEST OF-
AND MANAGED TO MAKE THE
EFFECTIVE DATE JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. WOULD BE A
MINUTE WITH NOT JUST FTA BUT
ALSO- THE MARKET THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME TO GET THAT BIND THE
COR TO WORK WITH THE BILL'S
SPONSOR. A VERY GOOD I BELIEVE
YOU'VE AGREED TO THE JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IS THAT
CORRECT YES PLEASE STAND UP
YEAH OKAY SAID THAT'S BEEN
AGREED TO. ALL RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM NOW WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
AND THEN IF THERE'S SOMEONE ON
VIDEO CONFERENCE- PLEASE SPEAK
UP NOW. THEY'RE BEING AND NONE-
WE CAN NOW ASK FOR THE PHONE
LINES TO BE OPENED AND PLEASE
GIVE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHERE THEY ARE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. WE WILL FIRST GO TO LINE
THIRTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE
APARTMENT ONE THIRTEEN QUIET
PLACE. ONE THIRTEEN- WE'RE SEEM
TO HAVE DIFFICULTY OPENING YOUR
LINE IF YOU COULD PLEASE RE
QUEUE. OCAL TO LINE. ONE TEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE I'M HAVING
SOME TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES IF
YOU'LL BEAR WITH ME FOR JUST A
SECOND PLEASE. IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM EVERYONE. YES SIR ONE
SECOND PLACE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY FIVE JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE OPEN YOUR LINE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND PARDON
ME MISTER CHAIR I'LL ATTEMPT TO
RESUME THE COMMENTS PERIOD-
VERY WELL THEN WE'LL HAVE THAT
FOR A MOMENT OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND. THIRTEEN
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD PARDON ME THAT WOULD
COULD NOT WORK. IN THE TRY LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND PAN. THEY CAN
MY APOLOGIES MISTER CHAIR JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE LOOK AT IT AND
TO RESOLVE THE ISSUE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE LATENESS AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU HAVE SIGNALED
THAT YOU WISH TO SPEAK TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. HEY AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO FIRST TO LINE.
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DONNED KHAKI
WITH MCCUE CAPTAIN AFFECTED
SOMEHOW THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY COUNCIL CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTY TWO. THE MORNING CARE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ADAM
RADLEY WITH A CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ONE ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITHIN TRAFFIC OF
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
BUT OUR CONCERNS AROUND A NEW
LABELING- PROP SIXTY FIVE LIKE
SYSTEM THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY
EIGHT. MEMBERS JUSTIN LEARN
ABOUT HOP OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPOSTING COALITION AND ALSO
THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN CITIES TO
LOBBY COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE. ONE OH FIVE. I
WANNA FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THAT NEED
MORE WHILE ON BEHALF OF
RECOLOGY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LINE FORTY ONE. HELLO THIS IS
ANDREA EVAN TURNER WITH CLEAN
WATER ACTION ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
READ SOME OF THE SUPPORT- SO ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE OF
NURSES FOR HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
SANITATION AGENCIES THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICTS. COMP THE COMPOST
MANUFACTURING ALLIANCE THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RECYCLING
ASSOCIATION. THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA. WORKSAFE
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO BAY KEEPER BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE I WOULD ADD THAT IN
ADDITION TO THE SUPPORTERS
THERE ARE A TOTAL- IN THE
ANALYSIS AT SIXTY FIVE
SUPPORTERS WE OBVIOUSLY WANT TO
RESPECT. THE NEED FOR BREVITY
TODAY SO WE WON'T READ THEM ALL
OUT BUT WE HOPE THAT THIS LIST
THAT I JUST GAVE YOU SHOWS YOU
THE DIVERSITY OF INTERESTS THAT
WANT TO SEETHIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS YOUR WE DO HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON WHO SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO TRY AND SPEAK
BEFORE AND WISH TO SPEAK NOW ON
THE BILL I HAVE NOT HAD A
CHANCE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO WE NOW GOING TO GO TO LINE.
ONE FOURTEEN. I WANT OUR
MEMBERS- PARTIES ARE CASHING
CHAIRMAN BURKE TO FORTY DOLLARS
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PRODUKTER SHIPPED COUNCIL AND
NATIONAL. ACTION COMPLICATED
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BUT YOU SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. VERY
GOOD AND THANK YOU OPERATOR WE
ALL HAVE PROBLEMS WITH
TECHNOLOGY FROM TIME TO TIME-
WE WORK THROUGH THAT WHEN. WELL
THANK YOU AGAIN- SO DO WE HAVE
A QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. WE
DON'T SEEM TO- SO THE
OPPOSITION RAISED A NUMBER OF
ISSUES UNFORTUNATELY WE GOT THE
OPPOSITION LATE LETTER A LITTLE
LATER- SO WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
HELP THE AUTHOR RESPOND I THINK
THERE'S A NUMBER OF REASONABLE
REQUEST IN THERE- I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE CAN REACH CONSENSUS BUT
IT I DO THINK WE CAN ADDRESS A
NUMBER OF THEM- SO AND- ONE OF
MY ONE OF MY OWN CONCERNS IS
ABOUT TO DEMAND A MISS LEVELS-
SO IF THERE ARE. NO QUESTIONS-
PERHAPS- MISTER CHANG YOU COULD
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LET ME JUST- COMMITTEE YOU WHEN
YOUR COMMITTEE THAT WE'RE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO. WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO TRY TO RESOLVE
THESE ISSUES- I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT I THINK MANY OF THEM ARE
RESOLVABLE. WILL KEEP KEEP
WORKING WITH THEM- WE THINK
THIS IS A VERY REASONABLE BILL
TO. AGAIN TO HAVE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF DISCLOSURE. ALSO TO
MAKE SURE THAT. IS THIS THE P.
FACETS ARE BANNED. FROM PLANT
BASED FOOD PACKAGING IT AGAIN-
MAKING SURE. THAT THIS PROPER
DISCLOSURE OF P. FAST BUT ALSO
HAS A OTHER HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS
AROUND COOKWARE. SEEMS VERY
REASONABLE FOR CONSUMERS SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE YES THANK YOU
AND AGAIN THAT DID TO MINIMUS
LEVEL I BELIEVE IS GOING TO BE
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE ALL GOING TO
NEED TO. MAKE SURE IS WELL
RESOLVED WITHIN THE BILL- AGAIN
I'M GOING TO SAY THAT FOUR
YEARS AGO- A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS BILL WAS BURKE
FORWARD WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS THAN. WE
ARE ALSO HOPING THAT IT COULD
BE ADDRESSED WITH GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM AND IT'S FOUR
YEARS LATER AND- WELL THEY HAVE
LOOKED AT POSSIBLY CONSIDERING
THIS THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT
THEY WILL. SO I THINK IT'S JUST
TIME FOR THE- ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE TO ASK AND HOPEFULLY GET
THE CONCURRENT INTO HOPEFULLY
GET THE CONCURRENCE OF THE
GOVERNOR- THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL I THINK THE SCIENCES WELL
DETERMINED AT THIS TIME. THERE
BEING NOTHING ELSE MADAM
SECRETARY I HAVE WE HAVE A
MOTION YES SO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ITEM SIX AB TWELVE
HUNDRED CHIANG THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE FLOOR QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I SMITH I WILL OF
STATE UNTIL WE SEE THE LANGUAGE
CHANGE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE SUPPORT OF IT. SMITH NOT
VOTING ARAMBULA. BARRICADE HAN
DALLY. GARCIA GARCIA I HOLDEN
HOLDEN EIN MATHIS MATHIS NOT
VOTING WHAT I TO CHANGE. OKAY
WE NEED TO KEEP THE YOUNG
WILSON WILL BE ADDING ON I
SUSPECT WE'LL GET OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT- COMMITTEE MEMBER
HOLDEN. AB ONE HUNDRED DRINKING
WATER PIPES AND FITTINGS LEAD
CONTENT AGAIN THIS IS ONE OF
THESE BILLS THAT- HAS BEEN
DELAYED BY- THE- PANDEMIC. WE
WILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH US ON THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC- THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE HUNDRED WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH A LEAD LEACHING
PERFORMANCE STANDARD TO COMPLY
AS LEAD FREE. IT WOULD REQUIRE
IN USE FIXTURES TO LEEDS LESS
THAN ONE MILLIGRAM PER LITER
LED. IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THE NSF INTERNATIONAL TESTED
FIVE HUNDRED FAUCETS THAT MET
THE CALIFORNIA LEAD CONTENT
STANDARDS AND FOUND THAT 25% OF
THE FAUCET AND LET- TESTED
LEACHED NOTICEABLE AMOUNTS OF
LEAD. WE ALL EXPECT THE WATER
WE DRINK WILL KEEP US HEALTHY
AND NOT MAKE IT SICK.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN WORKING TO
REDUCE RESIDENTS EXPOSURE TO
LED YET. LET IS STILL REACHING
INTO OUR DRINKING WATER THROUGH
FAUCETS AND FIXTURES. THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE ALL FAUCETS AND
FIXTURES LEACH AS LITTLE AS
POSSIBLE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE I HAVE SUSAN
LITTLE SENIOR ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
AND CLAUDIA- G. WITH COVERAGE.
ALL RIGHT- SUSAN LITTLE IS IN
THE VICINITY HIS IN THE WITNESS
PROTECTION. OKAY THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM TO FILL
UP THE SUSAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK UP AND- WILL HEAR YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR QUIRK CHAIR- MY NAME
AGAIN IS SUSAN LITTLE AND I'M
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
AB ONE HUNDRED. AS YOU KNOW THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL HAS
STATED THAT THERE IS NO SAFE
LEVEL OF LEAD IN CHILDREN. THIS
IS BECAUSE EVEN VERY SMALL
AMOUNTS OF LEAD CAN CAUSE
PERMANENT HARM LEADING TO
LEARNING AND BEHAVIORAL
DIFFICULTIES. GIVEN THAT
SERIOUS AFFECTS CALIFORNIA'S
LICENSED CHILD CARE CENTERS
WILL SOON BE TESTING THEIR
DRINKING WATER FOR LEAD WITH
THE ASSISTANCE OF ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF PUBLIC
FUNDS. AND THESE FUNDS WILL BY
THE CENTER'S NEW FAUCETS SHOULD
CENTERS NEED TO REPLACE
FIXTURES TO GET LET OUT OF
THEIR WATER. A MUCH STRONGER
LEAD LEACHING STANDARD FOR
FAUCETS WAS HAS BEEN RECENTLY
APPROVED WITH INDUSTRY SUPPORT.
BY THE NATIONAL SANITATION
FOUNDATION THE NSF A THIRD
PARTY CERTIFIER. HOWEVER THIS
NEW STANDARD WILL NOT APPLY TO
ALL FAUCETS IN THE U. S. MARKET
UNTIL AT LEAST TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT. IN THE MEANTIME THE
LOWER LEACHING FAUCETS WILL NOT
BE EASY TO IDENTIFY OR
PURCHASE. IN FACT CLEAN WATER
ACTION ONE OF AB ONE HUNDRED CO
SPNSORS PERFORMED AS BAY OF
FAUCETS ON THE CIRCLE HOME
DEPOT- DEPARTMENTS HOME DEPOT
STORES. NONE OF THE FAUCET
PACKAGES REVIEWED CONTAINED
VISIBLE INFORMATION ABOUT US
ITS LEAD LEACHING STANDARD.
SCHOOLS CHILD CARES AND
CONSUMERS WANT TO PURCHASE
FAUCETS THAT LEACH HAS LITTLE
THAT IS POSSIBLE. AB ONE
HUNDRED WILL ADDRESS THE NEED
THIS NEED AND REQUIRE ALL
FAWCETT SOLD IN CALIFORNIA TO
MEET THE NOTE NEW LOW LEACHING
STANDARD. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE HUNDRED I'D
ALSO LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
READ ALOUD. SOME OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL BEFORE I
PASS THIS ON TO CLAUDIA DEEP
WITH CAL PARK OTHER SUPPORTERS
INCLUDE CLEAN CLEAN WATER
ACTION A CO SPONSOR ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA. ERIC THE ERIN
BROCKOVICH FOUNDATION
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS CALIFORNIA
COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE BREAST
CANCER AND YOUR PARTNER'S FAX
FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR
CHEMICAL AND TOXINS. FRIEND'S
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA. COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION. WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY. ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH COALITION ALLIANCE OF
NURSES FOR HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS
INTEGRATED RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
LLC SAN FRANCISCO BAY
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL. LUÍT
AND THE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU- THEN WE'D
LIKE TO HEAR ON THE PHONE FROM
CLAUDIA GAG ON BEHALF OF THE
ARAFAT KELBERG. I THANK YOU YES
MY NAME IS CLAUDIA DEAN I'M NOT
PUBLIC HEALTH ASSOCIATE WITH
HEALTHCARE THE PAST TWO YEARS
CALPERS HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO GET LET OUT OF
THE DRINKING WATER IN THEIR
SCHOOLS. INCLUDING SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED FRESNO UNIFIED AND
OAKLAND UNIFIED ATHLETES RECENT
TESTING AT SCHOOL WORK HAS
SHOWN THAT LEAD CONTAMINATION
IS WIDESPREAD ACROSS THE STATE.
ACCORDING TO OUR JULY TWENTY
TWENTY ANALYSIS UP DRINKING
WATER TESTING DATA REPORTED TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE WATER
BOARD MORE THAN THIRTEEN
HUNDRED SQUAWKING CALIFORNIA
FOUND DANGEROUS LEVELS OF LEAD
IN THEIR WATER FOR MORE THAN
HALF OF THE COURTING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OUR
WORLD SUBURBAN AND URBAN AREAS.
MEDIATION IS CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING STUDENT HEALTH AND
SAFETY A FAUCET AND OTHER
DRINKING WATER FIXTURES ARE A
KEY PART OF THE SOLUTION AB
EIGHT UNIFIED THE FIRST
DISTRICT IN THE STATE TO ADOPT
A STRICTER STANDARD ON LEAD IN
DRINKING WATER. TESTED
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS AND ONE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TO FIND THE
BEST PLAN TO GET A LOT OUT HE
FOUNDED THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF
LEAD CONTAMINATION ONCE THE
FAUCET AND DRINKING WATER
FIXTURES THEMSELVES. AND SO
THEY TORE OUT ALL FIXTURES AND
REPLACE THEM WITH NEW ONES THE
DISTRICT IS PLANNING TO
IMPLEMENT THE SCENE STRATEGY IN
THE REST OF IT SCHOOL. AND
OTHER DISTRICTS ARE FOLLOWING.
AT A TIME WHEN SCHOOL ARE I.
WORKING TO GET LET OUT OF THEIR
DRINKING. IT ALSO CRITICAL THAT
THE- AND FIXTURE ON THEM OUR-
FOR KIDS TO USE. YOU MUST.
OFFICE CAL. TO MEET THEM
LEACHING STAND. PROVIDES
INCLUDE CAMERAS WITH EASILY
COPPER. CLASSIC TRANSACTION.
OPTIONS THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE CAMPUS YOU CAN
EXPORT OF AB. ONE HUNDRED. VERY
GOOD. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM AND I DON'T SEE ANYONE-
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. AND THEN IS THERE A
VIDEO CONFERENCE A PERSON WHO
WOULD LIKE TO- TESTIFYING
SUPPORT WITH NAME AND-
IDENTIFICATION OF POSITION IF
SO SPEAK UP. ALL RIGHT- THEN
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE MR JERRY
DESMOND ON BEHALF OF THE
PLUMBING MANUFACTURERS
INTERNATIONAL- PLEASE PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
CHAIR HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR ME
WELL. I'M WELL ENOUGH. WELL
THANK YOU WELL IT UP CERTAINLY
CHAIRED MEMBERS- THIS IS JERRY
DOES NOT ALL BEHALF OF PLUMBING
MANUFACTURERS INTERNATIONAL OR
PMI AND TO THE MEMBERS OF PMI
PRODUCE ABOUT 90% OF THE
PLUMBING PRODUCTS IN THE UNITED
STATES SAID WE WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THE PMI SUPPORTS THE
LAUDABLE POLICY OBJECTIVE OF AB
ONE HUNDRED TOLD LOWERED THE
MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE AMOUNT OF
LEAD TO BE RELEASED DURING
PRODUCT TESTING PER OFFICE AND
OTHER ENDPOINT DEVICES THAT ARE
USED FOR PROVIDING DRINKING
WATER FROM THE CURRENT FIVE
MICROGRAMS TWO ONE MICHAEL
GRAHAM. IN COORDINATION WITH
THE STANDARD AT A SEPT FIFTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY HOWEVER WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
IMMEDIATE JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AFFECTED DATE OF THE
BILL FOR ALL PRODUCTS TO COMPLY
WITH THIS NEW STANDARD ITS NOT
POSSIBLE FOR ALL THOSE INVOLVED
IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN YOU KNOW
MANUFACTURERS CERTIFIERS
DISTRIBUTORS WHOLESALERS AND
RETAILERS TO MEET SUCH A TIME
FRAME THAT WOULD TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY WHEN AB ONE HUNDRED
WITH UP LAW. AND IT SHOULD ALSO
BE NOTED THERE ABOUT FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND MODELS THE FAUCET ON
THE MARKET PLACE TODAY SO IN
ORDER FOR THE OBJECTIVES OF
WHAT AB ONE HUNDRED TO BE
REALIZED WITHOUT CAUSING MAJOR
DISRUPTIONS TO CALIFORNIA'S
MARKETPLACE AND WIDESPREAD
CONSUMER DISSATISFACTION IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE ASPECT OF
THE DATE OF THE BILL FOR A 100%
OF THE PRODUCTS WE CHANGED TO
GENERATE ONE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. THIS AFFECTED DATA
CONSISTENT WITH RPMI SUPPORT
POSITION ON LAST YEAR VERSIONS
OF THIS MEASURE AB TWENTY SIXTY
BY A SEVEN MEMBER HOLDEN STEP
ALMOST CROSSED THE FINISH LINE
BUT WAS UNFORTUNATELY HELD ON
TO SPENT THAN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. I
SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE NEW
ONE MICROGRAM MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE
LEVEL A LEVEL OF LEAD PROPOSED
IN AB TWENTY SIXTY LAST YEAR
AND AB ONE HEIGHT THIS YEAR IS
BASED ON THE STANDARD ENDED UP
SIXTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY AS
PROMISED DURING OUR
COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSIONS ON
LAST YEAR'S MEASURE PMI
ADVOCATED FOR THE EXPEDITED
PUBLICATION OF THAT STANDARD.
AND THAT WAS IN CHIEF IN AUGUST
OF LAST YOUR- THAT DATE
MANUFACTURES OF THE GUN THE
PROPS F THE PRODUCTS THE WITH
THIS HAVING THEM EMPLOYEE THEM
INTO THE MARKET THESE PRODUCTS
HELLO HE AND ANNA THAT'S THE
ONE TWO FLAYED COMPOSED THAT
THEY MAKE THE AB WERE HUNDRED
STAY AND THERE ARE NUMBER
NUMBER AVAILABLE FOR SALE TODAY
INFORMATION ABOUT COMPLY
PRODUCTS ARE POSTED ONLINE BY
THE EIGHT OR NINE THIRD PARTY
CERTIFIERS THAT CERTIFY THESE
PRODUCTS. MOREWILL BECOME
AVAILABLE AS WE MOVE TOWARDS
TOWARD THE HEART OF THE FEC
COMPLIANCE BY JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY
ONE A NO PMI IS SUGGESTED THAT
IN ADDITION TO THE ONE ONE
TWENTY FOUR EFFECTIVE DATE A
PROVISION BE ADDED INCLUDED IN
AB ONE HUNDRED AS A BUTTON AB
TWENTY SIXTY TWO REQUIRED THAT
THE CONSUMER FACING PRODUCT
PACKAGING OR LABELING OF
PRODUCTS THAT COMPLY WITH THE
DEFINITION OF LEFT THREE
INDICATE THAT COMPLIANCE BY
INCLUDING THE END OF THE DAY UP
FIFTY ONE LETTERING IN AN
EASILY IDENTIFIABLE MATTER.
EDUCATION ABOUT THIS CURRENT
LABELED IMPORTANT AND PMI WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
NOTICE COMMITTEE AND THE CO
SPONSORS OF AB ONE HUNDRED THE
SUPPORTERS TO GET THE WORD OUT
WE ARE ALSO ENGAGING NOW TO
EDUCATE THE CHILD CARE CENTERS
SCHOOLS AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC
ON HOW TO IDENTIFY THE NSF
SIXTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY LABEL
TO ENSURE THAT THEY PURCHASE
COMPLIANT. PRODUCT THANK YOU-
THANK YOU SIR- MR HOLDEN BEFORE
I ASK FOR ANY OTHER COMMENTS
WOULD YOU WANT TO WOULD. THE
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
ISSUE. YES THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE WE'RE
CERTAINLY. WILLING TO WORK ON
THAT DATE- AND PROBABLY COME TO
A REAL AGREEMENT ON IT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THOUGH IS
ENSURE THAT THERE'S LABELING-
THAT IS ESTABLISHED SO THAT'S
EASILY UNDERSTOOD TERMS OF THE
NATURE OF THE PRODUCT. AND THAT
BE DONE FOR THE LOWER LEACHING
PRODUCTS SO I THINK WE CAN SORT
OF GET THEIR- BUT WE HAVEN'T
GOT THERE COMPLETELY UP WITH
THE LABELING ISSUE FOR PUTTING
IT OUT THERE SOONER THAN LATER
I THINK THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE PUBLIC DOLLARS. ARE
CURRENTLY BEING SPENT- FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND CHILDCARE
CENTRES AND THEY'RE OUT THERE
BUYING THE PRODUCT AND JUST
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S- CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH IN THE LABELING
THAT. THAT THERE I THINK
REFERRING TO IS VERY HARD TO
UNDERSTAND A VERY HARD TO. DRAW
THE CONCLUSION OF WHAT THAT IS-
CLEARLY REFERENCING SO WE ARE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO MOVING BACK
TO THE TWENTY FOUR DATE BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE GET
THE PROPER LABELING OUT SOONER
THAN LATER. VERY GOOD- SO I
DON'T SEE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO IS GOING TO TESTIFY- IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE VIDEO CONFERENCE AREA TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. IF SO
JUST SPEAK UP. OKAY THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION- AND PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD
OPERATOR. THANK YOU TO STATE
YOUR POSITION ON THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE A FEW LINES IN
Q. WE CAN GO FIRST TO LINE
FORTY EIGHT. LINE FORTY EIGHT
AIRLINES OPEN. THE CHAIR
MEMBERS JUSTIN MALONE ON BEHALF
OF THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS. LEAD POISONING
IS A CRITICAL ISSUE FOR OUR
KIDS- WE ARE JUST SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE TWO
ADDITIONAL LINES IN Q. I
APOLOGIZE IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. WE HAVE A
STATEMENT FROM LINE ONE OH ONE
ONE HUNDRED ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD MORNING MELISSA HI FI ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION AND THE COURT THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
FIFTEEN ONE ONE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS JENNIFER
WILLIAMS WITH EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OPERATOR-
I'D SAY MISTER MATHIS PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND THANK YOU MY FIRST
YEAR MISTER CHAIR ALL ALL MAKE
MY COMMENTS. WE CAN BRIEF- DO
THE SECOND TIME MR HOLDEN I
TRULY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING WITH THIS ENDEAVOR. OF
THE FACT THAT WE'RE STILL
DEALING WITH FLOODING ISSUES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA- BY FRANKLY
IS RIDICULOUS AND I WANT TO
PARTNER WITH YOU ON THIS AND BE
YOUR YOUR JOINT AUTHORS SHOW
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WITH
THAT. DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE HERE BUT LET'S GET
THIS ONE ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
THANKS. JUST UP WITH YOUR
COMMENT FOR THE AMENDMENTS OF
GOING TO TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
FOUR. AND WOULD LOVE TO SUPPORT
IT WITH YOU TO. TO GET IT DONE
ALL THE WAY ACROSS THE BOARD SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO SAY YES. AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN AGREE TO THOSE
STATES CHANGES.
SEVENTY FIVE- A LAST TIME THANK
YOU. OKAY SO. I GUESS IT'S TIME
TO CLOSE. I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND I
AGAIN THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
MOVING THIS SIMILAR BILL OUT
LAST YEAR AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
THANK OKAY SO- OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF WILL BE WORKING WITH THE
AND I AS WELLWILL BE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS-
TO RESOLVE THESE LAST COUPLE OF
ISSUES- THE AUTHOR HAS SAID IN
THE- OPPOSITION IS SAID THEY'RE
WILLING TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
COME UP WITH A UNDERSTANDABLE
CONSUMER FRIENDLY LABEL AND WE
WILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT- THAT
THIS CAN HAPPEN WE WILL
DEFINITELY WORK TO DO THIS. I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE FOR
THOSE OF US WHO ARE LEFT- SO
HAVE WE HAD A MOTION. YES OKAY
GOOD THEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
ITEM SEVEN AB ONE HUNDRED
HOLDEN THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS AND. I SMITH SMITH HI
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN DALLY
GARCIA HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I.
MATHIS HI MATHIS I WENT OUT TO
CHEAT WE HAVE FOUR VOTE SO WE
NEED TO- HAVE ADD ONS FOR THE
OKAY- AT THIS POINT I'M
SUPPOSED TO PRESENT A BILL
HOWEVER. THANK YOU- WE NEED TO
GET MORE OF THE COMMITTEE HERE
SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS ASK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHEREVER YOU
ARE WE'RE GONNA DO ADD ONS.
AND- WELL WE NEED FOR NUMBER
THE BILLS WERE GONNA NEED
ADDITIONAL VOTES SO I WOULD ASK
YOU TO COME HERE NOW I'M GONNA
WAIT ABOUT TILL ABOUT TWELVE
FIFTEEN- AND THEN IF WE HAVE
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM LIKE TO
CONTINUE WITH I'D LIKE TO START
MY TESTIMONY. SO AGAIN- YEAH IF
IT IF FIVE PEOPLE NEED TO TAKE
A BREAK RIGHT NOW AND JUST BE
BACK AT TWELVE FIFTEEN. THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THIS ROOM
RIGHT NOW I'VE BEEN HERE FOR
THE WHOLE PROCEEDING THAT WE
WILL NEED TO GET THE OTHER
PEOPLE HERE. CHAU TILL.
TWELVE
FIFTEEN. OKAY AND WE HAVE-
HI
IS NOT WORK FORTY TWO HUNDRED.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT. THEY
MIGHT BE THREE. BUT OH GOSH IT
MISERABLY HOT YOU JUST LIKE RUN
YOUR AIR CONDITIONED CAR INTO A
STORE OR SEE DETECTED RIGHT
BECAUSE IT'S SO. THE PERSON-
YEAH- YEAH. THE THIRTY DO.
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE. YEAH. WELL
THIS THE THREE OKAY OKAY THANK.
OKAY WILL BE BACK IN SESSION
ENOUGH MISTER KIRK I INVITE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL AB THREE OH
FOR ALL RIGHT MOVING THE BILL
OKAY. VERY GOOD THANK YOU- VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB THREE OH
FOUR. REVISED STATE OVERSIGHT
AND STATE REQUIREMENTS FOR
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
OVERSEEING THE CLEANUP OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE SITES. AB THREE
OH FOUR HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE- I WILL ADD THAT. WE HAVE
THIS BILL UP TWO YEARS AGO AND
I HAD SAID IF THERE IS-
OPPOSITION FROM THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS ALTHOUGH THE
BILL UP THE BILL WAS HELD UP WE
WORK THINGS OUT. AND WE'RE NOT
GOING FORWARD WITH A CONSENSUS-
LET'S SEE DO I HAVE ANY
WITNESSES. NOPE AT THE- OKAY AT
THIS TIME ALLEN INVITE THE
PUBLIC IN A HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE. ALL INVITE THE
PUBLIC ON THE TELEPHONE LINES.
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN UP. JESUS
TO STATE YOUR POSITION ON THIS
BILL ME PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION ME PRESS
ONE THEN LIBERAL AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO COMMENTS
IN Q. LEFT FOR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OR DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE SCREEN.
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM VIDEO
CONFERENCE. SEEING NOT I'LL
INVITE THE AUTHOR TO CLOSE. ALL
RIGHT- YES FOR COMMITTEE
COMMENTS- ALL RIGHT HOW CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LIKE TO
QUICKLY DO SAID LIKE TO GO ON A
STRONG AUTHOR WITH YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS.
SURE ALL RIGHT. THANK ARE LESS
AUTHORED TO CLOSE AT THIS TIME-
THANK YOU AND- PLEASE GIVE ME
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU I KNOW
SNEAKING IN CAPE. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WILL HAVE A
ROLL CALL MADAM SECRETARY.
THANK YOU THIS IS ITEM EIGHT AB
THREE ZERO FOUR CORK FOUNDATION
IS DO YOU PASS AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FOR. CORK HI SMITH HI SMITH I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI OUR QUE
HAN. DALY AYE DALY AYE GARCIA.
HOLDEN HOLDEN I. MATHIS HI
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI WHEN I TO
XII. WE HAVE SEVEN VOTE SO
THAT'S OUT THERE MOVE ON TO
PROVIDE. THANK YOU. TECH
CALLING THE BILLS- THAT ARE. SO
THAT THOSE WHO ARE ABSENT CAN
ADD ON. LEAVE IT OPEN. HEY
MISTER CORRECT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL SEVEN
THIRTY TWO- I DON'T THINK
THERE'S TIME RIGHT NOW IF I
HAVE TO LEAVE AT TWELVE THIRTY.
OKAY WHICH IS. IS THAT CORRECT
THAT I HAVE TO LEAVE AT TWELVE
THIRTY. ONE SO I COULD STAY
UNTIL ONE. ALL RIGHT WELL THEN
I WILL PRESENT MY BILL. ALL
RIGHT- OKAY OF. SO THIS IS A B.
SEVEN THREE TWO- IT THE- AND
IT'S ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL-
THEY'LL- SO- VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL INCREASES THE
AMOUNT OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
FEE. NOR CLOSE A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT OF THE TOXIC SUBSTANCE
YOU ARE TROUT ACT. THIS FEE
INCREASE IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
STABLE FUNDING FOR THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM AND
THE SITE MITIGATION PROGRAM
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL. WELL THE
GOVERNOR HAS INTRODUCED A
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT ALSO
INCREASES THE ENVIRONMENTAL
FEE. I INTRODUCED THIS BILL
BECAUSE THERE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT POLICY ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH. WITHIN DURING
WITH ENSURING THAT DTS SHE HAS
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO REFILL
ITS- STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS ONE
PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR THAT IS
FUNDED BY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
FEE. IS A SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM WHICH WE REFER
TO A NUMBER OF TIMES BOY. I
LOST MY AUDIENCE THANK YOU- THE
IDEA OF THIS PROGRAM IS GREAT-
SCIENTIFIC LOOK AT CHEMICAL
PRODUCTS HOWEVER WE BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION OF NOT PROPERLY
FUNDED THE PROGRAM WE DON'T
PROBABLY FUND THIS PROGRAM WE
WILL ABSOLUTELY MISS OUT ON AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A WORLD
CLASS PRODUCT CHEMICAL
EVALUATION PROGRAM. DITION LES
THE ENVIRONMENTAL FEE FUNDS THE
CLEANUP OF CONTAMINATED SITES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. DGSE IS
HUNDREDS OF THE STATE'S WITH
SITES WITHIN THE DATABASE. THAT
THEY MAY KNOW ABOUT BUT LACKS
THE RESOURCES TO EITHER
INVESTIGATE FURTHER OR TO
INITIATE A CLEAN UP. IT HAS
BEEN ESTIMATED BY THE U. S. EPA
THAT THERE MIGHT BE AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONTAMINATED SITES IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE WERE NOT
CURRENTLY AWARE OF WHO WE NEED
A STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING TO
INVESTIGATE THESE SITES AND
ULTIMATELY RESTORE THE SITES TO
PRODUCTIVE USE. THIS IS A TAX
AND- IT WILL NEED TO BE-
ENACTED WITH A TWO THIRDS VOTE-
IF WE ARE ABLE TO PROPERLY FUND
THESE PROGRAMS HUNDRED DS-
UNDER DGSE- THE ONLY WAY TO DO
IT IS TO RAISE A TAX. SOEONE
HAS A BETTER PROPOSAL TO REVIVE
A STABLE FUND STABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR THESE PROGRAMS IS
NOT A TAX. THEN PLEASE DO SO
UNTIL THEN I THINK WE NEED TO
WORK WITH WHAT WE HAVE AND THAT
IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL FEE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
I'LL INVITE THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO TESTIFY. SEEING
NONE IN SUPPORT. ANY PUBLIC IN
A ROOM FOR OPPOSITION. KCA
NONETHELESS A FOR MODERATOR IF
THERE'S ANYWITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN THIRTY
TWO. YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION
AND AB SEVEN THIRTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD HMI PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. DO YOU TURN
ONLINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THE NEW QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES SIR. SO
MISTER CHAIRMAN I- GIVE YOU A
HEADS UP THAT I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS AND MY CONCERN WAS-
DISCUSSED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WHERE. THE GOVERNOR.
IS PROPOSING. A MAJOR REFORM TO
THE FEE STRUCTURE ALSO- WHICH
INCLUDES THE CHANGES TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL THREE. AND- THE
PROPOSAL. PERMANENTLY
ELIMINATES A FEE FOR BUSINESSES
WITH LAWSON HUNDRED EMPLOYEES.
I GUESS THIRD DEFINITION OF
SMALL BUSINESSES FREEZES THE
FEE FOR BUSINESSES WITH THE
HUNDRED TO FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
NINE. I'M MORE THAN TROUBLES A
FEE FOR BUSINESSES WITH FIVE
HUNDRED MORE EMPLOYEES WHICH I
THINK IT'S BEEN. IF NOT THE
TRYING TO LEASE TO. THIRD
THERE'S BEEN GREATER CALLS FOR.
YOU KNOW LARGE CORPORATIONS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO PAY
OFF. THEIR FAIR SHARE- AND TO
TRY TO HELP OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE-
SO GIVEN THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED IN THIS- WHY SHOULD I
SUPPORT YOUR BILL. GOOD
QUESTION THE ANSWER IS- I THAT
FIRST OF ALL IF WE DO IT- IF WE
DO THAT THE FEE BECOMES MUCH
LARGER APPROACH MY STAFF HAS
THE EXACT NUMBER BUT THE FEE
BECOMES MUCH LARGER ON THE
BIGGER COMPANIES. IF IT'S A
CONSENSUS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
THEY PREFERRED THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH- I'M PERFECTLY HAPPY
TO DO THAT AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WE'RE DOING THIS. IS
THAT WHILE YOU CAN SAYTHAT
THIS IS A TAX IT IS BUT IT'S
ALSO POLICY CONSIDERATIONS BOTH
IN TERMS OF. WHO PAYS AS WELL
AS- HOW THE MONEY IS USED IN
THIS IS A WORTHWHILE- USE OF
THE MONEY AND THAT WHAT I WANT
TO FIND FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IS DO THEY FEEL THIS IS A
WORTHWHILE USE- WOULD THEY
PREFER THE GOVERNOR'S APPROACH.
AND THEN FINALLY IS THERE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO ASSURE THE MONEY IS
BEING USED PROPERLY. WE HEARD
EARLIER FROM THE- SECRETARY AND
THE DEPARTMENT HAD- THAT THEY
ARE GOING TO HAVE METRICS AND
OTHER THINGS. MY QUESTION FOR-
THE COMMITTEE IS- ARE YOU READY
TO SUPPORT THAT YOU NEED TO GET
MORE INFORMATION FIRST LIKE
WHAT THE METRICS WOULD BE. BUT
THAT'S THE REASON FOR BRINGING
THIS FORTH NOW AND I'D LIKE TO
KNOW YOUR OPINION AND YOU
CLEARLY SEEM TO PREFER AT THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROACH AND- I'D
LIKE TO HEAR FROM OTHER MEMBERS
AS WELL- DO YOU FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THE- BILL
OTHERWISE. WELL I THINK- WE
ALL. APPRECIATE HAVING GOT. A
LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE TO ENSURE
THAT TO. THAT WE CAN HAVE
THESE- NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE- BUT IN THIS CASE IT
SEEMS LIKE OUR LEGISLATIVE
VEHICLE WOULD BE THE BUDGET
BILL- AND SO I- I WOULD PREFER
THAT- WE FOCUS THAT-
NEGOTIATIONS. ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FEE THROUGH THE
BUDGET BILL- RATHER THAN THIS
BILL OKAY IF THIS BILL DOES NOT.
PROVIDE ANY FURTHER POLICY
GUIDANCE BEYOND WHAT WE WOULD
WE COULD- INSERTED INTO THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI. ON THE TO DO WHAT
THE BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
ONLY TESTIMONY ONLY THERE'S NO
VOTE I HAVE A MESSAGE WILL BE
TESTIMONIAL K. AND MR HOLDEN
HAS TO LEAVE TO BECAUSE HE'S
GOT A TWELVE OKAY. FIND GO
AHEAD PLEASE THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR I'M THANK YOU MR CLARK
FOR PRESENTING THIS AS YOU
HEARD MY QUESTION EARLIER TO-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRACIE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION MY CONCERN IS IF
WE ARE INCREASING FEES IF WE
ARE IMPOSING THIS TAX ON
CORPORATIONS AND BUSINESSES
THAT WE ENSURE THAT WE ARE
DOING SO TO A DEPARTMENT THAT
IS ACTUALLY DOING THEIR JOB
RIGHT AND I THINK MANY OF US ON
THIS COMMITTEE FEEL LIKE
CURRENTLY THAT'S NOT. THE CASE
THE DGSE AND SO THROWING MORE
MONEY AT AN AGENCY THAT WE
DON'T BELIEVE IS ADEQUATELY
PERFORMING FEELS. THE BEST
CHOICE NECESSARILY- BUT I ALSO
HEAR WHAT THE AGENCY SAID IN
THEIR NEED FOR MORE RESOURCES
TO DO THE JOB. AND THAT YOU
KNOW HAVING NOT READ THE SEASON
DECADES THAT THAT'S AN INTEGRAL
PART OF ENSURING THAT THIS THE
AGENCY IS FUNCTIONING. BUT I.
SHARE WHAT YOU JUST SAID ABOUT
WANTING TO HEAR FROM US ABOUT
WHAT IT IS WE NEED. AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE SECRETARY
SAID BUT IN MY QUESTION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION I ASKED WHAT ARE
THE SPECIFIC METRICS HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO SHOW US. THAT IF
WE GIVE YOU THIS MONEY YOU ARE
PERFORMING IN YES EVERY TIME
THERE IS IF YOU HAVE TO COME
BACK BUT THE FIRST TIME WE
RAISE THAT FEE WE'RE DOING IT
SOMEWHAT IN BLIND FAITH THAT
THIS IS GONNA. THAT THEY WILL
START PERFORMING AND DOING THE
WORK THAT BUSINESSES NEED THEM
TO DO AND TO THE POINT THAT A
FAMILY MEMBER GARCIA MADE. YOU
KNOW IF SOMEBODY HASN'T GOTTEN
THEIR PERMITS SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THEY CAN'T OPERATE
IN THE WAY THEY WANT TO OPERATE
SO THERE IS INCENTIVES TO THE
BUSINESSES TO ONE DGSE TO WORK
GREAT THEY CAN BETTER. DO THEIR
JOB IF THE CHASSIS IS- HELPING
THEM DO IT SO. I SEE THE
BENEFIT OF IT BUT I THINK THAT
WHAT I REALLY NEED IS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT METRICS ARE IN
PLACE. WHEN WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THEM I WANT TO SEE YOU KNOW THE
SECRETARY SPOKE EARLIER ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND SITES THAT
HAVE YET TO BE CLEANED UP OKAY.
ARE WE GOING TO SEE. TEN
THOUSAND A MONTH THINK WE ARE
WE GONNA SEE TWENTY THOUSAND A
YEAR WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
CHECK THOSE WE'RE GIVING YOU
THIS MONEY WE EXPECT
PERFORMANCE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THOSE METRICS. AND I THINK
THAT'S THE KEY TO FEELING
COMFORTABLE GIVING THEM
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IS KNOWING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THOSE
METRICS THAT THEY WILL BE
FORCED TO PERFORM THEM. AND
THAT WE ARE GOING TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE OKAY SO WHAT I WILL
OFFER IS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO WANT TO HEAR
MORE. IS IT WE TRY AND GET A
MEETING- QUICKLY- AND GET THE
DISCUSSION OF METRICS AND OTHER
THINGS THAT WILL GIVE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- CONFIDENCE.
AND OF COURSE WE ALSO THE FACT
THAT THEY NOW. A BOARD. AND THE
EXTENT TO WHICH YOU FEEL THAT
THAT ALSO WOULD INCREASE YOUR
CONFIDENCE. CAN I ASK TO THAT.
PART OF THE PROBLEM WAS AND
WORK THEY HAVE TO DO AND HOW
THEY HAVE BEEN USING THE
DOLLARS AND SO THE WORK LOAD
ANALYSIS THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED
TO US ACTUALLY GIVES US A RANGE
WHERE IT TALKS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS IF WE HAVE THIS AMOUNT
OF MONEY WHAT CAN WE DO AND HOW
QUICKLY CAN WE GET TO THE
SITES- AND THE RANGES ANYWHERE
FROM YOU KNOW TEN YEARS TO A
HUNDRED YEARS DEPENDING AT THE
PACE THAT WILL WORKING AND- AT
THE CURRENT PACE AT WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO SUCCEED TO BE HUNDRED
TWO YEARS- THAT THOSE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO LIVE- AND THIS
POLLUTION SO. I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S MORE WORK THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE AND THAT IN ITSELF DOES
NOT GIVE US THE ASSURANCES THAT
WE NEED- ANYTHING GIVEN THE
HISTORY OF THE AGENCY IT'S HARD
TO SAY HERE'S SOME MONEY- BUT I
THINK THAT THIS IS WHERE WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT THE
GOVERNANCE REFORMS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY. THE ROLE OF THE
BORDERS I THINK WELL THERE'S AN
AGREEMENT ON THE BOARD THE ROLE
OF THE BOARD TO HAVE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY ARE YOU STILL
DETAILS THAT ARE BEING
DISCUSSED AND SO AS WE DO THE
WORK IT'S BEEN CLEAR TO WAS
THAT IS NOT. ONE WITHOUT THE
OTHER WE HAVE TO DO BOTH. THANK
YOU FOR. VERY GOOD. IT DIDN'T.
PRETTY MUCH MY COMMENTS. SAME
THING. ATTACK EVER BUSINESSES
ARE. PUBLIC WHAT DO. GET FOR
THAT MONEY THAT. YOU'RE BEING.
FOR SO I'D LIKE TO SEE SOME
MORE DISCUSSION. TO SEE IF WE
CAN NARROW DOWN IT'S GOING TO
BE THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY. THIS
COULD BE USED FOR THIS. AND
THERE'S IN RESULTS THAT WE CAN
SEE AT THE VERY END. AND IT'S
NOT. TEN YEARS DOWN THE ROAD.
YEAH WELL LET'S TRY AND FIND A
WAY. TO EITHER MEET AS A
COMMITTEE OR IF WE CAN'T GET
THEM. MEDIAN AN INFORMAL
MEETING- TO GET INFORMATION-
WE- IF WE DO IT INFORMALLY OF
COURSE WE'VE- WE- YOU HAVE TO
BE CAREFUL OF. WHAT WE DO BUT
IF IT'S STRICTLY. FOR
INFORMATION WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DO THAT- I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS BUT
IT'S VERY CLEAR WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO ME AND I'LL TAKE THAT AS
MY CLOTHES PERFECT THANK YOU
NOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME BACK
UP THE CLOSING MEETING OR EARLY
DOCTOR ARAMBULA- IT WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN. I ABOUT. TO GET VOTES
IN THE MEAN- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE START THE PROCESS. SAID
AND THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE THE VOTE EIGHT
ZERO- MORE DEBT TO G. HI. WHAT
I TO XII SO NOW THAT'S OUT AT.
NINE ZERO. I AM WE NEED DOCTOR
ROB ARAMBULA- ITEM THREE AS
WELL. FOR AS WELL. FIVE OKAY SO
ITEM SIX. IT'S AB TWELVE
HUNDRED THE VOTE IS THAT THREE
ZERO. ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN. OUR
QUE HAN I DALLY WHAT I TO GI
WHAT I TO GI SO WITH THOSE TWO
VOTES IT DOES PASS OUT. WE DO
HAVE TO ADD ON. A COUPLE OF
MEMBERS THE NEXT BILL IS ITEM
SEVEN. THE VOTE IS AT FOUR
ZERO. AB ONE HUNDRED ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I. OUR QUE HAN OUR K.
NINE DALLY. CRISTINA GARCIA HI
CRISTINA GARCIA I. WHAT TO
CHECK I WITH A TO G. S. SO THAT
BRINGS OF UP TO EIGHT ZERO.
OKAY ITEM EIGHT AB THREE OH
FOUR QUIRK THE VOTE IS AT SEVEN
ZERO OUR QUE HAN. BAUER-KAHAN
HI CRISTINA GARCIA HI CRISTINA
GARCIA HI AND THAT BRINGS THE
VOTE TO NINE ZERO SO THAT ONE'S
OUT COMPLETELY.THANK. YES. SO
WE ARE- I WILL GO THROUGH
DOCTOR ON THE LIST HERE- ITEM
NUMBER TWO. IS AB TWELVE FIFTY
CALDERON THE VOTERS AT EIGHT
ZERO ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI SO
THAT BRINGS THAT TO NINE ZERO
THAT'S OUT. GEN ITEM THREE
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY THE VOTE IS
AT FIVE ONE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
HI. THAT BRINGS THAT VOTE TO
SIX ONE. I ITEM FOR. NOBODY
THAT. FIVE ONE. THAT'S AB SIX
FIVE TWO FRIEDMAN ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I. ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
AB SEVEN SIXTY TO LEAD ARAMBULA
SIX ZERO. THE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
ARAMBULA IT'S I'M SORRY AB
TWELVE HUNDRED TANK. AB TWELVE
HUNDRED TANKS ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
I. AND THAT BILL HAS PASSED OUT
OR IT JUST ADDING ON. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN. IS YOU YOU VOTED
SO YOU'RE DONE WE'RE WAITING ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DELHI. OKAY DR
ARAMBULA ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY.
THE COMMITTEE AGREED THAT THEY
NEED MORE INFORMATION ON THE
TAX. SO WE WILL- WILL IT EITHER
ARRANGE AN INFORMAL MEETING
WHERE WE CAN GET MORE
INFORMATION OR IDEALLY
COMMITTEE MEETING- BUT THE
POINT IS TO LOOK CRITICALLY AT
METRICS TO ASSURE THE MONEY IS
BEING SPENT ALSO LOOKING AT THE
AMOUNT OF THE TAX WHAT CAN THEY
DO WITH VARIOUS LEVELS- AND- TO
ADD ON AN ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
FOUR EIGHTY GUARDRAIL THE BILL
HAS PASSED OUT BUT DALY. NOBODY
DALY IS NOT VOTING. I ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. IS AB SIX FIFTY
TWO FRIEDMAN. AGAIN THAT BILL
HAS PASSED OUT DALY. FRIEDMAN
IT'S M. A. B. SIX FIVE TWO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR FRIEDMAN. MY FOR IS
OKAY IT'S OKAY- NOT READY.
FRIEDMAN. IT IT IS A FRIEDMAN-
BILL DALLY NOT VOTING CORRECT
YES DALY NOT VOTING. I ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IS AB SEVEN SIXTY
TWO WE HAVE A- DALY NOT VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWELVE
HUNDRED TANG. NO. DALLY NO NO
GALLIANO. AND LAST ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB ONE HUNDRED HOLDEN
DALY NAVALNY DALY NOT VOTING
OKAY. WELL EVERYBODY IS ADDED
ON- WE FIVE FINISHED OUR
DISCUSSION- THE COMMITTEE HAS
EXPRESSED AN INTEREST IN MORE
INFORMATION ON THE TAX MEASURE
AND WE WILL BE GETTING THAT- I
NOW CLOSE THE MEETING.